як працює Піза програма міжнародного
оцінювання
учнів хоча Піза і була започаткована
організацією економічного
співробітництва та розвитку з осередком
у Парижі Однак до підготовки дослідження
долучаються освітні експерти з усього
світу насправді з часу заснування
програми у 2000 році кожна з понад 80
країн економік учасниць дослідження
сприяла його розвитку найкращі
представники цих країн створювали Тести
які могли б складати підлітки з усього
світу дослідження з'ясовує Якою мірою
підлітки можуть використовувати те що
вони вивчили в школі для виконання
завдань реального життя галузями
дослідження є природничо-наукові
дисципліни математика читання а також
деякі інші інноваційні галузі наприклад
спільне виконання завдань або фінансова
грамотність країни самі ініціюють свою
участь у
дослідженні якщо вся країна не може
взяти участі в такому масштабному
дослідженні долучитися до Піза можуть
окре її регіони коли участь країни в
дослідженні погоджує керівна рада Піза
формують перелік закладів учасників
учнів обирають випадковим чином так щоб
вони представляли всю систему освіти
були
15тирічними навчалися в сьомому або
старших класах підлітки складають тест
мовою якою
навчаються учнів не просять відтворювати
дати чи імена вивчені в школі
натомість Вони мають використати знання
і вміння щоб інтерпретувати тексти
розв'язувати математичні задачі чи
пояснювати певні природні явища з
наукового погляду за результатами
дослідження Учні не отримують
індивідуальних оцінок але їхні здобутки
стають частиною усереднених даних усієї
країни незважаючи на гучні публікації
які з'являються кожні три роки коли
оголошують результати дослідження Піза
не створена для рейтингування країн Це
дослідження показує те чи стають заклади
освіти більш або менш ефективними в
підготовці своїх учнів до подальшого
навчання чи до ринку праці це
дослідження про те чи сформовані в
15-тирічних підлітків соціальні емоційні
вміння які їм доведеться застосовувати в
житті як от уміння спілкуватися чи
працювати з іншими людьми а ще Піза про
те як резуль ути оцінювання стають
мільйонами одиниць даних які необхідно
скласти для того щоб побачити образ
найбільш ефективних систем освіти
загалом ефективні системи - це ті які
дають широкі можливості для навчання і
найміцнішу підтримку в реалізації свого
потенціалу всім дітям а не тільки тим
які мають гарні передумови для навчання
Піза має на меті не тільки показати те
які це системи Алей підтримати країни в
прагненні навчитися з досвіду таких
систем вибудовувати більш справедливу та
інклюзивну
освіту
Добрий день шановні друзі Добрий день
глядачі і глядачки я вітаю вас сьогодні
на презентації вітчизняного звіту про
результати міжнародного дослідження
якості освіти Піза 2022 року мені
надзвичайно приємно бачити вас усіх у
залі а також сподіваюся що ви мене
бачите в онлайні десь власне перш ніж ми
почнемо говорити про результати цього
дослідження перш ніж ми говоритимемо про
те А що власне робити в українській
освіті з огляду на ці
результати Мені здається що я скажу
очевидні речі ми маємо
Подякувати І вшанувати пам'ять тих
тих хто своїм
життям
своїм тілом у душею робить так щоб ми
могли мріяти
планувати діяти і сподіватися на те
що десь
там в мирній Україні майбутнього ми
матимемо якісну освіту і незалежну
територію я прошу вшанувати хвилиною
мовчання наших воїнів
[музика]
Дякую дорогі друзі Настав час говорити
про результати дослідження і тепер я маю
честь представити в першу чергу себе
адже я тут з вами буду впродовж усього
дня Мене звати Тетяна Вакуленко я на
національна координаторка міжнародного
дослідження якості освіти Піза в Україні
і також директорка українського центру
оцінювання якості освіти власне Вся
Україна всі міжнародні партнери
дивуються тому наскільки фантастично
цифровими ми є яких величезних досягнень
ми досягли в цій сфері є людина яка
перетворює мрії у дії і я попрошу цю
людину доєднатися до нас в онлайні і
привітати вас із з тим що сьогодні ми
презентуємо результати дослідження
Дякую Вітаю презентація результатів
міжнародного дослідження якості освіти
Піза 2022 важлива і своєчасна подія
разом з мон Ми продовжуємо працювати над
трансформацією освіти лише на основі
реальних даних можна ухвалювати
ефективні управлінські рішення одним із
джерел такої інформації і є дослідження
Піза ці дані описують нинішній стан
системи освіти і в цьому їхня
беззаперечна цінність для мене особисто
є дуже знаковим сам факт участі України
в дослідженні у 2022 році після початку
повномасштабного вторгнення останні роки
були надважкими для всієї системи освіти
ковід повномасштабна війна перехід на
навчання в онлайні чи уроки в укриттях
це відображається на динаміці та
досягненнях наших учнів у різних сферах
щоб підвищити якість освіти ми
виокремили стратегічні фокуси
трансформації перший - створити умови в
яких діти безпечно навчаються в очному
або змішаному форматі другий позбутися
радянського минулого і перетворити школи
на місця які стимулюють творчість та
інновації третій - зробити вчителів
рокзірками які запалюють дітей для цього
потрібно змінити моделі та рівень оплати
праці вчителів економічне диво неможливе
без освітнього дива тому наша ціль у
результатах Піза 2025 побачити що
якнайбільше дітей з різних регіонів
отримали доступ до якісної освіти це
буде важливим інструментом оцінки наших
дій зараз усім бажаю плідних
дискусій Я гадаю що пан Михайло Михайло
Федоров він власне дав заряд нашому
сьогоднішньому Заходу Я сподіваюся що ми
будемо більше говорити не про те Які
результати маємо тому що безперечно ці
результати не всіх сьогодні влаштують у
позитивному сенсі А будемо говорити про
те А що з цими робити правда і людина
яка може як найкраще насправді говорити
про те А що з цимцим робити людина яка
очолює Міністерство освіти і науки
України е це саме той е це саме та
людина яка гарантує те що результати
міжнародного дослідження будуть
використані для того щоби наша освіта
стала кращою сильнішою і щоби ми жодний
спосіб не боялися завтра а думали про те
як досягти цих високих нових результатів
Дякую Оксана
Лісовий шановні
друзі Я не погоджусь з тим що я можу
якнайкраще говорити Що з цим робити Я
переконаний в тому що в залі
знаходиться дуже багато людей які є
експертами дуже глибокими експертами і
саме на нашому з вами експертному колі і
лежить відповідальність за знаходження
тих рішень які потрібні Україні сьогодні
і українському суспільству і українській
молоді для того щоб наша освіта стала
е більш якісною для того щоб Вона
подолала ті виклики які постали перед
нами і для того щоб результати
ее досліджень наступного циклу е Пізи
стали
мали позитивну динаміку але перш за все
для
мене є один такий дуже масивний
позитивний сигнал в цьому дослідженні це
сам факт його
проведення тому що ми мабуть Єдина
країна Таня підтверд
спростуй яка проводила таке дослідження
під час повномасштабної війни на своїй
території це про нашу з вами впертість
про нашу з вами стійкість про нашу з
вами впевненість в тому що ми побудуємо
нашу
державу
демократичною вільною успішною
економічно процвітаючою це про нашу з
вами про наші з вами цінності про те що
людина Для нас це головне і найважливіше
це про те що ми будуємо країну і воюємо
за країну для людини і тому ми проводили
це дослідження під час війни і тому наші
освітяни наші наша батьківська спільнота
наші організації освітні робили це під
обстрілами і під час постійного масового
терору цивільного населення
України тому це великий успіх Тому це
вселяє оптимізмі в певних
в тому що ми зможемо подолати ті виклики
які ми зараз маємо і це знову ж таки про
те що ми маємо дані верифіковані дані
які дозволяють нам формувати і будувати
стратегії знаходити шукати і знаходити
рішення які базуються на об'єктивній
реальності тому шановні друзі Я вас
вітаю з цією презентацією попри те що
вона десь якісь показники її будуть нас
засмучувати десь вселяти тривогу але
саме головне самий головний сигнал
звичайно безумовно позитивний наша
система освіти працює наше вчительство
працює наші діти навчаються наші школи
функціонують і вселяють нашим дітям
впевненість і віру в завтрашній день
отже
отже вдруге Україна взяла участь у Пізі
жовтень 22го року українські школярі
попри всі виклики взяли участь в
дослідженні двогодинне тестування з
математики читання природничо-наукових
дисциплін і креативного мислення
загальна кількість учасників
3676 700
3876 учнів 164 заклади освіти взяли
участь у дослідженні водночас Як ви
бачите на мапі
е-а
у нас лише 18 областей взяли участь не
всі
регіони брали участь в
дослідженні Це ті регіони в яких було
безпечно проводити тестування
анкетування учнів в закладах освіти
зважаючи на воєнні виклики з огляду на
це будь-які порівняння результатів
українських 15-тирічних учнів з циклами
18-го року треба робити з огляду на це і
з
обережністю м хочу нагадати яким у нас
був жовтень 22-го року для школярів для
вчителів для всього суспільства це
восьмий місяць повномасштабного
вторгнення тривоги обстріли відключення
світла вже розпочались тоді на той
момент 20% учнів навчалися очно Решта в
дистанційному або змішаному форматі
пов'язано це було з питанням безпеки
звичайно і наявністю облаштованих
укриттів на той момент показник був 70
від забезпечення укриттям але крім цього
був ще й психологічний Фактор батьки
багато батьків ще тоді боялися
відпускати дітей до шкіл для порівняння
на слайді бачите статистику За 23-й рік
у понад два рази збільшилася кількість
дітей які навчаються очно і майже на 20%
шкіл більше мають уже облаштовані
укриття і цей процес триває і зараз і
буде тривати в наступному році
е-е
що мене вразило особисто це те що
тестування з Пізи підлітки проходили
взагалі 10 жовтня це якщо пам'ятаєте той
день коли саме Київ піддавався
масованому ракетному обстрілу це той
день коли було пошкоджено суттєво
пошкоджено одна із будівель Міністерства
освіти яка До сих пір
ремонтується
це доси досить складний день і тим не
менше Незважаючи на це діти пройшли
тестування і що цікаво як показали
результати дослідження рівень
задоволеності життям українських дітей
доволі
високий крім цього переважна більшість
дітей які взяли участь у Піза
почуваються в безпеці у своїх закладах
освіти це знову ж таки
надихає інші
цифри вони для нас невтішні але цілком
передбачувані враховуючи ті умови в яких
ми перебували в яких перебували наші
діти і наша освіта на момент проведення
і перед проведенням дослідження
математика мінус12
балів природничо-наукові дисципліни
мінус19 балів і найгірша ситуація з
читанням
-ну38
балів ви бачите в цій таблиці далі буде
багато ще цифр в презентаціях сьогодні
на сьогоднішній день ви бачите що впали
результати не тільки у України впали
результати і в інших країнах і це до
речі зокрема є наслідком пандемії ковіду
тривалого дистанційного навчання
щодо читання Хочу зупинитися окремо
падіння стрімке і цифри можуть лякати
але я прошу згадать кожного з з вас і
власний досвід в перші місяці
повномасштабного вторгнення як знизилася
здатність концентруватись на чомусь крім
новин як довго не виходило взя взяти до
рук книжку і це важко дорослим це важко
було нам це важко було мені не говорячи
про про дітей і про підлітків які
перебували в постійному стресі
ісім місяців в постійному стресі
ее детальніше результати
дослідження будуть представлені я не
буду зупинятися на деталях більше буде
даних і ви зможете їх обговорити і знову
ж таки великий і товстий звіт буде
оприлюднено
А причини які причини перш за все це
ковід ми розуміємо ІТ два роки
дистанційного навчання втрата мотивації
через втрату розвитку психосоціальної
психосоціальних навичок
е не підготовлена тоді ще система освіти
до дистанційного навчання виклик ковіду
був достатньо раптовий для нас і
звичайно Він не міг не відобразитися на
е результатах які який показали який
показала наша молодь війна звичайно і
перед війною була досить тривалий період
напруги і початок вторгнення і ці ісім
місяців безумовно відобразились і Це
очевидно
стрес
постійний перманентний стрес який
виникав з гостроїв хронічну фазу у
багатьох дітей так само У вчителів у
адміністраторів шкіл у цього суспільства
все суспільство перебувало в стресі який
виражався дуже по-різному і навіть люди
які заперечують у себе наявність стресу
тоді і зараз
просто не відчувають його або не
аналізують насправді свій
стан Отже
Що з цим
робити ми мали багато робочих зустрічей
дуже багато
обговорювали в експертній спільноті в
освітянській спільноті
різні опції різні стратегії подолання
освітніх втрат на чому сходяться усі
потрібно повертати дітей до очного
навчання власне один з пріоритетів нашої
команди повернути нашу молодь
максимально всюди де це можливо до
очного
навчання з перших днів ми цю собі мету
поставили створити всі можливості для
цього там де це можливо і базова вимога
до цього звичайно наявність укритті в
закладах
освіти тож цього року з державного
бюджету було виділено 1, млрда грвень
уряд виділив на облаштування сховищ це
майже 300 проектів які зараз все ще
будуються і вже побудовані введені в
експлуатацію це і будівництво нових
укриттів це і реконструкція це і ремонт
на наступний рік ми маємо
субвенцію на облаштування укриттів 2,5
млрд грн тож Ця робота буде
продовжуватись друга річ необхідна це
шкільні автобуси ви знаєте що дуже
багато автобусів було і викрадено і
пошкоджено і передано на потреби
збройним силам України і потреба в
автобусах в громадах сягала по Україні е
понад 3 000 одиниць в цьому році уряд
виділив мільярд гривень субвенцію на
підтримку цієї потреби для громад і за
ці гроші разом зі співфінансуванням
вдалось закупити 550 автобусів ще 400
автобусів нам виділили наші партнери з
11 країн світу
е-е з країн ЄС і в наступному році Ця
робота також буде продовжена на
підтримку громад уряд виділив ще 1 млрд
грн і також триває оця наша автобусна
коаліція з країнами ЄС Я думаю що ми і
ще Біля 1 000 автобусів у 24му році
зможемо забезпечити Таким чином значною
мірою закривши цю потребу водночас Ми не
можемо випускати з фокусу уваги дітей
які все одно не зможуть навчатися очно і
ми знаємо що єсть регіони в яких підліт
ракети настільки короткий і сигнал
тривоги звучить
настільки пізно що діти просто фізично
не зможуть спуститися в укриття навіть
якщо воно в школі є це Харківська
область запоріжька область Херсонська
область Миколаївська область ці регіони
Донецька область і та частина Луганської
області Ми в цих регіонах не зможемо
вивести дітей повернути дітей до очного
навчання і природньо що в цих регіонах
люди потребують підтримки природньо що в
ці регіони
потрібно дітей в цих регіонах
забезпечувати
гаджетами відповідно і вчителів і дітей
ця робота триває і ця робота буде
продовжена в наступному році ми дуже
дякуємо нашим партнерам Ми дуже дякуємо
цілому ряду компаній таким організаціям
як icef які допомагають нам з гаджетами
для соціальних категорій дітей яким які
цього потребують і також розвиваємо
проекти такі як всеукраїнська школа
онлайн
відновлення субвенцій на нову українську
школу це знову ж таки про якість освіти
цього року уряд виділив ви знаєте що не
було коштів не було субвенції на нову
українську школу в бюджеті 23го року в
середині року восени уряд виділив майже
півмільярда гривень на субвенцію за ці
кошти ми фінансуємо дидактику для
п'ятих-шостих класів ми фінансуємо
навчання вчителів е субвенцію закладені
кошти на забезпечення також навчальними
засобами сьомих пілотних класів це
113 мільйонів на ці цілі передбачено і
на наступний рік субвенція нуж
збільшиться і буде складати 1вто мльрди
Таким чином ми повертаємося до
довоєнного обсягу фінансування субвенції
на нову українську школу крім Рім цього
активно друкуємо підручники знаєте що в
22-му році всі кошти були перепризначені
на військові цілі і фінансування
підручників не було Через що ви виник
виник значний дефіцит значний геп в цій
позиції в цьому році було виділено 700
понад 700 млн урядом на друк підручників
і також восени додатково було виділено
півмільярда і таким чином кошти в цьому
році на друк підручників склали в цілому
і підручники Зараз якраз теж
додруковуються до кінця року
завершуються оці освоєння цих
півмільярда додаткових коштів е-е Таким
чином виходить мільярд 300 в цьому році
ми одержали фінансування на
друк-підручники і на наступний рік у нас
закладена субвенція на друк підручників
1, млрд грн Що дозволить нам фактично
закрити потребу за самими важливими і
самими гострими позиціями е-е в цій в
цій в цьому
питанні ще один надзвичайно важливий
аспект це піклування про ментальне
здоров'я від нашого психологічного стану
залежить наша спроможність взагалі
навчатися сприймати інформацію наша
мотивація наша здатність
фокусуватись наша здатність
запам'ятовувати і це стосується перш за
все звичайно як
дітей але це стосується і педагогів і
освітя
тож працюємо щоб допомогти школярам
сформувати навички піклування про своє
ментальне здоров'я про своє психічне
здоров'я бути
стійким бути здатними діяти в
надзвичайних ситуаціях і також маємо
амбітну мету це трансформувати
психологічну службу в системі освіти і
перш за все це спрямовано на збільшення
кількості штатної чисельності психологів
в школах що вкрай важливо для нас зараз
особливо в цей час коли психологи а
особливо в сільській місцевості надають
допомогу фактично всім і дітям і
вчителям і батькі і батькам і і і члени
громади якщо це села чи невелике
містечка звертаються до шкільних
психологів Тому що іноді інших просто
немає тому для нас дуже важливо виграти
дискусію з міністерством фінансів яку ми
зараз маємо щодо збільшення ставок
психологів це надважливо працюємо над
цим що ще важливо розбудова ефективної
системи тюторства індивідуального
менторства для школярів Я думаю наші
колеги представлять сьогодні деякі
проекти спрямовані на цю
мету це повинно стати нам треба
враховувати що це повинно не має стати
таким додатковим навантаженням на дітей
навздогін до шкільного навантаження
необхідно знаходити баланс між
навантаженням додаткових занять і
основних занять в школі а також тут
треба кошти і кошти значні тому
що якщо ми хочемо побудувати цю роботу
системно вона повинна фінансуватися
відповідним чином і повинна оплачуватись
робота педагогів які будуть працювати на
таких
платформах ми розуміємо що цих коштів
додаткових У нас великий успіх в тому що
ми от добились Ось цього фінансування і
ми розуміємо що цих додаткових коштів ми
зараз можливо не
ходимо в бюджеті держави але будемо
працювати над пошуком донорських коштів
в цьому році і будемо працювати над
розробленням стратегії подолання
освітніх втрат і в рамках цієї стратегії
уже аргументуючи ось цими
дослідженнями працювати з урядом з
міністерством фінансів щодо фінансування
таких рішень з державного бюджету уже
можливо всередині наступного року Так як
Нам вдалось добитися фінансування деяких
позицій в 23му році дискутуючи з
міністерством фінансів і заручившись
підтримкою прем'єр-міністра президента
на підручники чи на нову українську
школу Сподіваємось що нам також вдасться
досягнути цієї мети Отже підсумовуючи е
хочу сказати це насправді великий успіх
проведення цього дослідження під час
війни те що нас не вибили з робочого
стану те що ми змогли сфокусуватися на
головному і зробили це це дуже важливо Я
хочу подякувати всім педагогам і всім
тим закладам освіти які взяли участь в
дослідженні я хочу подякувати батькам За
те що вони дали правильний настрой своїм
дітям і розуміють важливість і цінність
навчання для їх дітей я хочу подякувати
командам організаторів і представництву
піса в Україні особисто тобі Тетяна за
цю Прекрасну роботу і хочу подякувати
всім партнерам які підтримують
дослідження а також підтримують
подолання оцих наслідків війни і
наслідків ковіду всім партнерам
партнерським організаціям донорським
організаціям Ну і звичайно я хочу
подякувати уряду України для те що він
виставляє сьогодні пріоритети за те що
освіта є в пріоритеті хочу подякувати
парламенту комітету з питань освіти за
те що всі ми працюємо як єдина команда
усвідомлюючи значення і важливість
освіти для розвитку нашої країни Ми
будуємо демо тичну і вільну країну
освіта є Основним інструментом цієї
розбудови ми розуміємо це і ми робимо
все для того щоб перемогти в нашій
боротьбі і В нашій роботі Дякую вам всім
Шановні
колеги Дякуємо пане Оксана власне після
ваших слів розумію що Надія
є ви говорили щойно про те наскільки
складно було проводити дослідження
дякували тим хто долучався до його
проведення і хто є серцем цього
дослідження та Але є одна людина без
якої я впевнена що Україна би не провела
це дослідження взагалі напевно це
дослідження би не існувало є одна людина
яка підтримала підтримувало нас дорогі
друзі Я бачу що в нас повітряна тривога
і це зрозуміло після такого після такої
промови було би дивно якби нас не намага
Ні немає Все
гаразд все гаразд фальстарт добре Але
для того а в Севастополі у нас хтось
оптиміст із Севастополя не страшно
дорогі друзі по-перше Ми з вами
перевірили що в нас є укриття я вам це
говорю що в нас є укриття якщо буде
повітряна тривога ми організовано
спустимося в укриття там колеги Вам
допоможуть на виході тож ми тепер знаємо
що робити власне продовжу є одна людина
яка надихала нас впродовж всього періоду
проведеня дослідження але небільшої
підтримки Ми отримали від цієї людини в
лютому 22-го року коли щойно ми
повідомили про те що навряд чи взагалі в
поточному циклі ми зможемо щось
проводити Ми отримали сотні листів сотні
слів
підтримки від команд Піза різних країн
ці команди Піза і команда організації
економічного співробітництва і розвитку
одразу сказали що вони з Україною і
підтвердили це тим що 3 березня Росію і
Білорусію було вилучено з усіх проектів
організації економічного співробітництва
і
розвитку Я дуже добре пам'ятаю ці тисячі
листів які надходили нам усім е і в яких
команду Піза України запрошували побути
десь в іншій країні отримати прихисток
це коли справою тобі допомагають
ця людина вона вірила в нас і вірить
кожну хвилину І власне Андре шлейхер чиє
відео ми подивимося зараз підтверджує
також що Надія
є друзі та колеги Після чотирьох
непростих років сьогодні наша
флагманська програма
Піза дає нам нові дані про Поточний стан
освіти по
світу ми бачимо наскільки учні
підготовлені до
завтра студенти з різних походжень яких
є шанси на успіх за останні роки було
важко
молоді особливо на території вашої
країни багато учнів
тут не могли вчитися постійно через
війну багато хто зазнав травми хтось був
переміщений Незважаючи на це участь
України в дослідженні Піза все ж таки
сталося І це говорить про стійкість і
міць народу і системи освіти
тутешнії протягом пандемії багато країн
зазнали зниження результатів навчання А
учні
України в академічних здобутках в
принципі втримали свій рівень незважаючи
на пандемію та війну і це дуже визна
подія Я знаю що останнє вивчення надає
даних по окупованих територіях тому
якихось конкретні порівняння робити щось
заранно але 22 результати все ж таки
відображають гарну стабільність ситуації
і окрім того 84% тутешніх
учнів
відчувають мають відчуття приналежності
до школи і це дуже гарний здобуток для
уd і це дозволяє нам говорити про те що
українські вчителі віддані в справі вони
підтримують не тільки процес навчання
учнів але також вони перекривають і
емоційні потреби учнів через війну де
народжується українська ідентичність Я
зустрічався з освітянами тут у лютому і
потім влітку і я був дуже вражений тим з
якою пристрастю вони ставляться ОТТ і
вчителі і освітяни до своєї роботи в них
є певне баченні вони бажають через
освіту створити кращий світ і це
відображається на рівні учнів за даними
Піза учні по Україні вони одни з
найбільш мотивованих в навчанні у школах
навіть якщо школи закриті давайте
зрозуміємо що сьогодні школи це наша
економіка наше суспільство наша
демократія завтра і завтра будуть зовсім
нові очікування серед
молоді на сьогодні освіта вже не тільки
стосується того щоб навчити учнів чомусь
це стосується до допомоги цим молодим
людям зрозуміти зорієнтуватися в житті
дати їм зряддя щоб вони впевнено
рухалися по такому нестабільному світу
де постійно якісь перетворення сьогодні
успіх в освіті стосується того що ви
відкриваєтесь Ви впізнаєте щось нове Ви
відчуваєте пристрасть ви з відкритим
серцем ставитесь до того що є І це
дозволяє мобілізувати соціальні
когнітивні і інші ресурси задля
подальших дій це наші кращі знаряддя які
дозволяють нам далати найбільші загрози
там закритість
ненависть небажання
вчитися Отже
те чому легко навчати це те що можна
легко оцифрувати
світ наш він не тільки нас винагороджує
за те що ми знаємо ввогулі є все Але що
ми можемо робити на основі знань Які є я
про це не дарма кажу тому що тешні учні
Вони гарно себе проявляють при виконанні
задач по математиці Наприклад ми от
проводили там тести але
потім важкувато вжити математичні знання
у вірному напрямі А це сьогодні дуже
важлива річ і в тому є велика різниця
між тотешніми учнями і найкращими
освітніми системами в
Піза традиційні підходи по школах
передбачають що ви великі проблеми
зменшиути до чогось меншого і потім
вчити учнів вирішувати ті чи інші
конкретні задачі але в сучасному
суспільстві слід інтегрувати різні
підходи створювати зв'язки між
ідеями і Тима дисциплінами які може були
недотичними але тепер це вже зовсім
інший підхід раніше все було розділено
вчителі контент все ділилося на предмети
і учні це взагалі була іншасто ніхто не
думав про їх кар'єрні
перспективи вони тримали цих учнів в
закладах А ось світ навкруги був чимось
іншим тепер все більш взаємопов'язано ми
говоримо про взаємозв'язки поміж
предметами про інтеграцію
учнів на території країни є варіанти для
прасування освіти дані також свідчать
про те що є велика прогалина в успіхах
між
учнями з заможних родин і Тима Хто живе
в незаможних родинах і
ту слід закладати основи для того щоб
було когезивне суспільство на території
країни
і для цього дуже важливі
школи якщо у вас заможна родина то у вас
будуть відкриті двері до різних закладів
в житті але якщо у вас таких привілей
нема то у вас є один шанс в житті щоб
піти до гарної школи і повчитися гарних
вчителів Отже слід проблюти
найтелевинтіших вчителів до навчання
всіх учнів і вони будуть Тима придними
лідерами які будуть навчати в непростих
школах інвестиції в освіту також
потрібні Україна має найкращі результати
серед країн які витратили подібні гроші
на на розрахунку з одного студента це
гарний
Доробок ви доволі небагато
витрачаєте у порівнянні з іншими краї на
одного учня в країні тим не менше
надаєте їм гарні можливості вчитися
цифровізація Також тут є важливим
фактором в кожній країні студенти
використовують цифрові прилади Але у вас
цей показник вище це тому що є
війна технологія просто стала тепер
варіантом який допомагає продовжувати
навчання навіть незважаючи на війну Піза
надає певні поради ми бачимо що активне
використання цифрового обладнання
навіть для розваг
може негативно відбитися на студентах і
в академічному плані і в соціальному і
багато учнів тутешніх відчувають
занепокоєння використовуючи ці прилади
навчання - це не просто якась транзакція
це завжди щось соціальне це завжди щось
те що стосується взаємин тому я бачу як
українські вчителі дуже підтримують
своїх
учнів і учні відчувають що вчителі
розуміють Хто вони ким вони хочуть стати
і вчителі супроводжують їх в цьому і
вони зростають і академічно і соціально
і в тому є один з самих великих успіхів
тут на
сьогодні є соціальні
мережі які дозволяють людям об'єднатися
за інтересом і Це додає нам варіантів
обмінятись думками ми вже не
відстораняємося від всіх
є різні думки які з'єднують і
роз'єднують нас у чомусь і тут школи
мають просто свою роботу що О почні
продумали про себе і об'єдналися з
іншими Вони мають набути Відчуття того
що вірним що ні вони мають відчувати
що слід виходити з межі індивідуальних
та колективних дій робота вдома і в
спільноті поміж жучними дозволить їм
глибше зрозуміти як живуть інші люди в
інших культурах і
традиціях як вони
мислять в науці або в
мистецтві післявоєнний період буде мати
свої
проблеми що мо може с дізнатися з
досвіду України це те що навіть за таких
важких умов ніколи не слід відступати
від освіти це запорука кращому
майбутньому і От такі важкі часи Можна
подумати про освіту в країні зробити так
щоб учні привели нас до кращого
майбутнього щоб ваші вчителі також
вчилися ставали креативними створювачами
інновативного простору для навчання
навіть у притулках і щоб Створювалися
спільноти які будуть трансформувати
усвіту я вас
поздоровляю є підтримка збоку
осд Я через тиждень маю приїхати до
Києва
У нас є ще гості з організації
економічного співробітництва і розвитку
Але трохи згодом вони повідомлять нам
про деякі результати власне жодне велике
жодна велика зміна в освіті неможливо
без законодавчого врегулювання без
унормування цих змін без того щоби
нормативна підтримка була в українських
освітян і гарантом такої підтримки на
сьогодні є Комітет Верховної Ради
України з питань освіти науки та
інновацій і безперечно її голова це
Сергій
Бабак пане Сергію прошу вас до
[музика]
слова Я напевно
почну трішки
незвично бо я завжди дуже глибоко
останні роки в самій системі освіти тому
знаю про всі її проблеми але почну я з
іншого
я пишаюсь нашою системою освіти і
пишаюсь кожним вчителем кожним
викладачем який є в системі освіти тому
що ця система вистояла за останні
півтора роки вже не кажучи про ковід не
просто вистояла вистояла Навіть через те
що близько більше ніж 10% наших закладів
пошкоджені або зруйновані мільйони людей
переміщені всередині країни мільйони за
межі країни частина закладів була
переміщена з з непідконтрольних
територій на підконтрольну територію
України і менше з тим система вистояла
більше того вона ще под підставила плече
всцій державі бо Наші шкільні автобуси
евакуювали людей Наші шкільні автобуси
пішли на потреби збройних сил наші школи
часто ставали прихистком для внутрішньо
переміщених осіб на досить довгий час і
нагадаю що по суті в лютому 22-го року у
нас закінчився навчальний рік по
великому рахунку це говорить про те що
діти які прийшли на тестування в жовтні
не мали навчання півроку до цього і вже
не кажучи про те що в нас два роки був
ковід пам'ятаєте місяцями карантини
потім системи безпеки протоколи і так
далі що є неминучим і неймовірним
стресом для дітей але Разом з тим ця
система вистла чи ми розуміли що будуть
втрати освітні да розумію
більше того Минулого року якраз
приблизно рік тому у нас була дуже
велика одна із нарад з президентом
України як ви знаєте президент України
дуже опікується питаннями освіти і
питаннями майбутнього наших дітей на цій
нараді Ми якраз намагалися підбити
підсумки 22-го року і поставити собі
завдання на
23-й і найголовнішою темою яка звучала
Це було питання освітніх втрат
як їх виміряти Що з цим робити як
стабілізувати систему і як їх
подолати я вам скажу
що єдине що нам в цьому допомагає це
безперечна єдність єдність між урядом
парламентом Да й всіма освітянами всі ми
розуміємо заради чого точніше заради
кого і заради чого Кого майбутнього ми
працюємо тому якщо ви пам'ятаєте тоди
один з перших законів який був прийнятий
після початку повномасштабного Це був
закон про захист вчителів Це був закон
про державні гарантії який гарантував
всім освітянам в Україні незважаючи на
те де вони будуть знаходитись найближчим
часом під час повномасштабного
вторгнення гарантував їм продовження
виплати заробітних плат чи хтось вірив в
те що наша система освіти витримає це
все ну вірили багато але впевнено не був
ніхто багато експертів у країні не
давали більше ніж 72 години Але разом з
тим так само як наші воїни
зробили майже неможливе так само майже
неможливе зробили І всі ми освітяни і це
дуже тішить тому можна з певністю
сказати що нашою системою освіти можна
пишатися це ми зараз дуже часто чуємо
від батьків тих дітей які Поїхали за
кордон раніше в нас був якийсь Ясь певно
каргокульт з цього питання там освіта
краща там все краще насправді зараз
багато батьків кажуть Ми би хотіли би
щоб наші діти повернулися Назад бо в нас
система освіти не гірша як мінімум і до
речі результати цьогорічні піса це ж це
підтверджують якщо ми подивимось
наприклад на падіння результатів з
математики то воно меншим є ніж падіння
в країнах
оecd в них падіння відбулося більше ніж
в нас за результатами що теж говорить
про певну високу якість освіти Чи є в
нас проблеми Да безперечно є і їх багато
якщо ви дуже детально прочитаєте великий
звіт по результатам дослідження то ви їх
всі побачите вони очевидні це різниця
між великими містами маленькими
містечками і селами в результатах вони
насправді шокуючі це і раніше раніше
була велика різниця але зараз вона стала
ще ще більшою якщо ви подивитесь на
результати дітей які проживають в
великих містах вони навіть вище ніж в
середньому по Європі але результати
дітей які навчаються в селах насправді
дуже турбують тому що по окремим
дисциплінам або напрямам тестування
різниця складає більше ніж 4чотири роки
навчання і це величезна сегрегація і Для
нас це велика проблема і нам треба
думати всім разом як її подолати можливо
нам потрібно повернути субвенцію
спроможня школа не на капітальні видатки
А на облаштування освітнього простору
спеціалізованих кабінетів нам безперечно
потрібно звернути увагу на повну
трансформацію як нам
здається системи перепідготовки і
підвищення кваліфікації вчителів і до
речі дослідження про це прямо каже що ті
учні в тих школах в яких вчителі більше
проходили підвищення кваліфікації
показують Значно краще результати і Це
очевидно Тому що ті вчителі які
проходять підвищення кваліфікації Вони
отримують нові знання нові методики нові
навички
нові способи роботи з дітьми і це дуже
важливо на в середині року ми в комітеті
провели величезні комітетські слухання
багато хто з вас був на них присутній
всі експерти всі ті хто приймають
управлінські рішення в країні в системі
освіти були на цих комітетських
слуханнях Ми дали багато сторінок
десятки пунктів рекомендацій що нам
потрібно зробити для того щоб визначити
освітні втрати і їх подолати На жаль
більша частина рекомендацій або не
виконана або зараз знаходиться в процесі
виконання і нам потрібно інтенсифікувати
цю роботу безперечно Я з жахом можу
сказати що в нас досі немає системи
освітніх вимірювань в країні і ми
чекаємо на результати Піза для того щоб
зрозуміти який рівень підготовки наших
дітей і оце нам потрібно робити В першу
чергу але сама по собі система
оцінювання анкетування і опитування вона
дасть лише нам розуміння про масштаби
освітніх втрат тому дуже важливо і давно
треба розробити
стратегію подолання освітніх втрат і
дати цей інструментарій школам
директорам і вчителям для того щоб ці
освітні втрати ми з вами долали тому що
інакше На жаль ми будемо констатувати
зниження рівня знань з кожним
дослідженням Піза або власне і це не
дуже добре і якщо ми вже заговорили про
підвищення кваліфікації вчителів Я думаю
що варто переосмислити в принципі
систему педагогічної
освіти Я не говорю про те що в нас лише
20% випускників педагогічних
університетів доходять до до роботи
вчителем це трагедія тому що це на 99%
відбувається за бюджетний кошт і над цим
ми працюємо зараз з урядом але також є і
питання якості якості підготовки
вчителів для того щоб вони виходили вже
готові Вже з сучасним інструментаріями
методиками ми говоримо про зараз про
дуже важливі і Дуже системні реформи які
нам потрібно зробити І багато хто в
вважає що в країні яка воює реформи
неможливі або майже неможливі Повірте ми
вже з вами довели що все можливо а наші
воїни на фронті кожного дня доводять Що
неможливого не існує ми з вами змінили
систему зовнішнього незалежного
оцінювання я нагадаю приблизно за 3, по
місяці ми перейшли під час
повномасштабного вторгнення під час того
як було 30% території окуповано ми
перейшли від паперового зовнішнього
незалежного оцінювання в електронний
національний мультипредметний тест який
спочатку визвав викликав подив а десь
супротив але зараз Всі розуміють
наскільки це був важливий і правильний
крок який залишив для дітей можливість
Рівного доступу до вищої освіти і дав
нам певний інструмент все ж таки
оцінювання і це важливо його розвивати Я
не впевнений що ми колись повернемось до
паперового зовнішнього незалежного
оцінювання можливо це буде колись
гібридна форма але поки ми рухаємось в
такому напрямку і всі вважали що це
неможливо і навіть в парламенті коли ми
голосували за цей законопроект нам
багато хто казав що це неможливо Але ми
з вами довели що це можливо тому і
реформи можливі і нам потрібно зробити
висновки з цього раунду досліджень Піза
так само як ми зробили висновки з
першого раунду бо Повірте одної з першої
книж книжок яка з'явилася в мене на
робочому столі називалася уроки Піза
2018 наскільки я пам'ятаю правильно
Тетяна і це такий певний дороговказ до
того що нам потрібно зробити Я впевнений
зараз буде ще одна аналітика від
українського центру оцінювання якості і
це все буде дороговказ для нас Шановні
колеги немає нічого
неможливого ви це доводите кожного дня
наші воїни доводять це кожного дня тому
в нам з вами попереду дуже багато роботи
бо наступне дослідження вже буде через
три роки
Дякую дорогі друзі зараз я запрошу ще
одну спікерку до слова але перед тим як
я це зроблю я попрошу тих із вас хто
використовує навушники для англомовних
спікерів Якщо у вас є проблеми ви можете
звернутися вту залу за за нами і Вам
допоможуть налаштувати ваші навушники
так щоб ви добре чули і розуміли
спікерку нашу Тож сьогодні говоритимемо
багато про єдність є одна
організація яка з нами з першого циклу
Піза в Україні вони підтримували всі
наші мрії всі наші бажання і
сьогоднішній захід багато в чому був
зроблений є зроблений і проведений буде
проведений завдяки цій організації Я маю
честь запросити до слова голову з секції
освіти юніiceф Україна ель аріу яка
повідомить про нашу давню дружбу і про
те що юнісф робить В Україні дуже
[оплески]
дякую Шановна пані міністр пані та
панове шановні промовці представники
урядових структур і
неурядових багато хто з вас сьогодні є
тут
я на початку хочу також сказати що ми
вдячні міністерству і
ecd голові по освіті Я хочу поздоровити
мін освіти і науки з тим що проведена
така велика масштабна робота по оцінці в
той час коли багато дітей сімей та шкіл
переживають важкі
часи як вже казав пан шлейтер результати
Піза за 22-й рік і тенденції які там
зафіксовані дають можливість вимірити
міць первинної та вторинної освіти і
продовжувати спиратися на це для кожної
дитини таким же чином дані дають важливу
можливість розглянути те деякі
коригування потрібні в цьому на подальше
щоб побачити куди інвестиції слід
спрямувати щоб виправити втрати освітні
і також зробити так що що всі діти і
молодь могли реалізувати повністю свій
потенціал разом з чотирма
організаціями дві з яких сьогодні
представлені дистанційна це icd та
світовий Банк unніicef виявили п'ять
Скажімо так напрямів
політики де є докази міжнародні того що
слід виправляти
перекривати втрати в освіті це
стосується ще постковідних заходів а
також і дані про те як можна повернутися
до нормального навчання з врахуванням
всіх дітей і разздано дві з таких два з
таких напрямів політики які є найбільш
дотичними на початку були коментарі щодо
того що слід концентруватись на рішеннях
на подальших діях заради дітей та шкіл
слід розібратися з цим сперечись на дані
дослідження
dpза хочу сказати про дві конкретні
сфери перше з них - це оцінка доробків
учнів результатів їх навчання мається на
увазі а друге
стосується
інструктажу для вчителів і також
директорів
шкіл освітні проблеми з'явилися ще за
ковіду а потім через війну
Отже ми працюємо з учнями на
індивідуальному рівні І це дуже важливо
в результатах від відзначено
що певні
прогалини збільшилися в навчанні Ти в
кого нема приладів або Інтернету вони
пропустили шмат дистанційного навчання
деякі батьки не змогли просто технічно
підтримати варіант навчання дитини з
дому ми знаємо по результатах
міжнародних оцінок що учні як правило
страждають від цих факторів і вони вже
стикаються з труднощами в навчанні і це
що було навіть до ковіду І до цієї війни
зростає частка дітей які повертаються до
шкіл через змішану модель або
індивідуальне навчання вчителі будуть
мати справу з учнями які мають різні
здобутки в навчанні вони на різних
етапах навчання і набуття знань і такі
вчителі будуть потербувати ефективні
оцінки для того щоб зрозуміти на якому
етапі знаходиться дитина яка повернулася
до школи
батьки також мають підготуватися
підтримувати своїх дітей щоб вони
надоложували втрачене в освіті навчання
на дому передбачає що батькам доведеться
багато чого зробити самотужки щоб дитина
продовжувала освітній процес Я думаю
існуюча система тутешня тай не тільки
тут буде залишатися залежною від
залучення батьків протягом
цієї ситуації з надолодженням втраченого
в освіті слі знати не тільки як
відсотковати доробки учнів але Що з цим
робити як використовувати ці результати
щоб учень рухався далі на якому б етапі
Він знаходився зараз що стосується про
те про що казав міністр у промові це не
тільки важливо в плані академічних
основних засадчок дисциплін але також це
навіть більш важливо по некогнітивних
навичках Тобто прийняття рішень
розв'язання проблем соціальні зв'язки
все це буде дуже важливо при визначенні
того чи людині потрібна додаткова
підтримка в навчанні на подальше
переходимо від оцінки учнів до вчителів
вчителі Вони знаходяться на передовій
всієї цієї роботи і про це свідчать дані
Піза виходячи з оцінки даних про
навчання в класах вчителя вчителі
потребуватимуть підтримки для того щоб
проводити
структуризовані уроки які стосується
надолуженого надолуження втраченого і
набуття учнями навичок під наглядом
Міністерство проводиться робота яка на
сьогодні охопила вже багато шкіл в
країні цеє індивідуальний варіант
навчання і онлайновий я знаю що багато
роботи проводиться по групових і
індивідуальних варіантах наставництва
надолуженя є цифрові центри навчання
літні програми на долуження а також є
стратегії які влаштовуються мо в класах
щось змінює варіанти розподілу вчаса
вчителя відносно того на яку сферу знань
слід приділити більше уваги ми знаємо що
навчання - це також соціальна справа і
про це також пан шлегер казав це
соціальна соціальний процес він
передбачає взаємодію і в основі ї цієї
взаємодії є вчителі я можу також Сказати
що і вчителі шкіл керівники шкіл Отже
інвестиції будуть потрібні не тільки в
фізичну Але й в цифрову інфраструктуру
це важливо але цього ще недостатньо ми
маємо роздати варіанти розширення
спроможностей тих хто
запроваджує варіанти надолуження втрат в
освіті і використовування цифрових
систем навчання буде їм великою
допомогою в цій роботі є важливість
підтримки навчання тих кому до 15 років
і в принципі про це пізае в дослідженні
говорить тут ми говоримо не тільки про
первину та середню освіту також слід
розлядати два напрями систему освіти не
слід забувати про важливість раннього
навчання дитини щоб діти були готові
вчитися і здобувати відповідних
компетенцій в первинній гільці навчання
також розглядати різні варіанти для
підлітків в навчанні щоб вони могли
набувати тих компетенцій самі в родинах
і
це знадобиться їм задля економічного
одужання
щоб всі діти та молодь успішно вчилися
незважаючи на
проблеми
слід брати до уваги той успіх який є і
допрацьовувати подальшу систему освіти у
подальшому Як віце-прем'єр казав система
освіти слід трансформувати для того щоб
оперативно
реагувати на
прогалини які мають діти і молодь і
навчання я думаю в цій
країні в секторі освіти є багато
партнерів які
залучаються до підтримки дітей та молоді
в плані навчанняці партнери є на різних
рівнях державні приватні структури
громадянське суспільство школи та й самі
діти та батьки вони також партнери в цій
справі щодо побудови шкіл та процесів
які допо можуть надолужити втрачене в
освіті хочу закликати Міністерство науки
та освіти розвивати чу мережу партнерів
unніiceеf входить до
неї під гаслом національної програми на
долуження втраченого в освіті для того
щоб
всі заходи охопили всю молодь і дітей в
країні будемо проводити роботу з урядом
щоб всі діти продовжували навчатися і
сподіваюся що через такі колективні
зусилля і дискусії які проводяться ми в
25му і 26му році будемо розлядати
результати Піза які
продемонструють що ці інвестиції дали в
плані
навчання власне все що ми робимо
це наслідки єдності і взаємодії і
співпраці є одна установа з якою ми
співпрацюємо вже багато років і одним з
найбільших продуктів нашої діяльності є
та система тема освітніх оцінювань яка
може і не повною мірою виконує ті
функції які перед нами є але відповідає
на багато запитань власне ще в 19-му
році ми підготували стратегію розвитку
освітніх оцінювань до 2030 року в якій
говорили і про те яка якою має бути
державна підсумкова атестація які
міжнародні дослідження ми маємо
проводити окрім Піза і підготували ми
такий документ великий потужний завдяки
підтримці прекрасної надійної установи
організації з якою ми давно співпрацюємо
міжнародний фонд Відродження і
виконавчий директор Олександр сошко
прошу до
слова добрий
день дуже радий бачити повну залу і
тішуся що є привід для того щоби
засвідчити новий етап у нашиіх спробах
побудувати освіту базовану на даних
відповідну політику відповідні
е-е бачення майбутньої
е-е української шкільної в даному
випадку не тільки шкільної освіти Так я
пам'ятаю добре той день в 18-му році
коли ми презентували е коли
презентувалося е попереднє дослідження в
Україні пам'ятаю ті висновки і тому дуже
цікаво буде порівняти не тільки Україну
дійсно з іншими країнами але й Україну з
Україною тою до до ковідною до воєнною
ймовірно там теж є істотні відмінності і
але зараз ми бачимо наскільки Ну от
висновки і саме застосування цих
висновків які отримані цим
дослідженням виходять за межі суто
питань е освітньої політики тобто
сьогодні ми коли говоримо щойно
прозвучали
наприклад висновки про те наскільки
посилюється розрив між освітою в
сільських школах і в крупних містах та
Тобто це чи це питання суто системи
освіти Ні це питання е розвитку країни і
тих диспропорцій які як ми бачимо
посилюються
спочатку пандемією А тепер війною і
вирішувати ці питання цих
диспропорцій ясно що неможливо в рамках
виключно освітньої політики це питання
загалом підходів до державного
будівництва і розподілу тих ресурсів
обмежених які
Україні
є чи будуть в майбутньому
ми дуже уважні в тому що
стосується
тих даних які можуть допомогти країні
сформувати
якісно
стратегію
відновлення стратегію яка стосується не
тільки тих регіонів які постраждали від
окупації чи продовжують страждати а
також
і більш віддалених від війни регіонів
очевидно що зараз дуже багато різних
проектів прожектів пов'язаних саме з
відновленням і готові приходити донори
міжнародні допомагати і інвестори Ми
сподіваємося прийдуть так от власне Який
план представити їм які пріоритети
позначити перед ними для того щоб ці
кошти які вони потенційно принесуть були
витрачені найбільш ефективно Я думаю що
от такі дослідження вони допоможуть Вони
не тільки нам показують там конкретно
рівень знань з окремих предметів Ні вони
показують нам рівень людського розвитку
і динаміку і в тому числі загрозливі
тенденції які треба ймовірно на які
треба реагувати от тому ці ці дані ці
е ці дані вони безумовно дуже цінні і
для наших міжнародних партнерів Ми також
побачимо е ми можемо продемонструвати
світові
ее наскільки українське суспільство
виявилося стійким до тих
екстраординарних викликів які тут значно
глибші ніж в
більшості інших країн світу Якщо
говорити про мирний час так мирні країни
от тому це це теж дуже цікавий індикатор
до нього будуть придивлятися Я думаю
дуже багато аналітиків із різних сфер
теж не тільки освітньої От і все це дуже
підвищує вартість цього дослідження його
актуальність його за сферу застосування
цих даних які отримані тому власне Я
думаю що ніколи е
Ніде в світі от власне застосування
отриманих результатів не буде не не має
потенціалу бути настільки універсальним
як тут в Україні з цими даними тому що
це питання дійсно питання зрізу ситуації
в такий екстремальний момент історії і
нам треба чітко бачити де де у нас є
точки міцності А де навпаки ми бачимо
найбільшу вразливість
країни яка виявляється в тому числі і у
такому такому показникові як як власне
якість тобто якість знань у
учнів підлітків 15 років Тобто це це
дійсно безцінні дані я сподіваюся і буду
усіляко їх рекламувати спеціалістам з
різних сфер і дуже впевнений в тому що
вони знайдуть своє застосування а ми ще
раз підтверджую слова Тетяни ми як
інституція як фонд Відродження
продовжуємо бути в процесі ми цікавимося
ми постійно тримаємо руку на пульсі
подібних досліджень і комунікуємо і
сприяємо їх кращій комунікації також і
назовні всіх тим всім тим аудиторіям
кому Чию увагу треба звернути на такі
результати Дуже дякую і бажаю також
сьогодні плідної дискусії
дякую
Щиро дякуємо за адвокацію Я упевнена що
вашими зусиллями ці результати стануть
дійсно відомими багатьом-багатьом
експертаманалітикам точно знаю що є одна
установа яка використовує наші
результати і використовує результати
подібних великих досліджень для того
щоби планувати надавати фінансову
допомогу Світовий банк це та установа
яка давно підтримує Україну і завдяки
якій багато з процесів в Україні не
зупинилися власне керівник секції з
питань освіти Джеймс грешем звернеться
до нас зараз із
словами Вітаю вас колеги Мене звати
Джеймс грешин я головний спеціаліст
освіти у світовому банку я очолюю робочу
програму освіти по Україні відмені
організації хочу подякувати тутешніму
уряду і міністерству освіти і науки і
ecd за запрошення взяти участь у цій
конференції з представлення результатів
Піза
2022 результати дають унікальну
можливість країні забезпечити розуміння
того що знають учні на сьогодні що вони
розуміють і як вони проявляють себе в
математиці та інших дисциплінах Як ми
знаємо на постала великою проблемою для
тешньої системми освіти продлисть оцінка
потреб у березні 23го року і по
результатах ми бачимо що 78 до мільйонів
доларів США будуть потрібні для
відбудови інфраструктури освіти А що 28
мільонів потребуватиметеся щоб
забезпечити стійкість процесу навчання
ці дані це тільки поверхове розуміння
того з чим стикаються учні та вчителі
стикаючи з викликами ми маємо визнати що
відбудова йде за межі просто
інфраструктури
освіти інформація з інших країн які
постраждали від виійни І вказає на те що
серед наслідків ми бачимо нерівність в
освіті через те що зменшується
інвестиції в надання високоякісного
навчання і
погіршується середовище для навчання іє
обмеження в підтримці вчителів в плані
їх підготовкити Піза для України - це
великий крок до оцінки доробків учнів з
2018 року в навчанні це оцінює те як
відбився конфлікт на них як ми
очікували відбитки війни і
пандемії нашкодили результатам навчання
учнів і частка тих хто не допрацьовує в
цьому вирісла по всіх предметах Також ми
маємо додати до результатів ще додаткові
академічні перетрубації які не охоплені
цим дослідженням результати не тільки
проловить світла на ті питання з якими
стикаються учні але також це допомагає
визначити варіанти рішень для їх
підтримки така ситуація потребуває
інноваційних та цілеспрямованих дій щоб
зменшити довгострокові відбитки війни на
освіту і Дані підкреслюють нагальність
таких інвестицій щоб посприяти людському
капіталу Тому ці результати Пізи мають
слугувати не тільки як діагностикою але
і каталізатором для стратегічних
негайних дій щоб підтримати тотутешніх
учнів ві за 2022 входить в інші напрями
роботи уряду з модернізації системи
освіти виходячи з придного досвіду це
може бути фактором післявоєнного
відновлення якщо використовувати це на
рівні твореня політики і включати це в
існуючий процес рефомування на практиці
це буде означати що резутати Піза будуть
доведені до шкіл до
класів оцінка
і реформи освіти будуть ефективними
тільки тоді якщо вони будуть мотивувати
на всіх рівнях уряду якісь дії Я думаю
що це вдасться і тут Україна зможе це
використати для того щоб забезпечувати
учбові плани на основі компетенції і всі
підходи до навчання будуть заточені під
потреби учнів і спроможносте вчителів
Таким чином країна може не тільки
розібратися з прогалинами в навчанні але
також закласти підморки для більш
стійкої Іда но системи
освіти по-друге Піза підкреслює що
важливо фундаментальну освіту
забезпечувати щоб на дошкільних закладах
і інших все було прив'язано до
покращення результатів навчання
майбутньому по результату ми бачимо що
країна має забезпечувати доступ і
покращувати якість ранньої освіти щоб
всі діти були б готовими вчитися в
майбутньому покращення системи освіти
має розпочинатися на шкіму рівні Де
учні вчиться рахувати та читати а потім
переходить до мислення і розв'язання
певних задач хочу також підкреслити те
що Піза стосується і інтеграції ринку
праці і вищої освіти учні мають
готуватися до глобального світу
взаємопов'язаного де академічнії навички
почитанні науці та математиці необхідні
але це хоч недостатньо в літі ми
говоримо також про критичне мислення
цифрові навички і креативність це
важливо для того щоб була відбудова і
відновлення в країні на перспективу всі
ці аспекти охоплені в рамках цього
вивчення Піза Ми сподіваємося що країна
про це подумає в плані модернізації
своєї системи освіти і провтехнавчання
також ми готові підтримувати мін
освіти в цих реформах далекосяжних з
Минулого року ми надавали кошти
на підтримки уряду щоб безперевна була
система навчання і ми також забезпечуємо
і наступні етапи нашої підтримки ми
активно Працюємо з мон
щоб розширювати нашу допомогу з
урахуванням того що слід покращувати
доступ до персонального навчання і
підвищення якості освіти і ми
хочемо співставляти свою фінансову та
технічну підтримку з результатами
Піза Світовий банк також надає технічну
допомогу щоб допомогти країні знизити
прогалену між екстреним реагуванням на
потреби в навчанні і те що було втрачено
в освіті Ми хочемо зробити так щоб по
даних Піза ми провели діагностику і
змогли б не тільки відновити доступ до
освіти але також покращити взагалі
якість
освіти можеми очікуємо що резутати Піза
стануть підмурком для стратегії для того
щоб наша підтримка країні була
цілеспрямована під потреби учнів і
вчителів
і системи освіти в
цілому на завершення Я хочу ще раз
підкреслити що участь у Піза це
серйозний здобуток для країни
цей зазвичай не просто провести участь у
Піза під час війни це свідчить про те що
ви хочете дбати про освіту і про людськи
каптал і також це говорить про стійкість
українського народу Ми сподіваємося що
країна буде спиратися на найбутні уроки
останнього вивчання Піза і ми на рівні
світового банку готові підтримати
подальшу роботу вашу в плані оцінки та
відсідковання освітніх здобутків всіх
учнів країни Ще раз дякую за запрошення
виступити перед вами сьогодні і бажаю
вам продуктивного діалогу на цьому
заході
нашою стійкістю захоплюється не тільки
Джеймс і наші інші колеги але і людина
яка подолала 32 години шляху величезний
довгий шлях з Парижу до
Києва приїхала сюди з відкритим серцем з
купою емоцій щоби поділитися даними
організації економічного співробітництва
та розвитку опублікованими в
міжнародному звіті зокрема говорити про
те яких результатів набула Україна саме
в цьому циклі Піза вітайте гійома буске
представника організації економічного
співробітництва і
[оплески]
розвитку
Добрий день я відповідаю за роботу з
даними вd Мене звати мске Я вже працюю
років
сімм вдруге Я працюю з даними по України
в системі Піза і радий сьогодні
представити основні результати Піза 2022
от цього міжнародного
звіту хочу нагадати про те що таке Піза
це міжнародне обстеження по
математиці читанню та про од наукових
дисциплінах з 2000 року це проводиться в
22му
році 690 студентів по світу з різних
країн було
охоплено вони проходили тести і
анкетування України бере участь вдруге в
цьому циклі
досліджень Сьогодні ми представляємо
перші два
розділи звіту це стосується основні
результати порівності а далі
навчання під час війни з урахуваннями
ковідної
кризи хочу підказати що дані які ми
сьогодні
говоримо представляють
25-30% від повного циклу даних які ми
опрацьовували в
пізе потім будуть видені інші розділи по
креативному мисленню фінансової
бізненості Я думаю що я вернуся і згодом
представлю і цю частину потім
щодо
результатів Сингапур по математиці
найкраще себе появив по читанню і по
пророднонаукових дисциплінах і в
Сінгапурі Ну вони на три роки вперед
просинулися відносно середнього
показнику по всіх предметах цих трьох
цей рівень набагато вище ніж у інших
країн Україна вона не дотягує до
середнього показника
поd можна її порівняти з ісландією
особливо по читанню та наукових
дисциплінах є пять-шість країн оd які
також мають подібні результати по цих
предметах Питання постоє в тому що після
пандемії який є в цілому стан навчання
за останні роки інформаційна технологія
багато в чому
змінилася 17-му Піза показувала що
половина учнів не
можуть розрізняти факти або
думки технології підвищують математичні
навички серед дітей та
учнів у 22-му році пониження результатів
з математики було безпрецедентни на 15
балів це
75% пороку навчання це велике зниження
найвеличезніша зміна була раніше чотири
бали А тепер 15 Отже ковідна криза
стоїть за цим зниженням в першу
чергу але це не пояснює повну ситуацію
Якщо говорити про короткострокові
результати от по математиці можна
сказати що в Європі також є
зниження в Азії стабільна ситуація а по
читанню та науці було
краще Європа Америка і інші мають
зниження якщо дивитись на перспективу ми
бачимо що результати по науці і
математиці і читанню вони знизилися
повсюди в оd
ми порівнюємо цей результати яки було 20
років тому є зниження за останні чотири
роки зокрема втрата результатів склала
75% по математиці половина по читанню по
науці там не було великих змін
минулого разу
були не всі країни реагують однаково
Якщо розглядати
траєкторії результатів по математиці то
можна сказати що не ну в деяких країнах
є зростання там в Колумбії в Чорногорії
в Португалії це країни
оd там зростають результати а в Великих
країнах од Фінляндія Франція Німеччина
там є зниження
посякдень ковідна ситуація частково це
пояснює Але не повністю
є навіть різниця в самих цих країнах не
тільки поміж
ними є учні з різного походження і так
воно було останні 20 років в багатьох
країнах є от Велика різниця між
походженням учнів соціальним походженням
мє велике питання навіть якщо ми
говоримо про підвищення рівня середне
кращих учнів то є ті в яких нема гарних
перспектив і є така ситуаці в країнах і
між цима двома категоріями збільшується
різниця
Ми також цікавимося як складаться
ситуація по хлопчиках та дівчатах по
математиці в багатьох країнах з
математикою у хлопчиків краще ніж у
дівчаток це не тільки через стать у 17
країнах у дівчата кращеі дробки ніж у
хлопчиків тобто тут є щось із тим як їх
навчають як вони вчаться по читанню
навпаки у 81 країни яка була охоплена
вивченням 80 країн мається серйозний
розрив між дівчатками та хлопчиками
дівчатки краще читать ніж хлопчики по
науці не було особливої різниці поміж
цима в
країнах як використовуються
ресурси чи гроші можуть змінити щось
докйним
чином можна подумати що якщо дати більше
грошей то зростуть результати навчання
але це не все так просто
якщо дивитись на лівий бік цього слайду
ми бачимо що Сінгапур та Катар
витрачають стільки ж
грошей на
підлітків ерезутати в
Сінгапурі на пть років випередили
ситуацію в катарі якщо поглядати на
Україну То можна побачити що вона краще
себе проявляє ніж очікувалося виходячи з
витрачених грошей на
це відносно інших країн які стільки ж як
ви витратили тому Гроші це важливо але
слід їх витрачати як слід грамотно щоб
інвестувати в підходжі
ресурси брак ресурсів матеріальних це
також проблема як раніше казав
міністр у вас брак ресурсів це велике
питання через війну потрібні автобуси
інфраструктура подикуди
зруйнована якщо не вистачає вчителів і
матеріальної бази то це впливає особливо
на недбані школу це тільки розширює
різниці в результатах і підвищує
нерівність тому важливо забезпечити
роботу щоб скоротити цей розрив особливо
по занедбаних закладах Тому що їм дуже
не вистачає
всього якщо ми
знаємо про ситуацію зі
школами давайте розлянемо ситуацію з
учнями давайте послухаємо про що вони
кажуть в цілому ми бачимо що у більшості
країн
учні задоволені тим що ходять до школи
раніше вже казали що більшність 80%
тотешніх учнів відчувають свою
належність до школи Це велика цифра але
є
зміни в поведінці учнів
Наприклад якщо говорити порацькування В
багатьох країнах є менше
рівенькування Україна тут не присутня
тому тому що ми не могли цей цей тренд
відслідити однак в національному звіті Я
думаю це буде позначено в цілому ми
бачимо що в багатьох
країнах ситуація з іцкуванням знижується
це підвищує результати по математиці
студентам зручніше в школі тоді вони
мають кращі результати в
навчанні безпека в школі - це також
фактор який дозволяє вимірювати здобутки
в навчанні з цим також будуть проблеми
Якщо безпека в школі підвищиться на один
бал то ми
бачимо зміни по ситуації зростають
наприклад еозти по
математиці тобто у учнів є можливість
вчитися і краще концентруватися і в того
і більший результат кращий чим ми можемо
зарадити в цих наших звітах Ми даємо
різні дані
це на 500 сторінок такий документ Я не
буду все розлядати
резану один пункт це наявність цифрових
приладів Це важлива річ особливо це ми
відчули під час ковідної кризи можна
сказати що якщо учень витрачає 30 хвилин
на день використовуючи цей цифровий
прилад в нього Результати будуть більше
ніж у того в кого такого нема Тому ці
прилади зараз дуже важливі і важливо
розумієте що тут йдеться про ключові
навички для того щоб потім увійти до
ринку праці водночас із цим ми бачимо що
75%
учнів впевнено використовують цифрові
прилади і платформи приблизно 40% з них
не відчувають в собі мотивацію щоб це
долучати до роботи в школі ковідна криза
показала що учні можуть адаптуватися в
рамках системи освіти щодо використання
цих приладів водночас із цим фізична
присутність у школі це тим неменш
важливий Фактор і вчителі тоді мають
безпосередній контакт з учнями і можуть
їм допомагати краще ми також відзначаємо
що якщо брати зновтаки цифрові прилади
вони можуть ламатися тому важливо
контролювати те як дитина використовує
цей прила
прилад от час
використання в рамках однієї години це
підвищуй результат якщо забагато годин
провести за приладом тоді результати
падають ну є таке вивчення і ми бачимо
яка тривалість використання призводить
до падіння або підвищення
результату тут Україна має бути десь
справа я цифри не бачу А ви бачите Ну
вона має бути десь справа там
Це ті країни які Серед лідерів по
використанню цифрових приладів ковідна
ситуація і війна вони є першопричиною
такої ситуації але гарне те що якщо
дивитися на це можна дивитися на
о таку ситуацію що
цифрові прилади не шкодять людям учням в
більшості країн і У вас таке ж саме
Тобто ви маєте навчити вірно
використовувати навчити дітей вірно
використовувати ці прилади даних багато
і те що я показав це тільки невеличкий
зріст того що є в
звіті я багато чого там про школи про
учнів про добробут про зміну
звичок на вебсайті Піз можна подивитись
більше даних На завершення хочу сказати
про Україну про освітян вчителів
директорів шкіл учнів у 2018 році я вже
працював упіза Україна тоді вперше брала
участь Якщо вперше береш участь то ваші
дані розглядають іважно щоб не було
помилок щоб все було якісно щоб ніхто
там не махлювали з
тестами і я займався от на першому етапі
цим ми були дуже ле
якісті коли в 22-му ми це проводили ми
подумали що зберемо щерез дані побачимо
що змінилося за останні чотири
роки ми подумали що може цього разу
України не буде тому що є інші
пріоритети але
ви взяли участь у вивченні Пізи і я
знову отримав дані і
я а коли отримав ваші дані Я не був
здивований Я був Я просто оцінив якість
і рівень залучення з вашого
боку на те щоб все було гарно Я б сказав
що це перевершило очікування Тобто ви
вийшли на вищий рівень Піза для себе
серед інших країн у вас не такі
обставини як у інших країн зараз ви
можете сказати учням вчителям батькам І
всім освітянам про те що вони можуть
пишатися своїми
доробками побачимо що буде в
20256 роках Я ще працювати сподіваюсь в
Піза і я думаю Там ми отримаємо Ще кращі
результати по вашій системі
освіти чути що твої дані є абсолютно
чистими І що міжнародні колеги
захоплюється чистотою твоїх даних це
справді велика робота всієї команди тому
що ми проводили дослідження і ви знаєте
про це абсолютно чесно прозоро
відповідно до тих процедур яким
довіряють яким довіряють тепер ще й
міжнародні колеги тому що бачать на наші
дані власне пан Гійом говорив про те як
захоплюється вчителями України є вчителі
в Україні які за якими захоплюється весь
світ прошу до слова Артура пройдакова це
переможець національної премії Global
teacher prize і фіналіст міжнародної
премії Global teacher Price фантастичний
вчитель української
мови 11 1 2 3 дякую за запрошення дуже
приємно бути тут і дуже приємно
скористатися нагодою виступити Тут
напевно не насамперед як представник
громадського сектору як представник кола
освітян і коло вчителів які
безпосередньо співпрацюють з дітьми і
так чи інакше впливають на результати
Піза в тому числі і Піза
2022 Сьогодні у нас в Україні триває
тиждень читання який проводиться за
ініціативи українського інституту книги
і мені випала честь поговорити якраз про
читання не знаю чи це збіг обставин чи
ні але але підозрюю що сьогодні коли
офіційна комунікація буде від
українського центру оцінюння якості
освіти То напевно що найбільше уваги
серед освітян батьків і спільноти в
Україні буде присвячено саме результатам
з читання тому що саме Там ми маємо
найбільше прогалини і найстрімкіше
падіння яке у нас є за результатами в
порівнянні із математикою в порівнянні
із природничими науками і Відповідно ми
маємо поговорити про те чому це сталося
Чому це відбувається а власне Я не хочу
претендувати на якусь об'єктивність
Напевно це буде початок дискусії я
підозрюю що сьогодні в соцмережах буде
багато дописів на цю тему про те чому у
нас такі показники як треба з ними далі
боротися що треба діяти чи варто щось
діяти з чого починати тому власне Я
скористаюсь таким правом поділитися
своїми думками і за закликати залучати
вас до дискусії про те чому у нас такі
показники з читанням і як ми можемо на
це Власне кажучи Вплинути Отже якщо ми
будемо говорити У нас є презентація на
екрані чи
[музика]
ні зараз буде якщо не буде то я можу
сказати про те що в моєму досвіді чомусь
серед батьків моїх учнів учениць є такий
стереотип що є хардові предмети як
математика як фізика як біологія можливо
хімія там де треба обов'язково
виконувати дома завдання там де треба
мати чіткі результати чіткі показники А
є предмети які такі більш лайтові і до
числа більш лайтових предметів чомусь
спільнота батьків дуже часто зараховує
результати з літератури де можна в
принципі твір прочитати можна прочитати
скорочено можна подивитися YouTube відео
можна послухати подкаст і якимось чином
про цей твір якось розказати розповісти
і отримати результати отримати оцінку і
рухатися далі але виникає запитання чи
варто взагалі читати і і яка функція
читання зокрема в школі Якщо ми будемо
говорити про це Е то Власне кажучи ми
можемо сказати що читання окрім якихось
академічних результатів Може містити
емоційне задоволення Може містити утіху
Може містити позитивну інформацію і Може
містити корисну інформацію і власне
кажучи Власне кажучи навичка читання
вона залишається Важливо не тільки для
учнів в середній школі в початковій чи в
старшій школі а ці навички вони будуть
важливими корисними для людини протягом
всього життя недаремно ми говоримо про
навчання впродовж всього життя long life
Learning І власне кажучи читання в цьому
якраз сприяє і допомагає Власне кажучи
на презентації яку ми з вами скоро
побачимо або Не побачимо перший слайд
власне про те що читання дозволяє нам
різноманітно використовувати свої
підходи в подальшому житті але якщо ми
говоримо про читання в школі то тут ми
стикаємося з вами з дещо інакшими
підходами і тут можливо це можливо А
може ні саме це впливає на те що в нас є
нижчі показники з літератури саме за
дослідженням Піза 2022 будь ласка
наступний
слайд Ага тільки у
мене є та Чудово дякую Отже ми з вами
дійшли про те що читання є в школі І
власне кажучи мені здається що у нас є
деякі проблеми які недоста проговорені А
про які варто говорити Сьогодні можливо
саме це впливає на не дуже високі
показники зчитання в програмі з
української літератури є багато текстів
і по суті коли ми навіть зараз говоримо
про онлайн навчання або про змішане
навчання вчитель або вчителька
літератури української чи світової так
чи інакше має цю програму вичитати щоб
записати в журналі програму виконану або
в електронній версії виставити оцінки
річні і так чи інакше Ми оглядово
бігаємо і всі ці твори маємо вичитати
для того щоб діти мали якесь розуміння і
власне кажучи на виході ми і маємо якесь
розуміння про ті чи інші твори Тобто ми
оглядово знайоммось із суттю книжок плюс
У нас є такий момент Який теж варто
проговорити що потрібно задля оцінки на
уроці з літератури коли в класі є 15
тире 30 дітей достатньо учню або учениці
протягом 45 хвилин двічі відповісти на
запитання вчителя або вчительки в
принципі оцінка вже в кишені є ці
запитання будуть наприклад хто є
головний герой Куди він рухається що він
хоче зробити що він робить і що на
виході отримує тобто по суті це фактаж І
власне кажучи в дослідженні Піза 2022 ми
бачимо що учні учениці наші українські
вони дуже добре можуть дати собі раду із
тими завданнями де треба виявити
фактичний якийсь момент фактичну помилку
або прямо в тексті В конкретному реченні
знайти якийсь нюанс і його озвучити його
знайти а власне там де нам треба
подумати поміркувати встановити логічну
відповідність там уже нас є проблеми і
можливо це пов'язано з тим що зокрема в
школі ми на це акцент не робимо що я маю
знати задля складання іспиту зновутаки
якщо ми подивимося з вами на ЗНО з
української літератури яке у нас було дО
оголошення повномасштабної війни а
точніше не Оголошення До старту
повномасштабного вторнення то ми
поговоримо про те що на ЗНО для того щоб
отримати високий бал з літератури
достатньо було знати де відбуваються
події твору коли вони відбуваються Хто є
головним героями твору особливості
знову-таки сюжету і на ЗНО з української
літератури не варто було встановлювати
якісь смислові зв'язки можливо було
просто навіть завчити якісь певні дані і
було багато довідників такої інформації
де можна було прочитати хто куди наві що
рухається І власне кажучи отримати
результати відповідно все це може
впливати на те що у нас виникають
негативні тенденції діти на мою думку
здебільшого уникають або бояться
креативних завдань коли ми кажемо що на
уроці пишемо діти кажуть А можна щось
інакше можна щось там тести дайте нам
будь ласка Ми тести будемо вигадувати
писати і так далі тобто У нас є ситуація
коли писати діти а не дуже люблять і б
не дуже хочуть і в вони ще цього можуть
уникати відповідно Коли потім треба десь
більше подумати ніж межі якоїсь норми ми
маємо з вами негативні результати У нас
є таке поняття яке Я назвав Загублені
поміж абзацами Коли у нас є текст
складається з чотирьох-п'яти абзаців А
не дай боже Є ще два-три тексти і треба
установити між ними логічні зв'язки діти
починають губитися вони прочитали перший
абзац вони можуть відтворити перший
абзац що в другому що в третьому що в
четвертому вже важко якось провести
якісь логічні зв'язки А якщо ми просимо
щоб діти почитали текст а потім пере
знайшли взаємозв'язок з текстом б і з
текстом в у дітий у дітей виникає
плутанина і каша в голові відповідно
зновутаки Можливо тому що ми в школі
якраз натаскуємо на те що швидко пройти
цей твір прочитати його скорочено
оглянути хто куди Що робив і на основі
цього ми виставляємо оцінку то діти
відповідно далі І не хочуть це все
робити Ну і власне тенденції про те що в
тексті діти можуть знаходити очевидні
речі і про це в нас ідеться і в
підручниках з літератури дібрати
заголовок до тексту визначити основну
думку визначити ідею охарактеризувати
персонажів цитатна характеристика або
щось ще визначити проблеми і на цьому в
принципі аналіз твору вважається
виконаним тобто якщо дитина може твір
переказати може визначити думку ідею то
я можу сказати що ця дитина можливо
матиме 10 або 11 балів з літератури або
за урок або за семестр і так далі
відповідно у нас з вами виникає ситуація
коли ми в школі готуємо дітей до одного
А коли діти стикаються
із завданнями на Піза або десь завдання
підвищеної складності діти починають
плутатися ми з вами чудово знаємо багато
мудрих цитат і фраз про читання Зокрема
я для нашого на сьогоднішньої зустрічі
вивів цитату Василя Сухомлинського Про
те що читання впливає безпосередньо на
мислення на розумовий розвиток але так
переконати дітей до читання нам стає не
дуже просто зараз мудрою цитатою Василя
Сухомлинського зновутаки варто говорити
про те що читання сьогодні це про основи
медіаграмотності коли діти читають
анонімні telegram-канали коли вони
порпаються в купі фейків ми маємо
розуміти що якщо дитина матиме основи
критичного мислення і вдумливого читання
то тоді шансів опинитися в пасці буде
набагато менше ми говоримо про те що
завдяки читанню ми можемо пізнавати
інформацію здобувати освіту власне
вивчати інші мови Коли ми можемо читати
тексти і пізнавати нову реальність Ну і
про те що ми говорили навчання впродовж
життя читаючи людина може пізнавати
якісь інші обрії якісь інші можливості
відкривати для себе світ чогось нового
Чого бракує сьогодні Тобто ми окреслили
певні проблеми на мою думку зновутаки
закликаю до дискусії тенденції які нині
в українських школярів є і вони є а
через виклики ковід вони є Б через
повномасштабне вторгнення Росії і вони є
в через те що ми в принципі на цьому не
фокусуємось Мені здається що в нинішній
українській літературі шкільному курсі
не вистачає деяких аспектів які я можу
вам акцентувати занурення до текстів Ми
дуже хапливо хапаємо не знаю один текст
один фрагмент Один другий третій
намагаємося все це запам'ятати потім
написала тестову роботу на 12 запитань і
вже на наступне завдання у нас інший
текст нам не вистачає вдумливого
занурення до тексту І можливо зараз
скажу таку не знаю річ можливо
революційну а можливо ні тому що про це
говорить багато моїх колег уже протягом
тривалого часу читати менше творів але
якісніше не 35 творів за один навчальний
рікар нехай це буде там сім до 10 творів
7 тире 10 творів і ми їх читаємо менше
Але розбираємо детально аналізуємо
зв'язок із сучас часним життям і так
далі ми маємо враховувати власне
читацький та життєвий досвід в одному із
завдань Піза Я думаю що Ви матимете
нагоду потім ознайомитись із
результатами і почитати детальний опис
детальний звіт саме присвячений блоку
читання є завдання про те що виявити
плюси і недоліки власної правової
системи в вашій державі Тобто ми через
текст апелюємо до власного читацького
або в життєвого досвіду учня або учениці
знову-таки учні та учениці не завж
готові порівнювати текст Вони сприймають
його відірвано від реальності начебто це
ось написано я це маю прочитати з дати а
якось пов'язати це з життям Це буде дуже
важко креативного підходу нам не
вистачає у вивченні літератури і те що
важливе те що ми говорили тут і сьогодні
зокрема і в соцмережах і так вирують
дискусії про те що нам треба пропонувати
дітям різні види текстів і можливо нам
варто відмовитись від хронологічного
підходу до вивчення літератури можливо
нам варто акцентувати або на тематичному
підході коли ми вивчаємо блок
присвячений наприклад темі емансипації
темі дружби темі патріотизму е іншим
якимось екологічним темам наприклад і
можливо нам тут якраз варто
використовувати різні медіатексти коли
ми читаємо статтю з одного журналу в
електронній версії коли ми читаємо
дописи Аля дописи пости в Інстаграмі чи
в якихось інших соцмережах тому що це
все є в реальному житті але цього немає
на шкільних уроках літератури І власне
кажучи мені здається що ось ці питання
які ми з вами порушимо ми на них не
знайдемо сьогодні відповіді впродовж
того часу який мені сьогодні виділено
Але мені здається що треба ці питання
ставити вступати в дискусії разом з
експертами вчителями літератури тому що
ці показники які у нас є вони просіли
всюди і в Польщі зокрема і в Естонії У
нас вони просіли більш катастрофічно
аніж в інших країнах відповідно нам
варто прийняти це довідома і думати що
робити далі Як на мене знову таки у
звіті написано цитату Андреса шляйхера
про те що результати дослідження Піза
можуть стати стартом для змін підходів в
освіті для змін і написання нових
освітніх політик і Можливо коли як не
зараз коли ми бачимо з вами різьке
падіння читання нам варто те про що ми
так багато говорили спробувати втілити в
життя якщо ми спробуємо це втілити в
життя у нас не вийде Ну принаймні ми
спробували Але якщо ми не будемо цього
робити у нас будуть знову ті самі
результати Можливо навіть гірше тому
Власне кажучи завершую цитатою Ернеста
Міллера гемінгувея про те що гарна книга
подібна до айсбергу 7/8х якого приховано
під водою зновутаки ми на виході в школі
хочемо зробити твір доступним для всіх
щоб ми чітко розуміли що хотів сказати
автор яка основна думка яка основна тема
ідея а можливо в тому й сенс Коли у нас
є певна недосказаність коли один учень
трактує цей твір От по одному інша уче
це трактує інакше і можливо в цьому
якраз і полягає виуч літератури Тож у
нас повторюючи слова голови комітету
освіти науки і інновацій пана бабака
дуже багато попереду роботи і сподіваюсь
що це дослідження зможе пришвидшити наші
процеси на шляху до
запровадження якісних нових підходів до
вивчення літератури зокрема
дякую
Дякую щиро дякую пане артуре власне ви
бачите що в нашій програмці відбулися
невеличкі зміни і тому говоритиму я а
потім пані Ольга і якщо можна мою
презентацію будь ласка на
слайд попри очікування Я не говоритиму
про результати Піза тому що результати -
Це точно щось Що Мої колеги уже
висвітлюють і ми продовжимо говорити про
них в наступних
наших в наступних
наших обговореннях наприклад під час
панельної дискусії яка відбудеться
одразу після кава пауза власне
міжнародне дослідження якості освіти
Піза - це той Перший великий міжнародний
проект який проводить Україна після
відмови від тімса На жаль в 2011 році ви
всі пам'ятаєте як припинилася участь
України в teімсі і попри те що Україна
отримала результати потрапила до
міжнародної бази даних але ґрунтовно
обговорення результатів звіту та
пропрацювання цих результатів так і не
відбулося вважаю що основна місія
команди Піза сьогодні в Україні - це те
щоби така печальна доля тімса не
спіткала міжнародне дослідження якості
освіти
Піза що ми мали в лютому 22го року
коли Росія вторглася на територію
України
власне ми мали війну в країні
повномасштабну велику жорстоку ми мали
регіони де абсолютно неможливо було
проводити жодні дослідження І власне
освітній процес там був під питанням ми
мали регіони які мають і маємо дуже
велику на жаль дуже великий кордон із
Росією або Білорусію це означає що ворог
у тебе прямо за спиною а то краще просто
на твоїй спині ми маємо постійні
повітряні триво ми маємо віялові
відключення
електроенергії пізніше впродовж року
ворог почав атакувати нашу енергосистему
і ми мали ці втрати і відчували ці
втрати тож коли
Влітку ми замислилися над тим А чи
проводити пізо в української команди
були посутні питання про те чи варто це
робити І вони були абсолютно
обґрунтовані я не думаю що у когось
виникали би сумніви в нашому завзятті і
в тому що ми готові горе звертати
особливо після того як ми провели все ж
таки національний мультипредметний тест
і за кордоном не лише в Україні але тут
питання були тому що коли ми говоримо
про Національний мультипредме
мультипредметний тест ми говоримо про
вступ Відповідно ми говоримо про те що є
мотивований вступник який розуміє все що
відбувається і все ж приходить до
тимчасового екзаменаційного центру коли
ми говоримо про пізу ситуація зовсім
інша це дослідження і чому я як мама маю
довірити свою дити
цим людям чому вчитель має прийти Цей
заклад освіти для того щоб його
проводити
але ми мали не тільки те про що я
сказала ми мали ще абсолютно фантастичні
і мали і мали і маємо фантастичні
заклади освіти коли ми Звернулися до
закладів освіти в липні з'ясувати
ситуацію з учасниками з'ясувати ситуацію
з учнями де взагалі перебувають заклади
освіти в якому форматі Вони працюють як
вони працюють Ми зрозуміли що заклади
освіти по-перше з нами Усі на зв'язку А
по-друге всі Які взагалі можуть
проводити дослідження готові це робити
ми мали дуже сильні і маємо дуже сильні
департаменти освіти які готові були
підтримувати нас в усіх наших діях мріях
і
сподіваннях ми маємо сильну команду в
українському регіональному регіональних
центрах оцінювання якості освіти ці
команди є незламними У нас є центр в
Харкові
є центр який був в Донецьку тепер він у
Слов'янську А тепер він ще десь є центр
в Херсоні але ці люди працювали працюють
і працюватимуть надалі для того щоб
робити освіту Україну кращою ми мали
фантастичних друзів регіональних
координаторів дослідження і фахівців з
питань моніторингу дослідженьня які
працювали з нами і в попередньому циклі
які були готові робити все що від них
залежало для того щоби дослідження
відбулося Я вже говорила про те яку
фантастичну підтримку надали нам колеги
з організації економічного
співробітництва і розвитку як швидко
оперативно зреагував інститут освітньої
аналітики коли треба було знаходити дані
по закладах які На жаль уже подекуди
були неактуальними тому що відбулося те
що
відбулося ми мали всіх вас
ті хто присутні в цій залі також тих хто
знаходиться за тим екраном які тримали
за нас кулачки говорили що все вийде Я
дуже добре пам'ятаю Дмитра Завгороднього
який якось зустрімена в коридорі і
сказав Тетяно Піза треба я кажу Ну ти
розумієш ситуацію як це все відбувається
він мені сказав ви можете зробити
неможливе
можливим і
це і це абсолютно правда неможливе
можливим це фактично наше кредо девіз Я
не знаю як це правильно сказати саме
завдяки цій фантастичній підтримці
дружбі єдності спільності ми маємо ті
результати які є і про які пан Гійом
говорив що вони доволі чисті а це
означає що ми отримали дані які
дозволяють робити аналітичні висновки і
дозволяють над ними працювати ось ці
заклади освіти з 18 регіонів які
потрапили в міжнародний звіт окремо я
скажу про результати Дніпра у нас були
заклади освіти з Дніпра але на жаль вони
не не попали потрапили до міжнародної
бази тільки тому що було дуже мало цих
закладів для всього східного регіону але
ми клінно вдячні тим освіттянам з Дніпра
які попри великі повітряні тривоги
проводили це дослідження ваші результати
не там але ваші результати в серці і ми
знаємо що ви це
зробили Що ми маємо
тепер ми маємо надійне джерело
інформації про те якою є освіта та в
Україні після довготривалого карантину і
після майже
року великої
війни ми можемо дивитися на свої дані і
на міжнародному і на вітчизняному тлі ми
можемо аналізувати їх і відповідно
можемо вибудовувати політики засновані
на цих
даних ми не тільки провели це
дослідження але й надихнули команду
едкемп Україна і державну команду
державної служби якості освіти для того
щоби почати інше
дослідження також дослідження
організації економічного співробітництва
і розвитку це дослідження
соціально-емоційних навичок І власне
Основний етап цього дослідження вже
проведений в цьому році Тобто ми не лише
здатні самі проводити ці великі
реалізовувати ці великі проєкти А ми й
надихаємо своїм прикладом наших
партнерів і колег ми маємо серйозну
аналітичну команду ми вдячні організації
економічного співробітництва і розвитку
за те що двічі поспіль наші провідні
аналітикині Пані Марія мазарчук та пані
Ганна Бочко беру брали участь в
програмах для аналітиків І власне те що
ви тримаєте в руках такий якісний звіт
це величезна робота цих шановних пані
але також це величезна підтримка
організації економічного співробітництва
розвитку тому що дотичність до найкращих
світових
практик - це те до чо нас запросили і
чого не могло би бути якби команда в нас
не вірила і Якби ми не підтримували тате
що ця Віра
виправдана ми маємо політичну волю до
використання результатів Я гадаю що
після такої великої презентації ні в
кого немає сумнівів у тому що результати
будуть використані тому що ми про це
почули
від найвищих посадовців а це означає що
так і буде міжнародний звіт і
український націона льний звіт про
результати Піза уже є на сайті Піза
України ви можете зайти на цей сайт Піза
тестпортал gf.ua
завантажити результати і національного
звіту і міжнародного і працювати із ними
в першу чергу починаючи з
ознайомлення що буде далі великі команди
така такі як команда українського центру
це команди які більше планують і йдуть
уперед
а не дивляться назад можливо це не
завжди добре але у нас дуже далекі дуже
такі серйозні плани тому важливо їх
починати реалізовувати вже сьогодні
наступного року і про це ми вже говорили
буде оприлюднено звіт про результати
участі Україні України в галузі
креативного
мислення всі чекають на ці результати І
я впевнена що і міжнародні результати і
результати України в цій інноваційній
галузі будуть цікавими для аналітиків і
дослідників наступного року україномовні
освітяни які На жаль ще не опанували
англійською зможуть ознайомитися і з
Міжнародним звітом за результатами
дослідження перший том ми обов'язково
перекладемо українською мовою для того
щоби ви могли ще глибше працювати з
результатами і з даними
українці підтримали практику організації
економічного співробітництва і розвитку
з підготов тематичних звітів про
надважливі теми і ми маємо свої такі
добірки ви знаєте що за результатами пі
за 2018 року ми ледь не щомісяця
оприлюднювали нові і нові числа таких
звітів і вони є потужним підґрунтям для
аналітиків вони є дуже важливими для
політиків управлінців для освітян і ми
продовжимо цю роботу і відповідно за
результатами Піза 2022 року числа
Україна в центрі уваги Україна є в
центрі Європи і відповідно в центрі
уваги будуть оприлюднені на сайті
pізаukrain І обов'язково продобльовані
на сайті українського центру Ми
продовжуємо ро розширювати тестувальник
Піза якщо ви вчитель учителька Якщо ви
хочете щоби ваші учні спробували себе в
завданнях справжніх завданнях
міжнародного дослідження перекладених
українською мовою Заходьте на наш
сайт заходьте в тестуваль і пропонуйте
учням завдання з математики
читання природничонаукових дисциплін це
перший крок до того щоби Побачити які це
є завдання і чого нашим підліткам бракує
І що від них очікують на ринку праці
фактично
Піза
2025 уже у нас постійно на робочих
столах ми вже працюємо над цим
дослідженням Чому Тому що Наступного
року ми маємо проводити пілотний етап
тож переклади всіх інструментів
дослідження виконання завдань із вибірки
це те що вже складає велику частину
нашого робочого дня наступного року
пілотний етап дослідження відбудеться
так само на вибірці закладів освіти і
після того як ми провели Основний етап
Піза 2022 в мене немає жодних сумнівів
що наступного року Все буде Що цікавого
про наступний цикл дослідження по-перше
те що Та в ньому буде цікава галузь це
Learning in a Digital World навчання в
цифровому світі а також те що ми
працюємо з організацією економічного
співробітництва розвитку для участі в
компоненті з англійської
мови багато дискусій є про те
чи потрібно наскільки добре опанували
Наші учні англійською мовою який у нас
рівень сформованості англійської мови ми
дізнаємося про це
невдовзі
ми щиро вдячні юніicef Україна за те що
підтримують нас в цьому проєкті і ми
сподіваємося що ми власне за підтримки
юніiceф України зможемо долучитися до
цієї частини грамотності наступний цикл
дослідження буде присвячений природнич
Науковій грамотності Якщо є щось чим я
хотіла б завершити цей сьогоднішній
виступ принаймні цю частину це та що в
тваринному сві до якого ми з вами також
належимо є багато прикладів яких варто і
в нашому людському житті
дотримуватися є істоти які виживають не
завдяки своїй абсолютній силі не завдяки
тому що вони найхитріші не завдяки тому
що в них є найбільше ресурсів а завдяки
тому що вони можуть об'єднуватися в
групи
єдність рятує дуже маленького мурашку і
доволі собі великих таких пінгвінів які
проживають в дуже холодному кліматі якщо
ми говоримо про королівських пінгвінів
це Той досвід який ми точно застосували
і це Той досвід на якому важливо
будувати все що ми далі робимо разом ми
сила United Stand divided We
Fall разом ми та стоїмо А окремо можемо
впасти але ми не будемо падати тому що
ми стоїмо разом я дякую вам і це перша
частина
і це перша частина нашої зустрічі власне
ті з вас хто є глядачами і глядачками Я
запрошую вас до кави на вашій кухні чи
на вашому на вашій роботі а присутніх у
залі Я також запрошую до кави яка буде
там і о
14й годині ми починаємо каву о 15 годині
Я запрошую вас назад нас чекає дуже
багато багато цікавого у нас дискусія і
про важливість даних в освіті і про те
як громадські організації підтримують
освіту і про те над чим варто працювати
в предметній галузі нашим колегам до
зустрічі
як працює Піза програма міжнародного
оцінювання
учнів хоча Піза і була започаткована
організацією економічного
співробітництва та розвитку з осередком
у Парижі Однак до підготовки дослідження
долучаються освітні експерти з усього
світу насправді з часу заснування
програми у 2000 році кожна з понад 80
країн економік учасниць дослідження
сприяла його розвитку найкращі
представники цих країн створювали Тести
які могли б складати підлітки з усього
світу дослідження з'ясовує Якою мірою
підлітки можуть використовувати те що
вони вивчили в школі для виконання
завдань реального життя галузями
дослідження є природничо-наукові
дисципліни математика читання а також
деякі інші інноваційні галузі наприклад
спільне виконання завдань або фінансова
грамотність країни самі ініціюють свою
участь у
дослідженні якщо вся країна не може
взяти участі в такому масштабному
дослідженні долучитися до Піза можуть
окремі її регіони коли участь країни в
дослідженні погоджує керівна рада Піза
формують перелік закладів учасників
учнів обирають випадковим чином так щоб
вони представляли всю систему освіти
були
15тирічними навчалися в сьомому або
старших класах підлітки складають тест
мовою якою
навчаються учнів не просять відтворювати
дати чи імена вивчені в школі натомість
Вони мають використати знання і уміння
щоб інтерпретувати тексти розв'язувати
математичні задачі чи пояснювати певні
природні явища з наукового погляду за
результатами дослідження Учні не
отримують індивідуальних оцінок але їхні
здобутки стають частиною усереднених
даних усієї країни незважаючи на гучні
публікації які з'являються кожні три
роки коли оголошують результати
дослідження Піза не створена для
рейтингування країн Це дослідження по
показує те чи стають заклади освіти
більш або менш ефективними в підготовці
своїх учнів до подальшого навчання чи до
ринку праці це дослідження про те чи
сформовані в 15-тирічних підлітків
соціальні емоційні вміння які їм
доведеться застосовувати в житті як от
уміння спілкуватися чи працювати з
іншими людьми а ще Піза про те як
результати оцінювання стають мільйонами
одиниць даних які не неохідно скласти
для того щоб побачити образ найбільш
ефективних систем освіти загалом
ефективні системи - це ті які дають
широкі можливості для навчання і
найміцнішу підтримку в реалізації свого
потенціалу всім дітям а не тільки тим
які мають гарні передумови для навчання
Піза має на меті не тільки показати те
які це системи але й підтримати країни в
прагненні навчитися з досвіду таких
систем вибудовувати більш справедливу та
інклюзивну
освіту
як Піза програма міжнародного оцінювання
учнів допомагає у розробленні освітніх
реформ кожні три роки результати Піза
показують що можливо зробити в освіті
країни із задоволенням навчаються на
досві інших погляньмо що було зроблено в
Німеччині
року країна із сумом дізналася що кожний
п'ятий учень не досягав навіть базового
рівня сформованості читацької
грамотності також дізналися про
величезний розрив у результатах багатих
і бідних дітей цей показник був
найбільшим серед усіх країн
оср цей пізашок змусив політиків у
галузі освіти приймати рішення школи
повного дня перестали бути винятком а
стали
правилом уряд презентував навчальні
стандарти і створив систему оцінювання
для вимірювання рівнів досягнень цих
стандартів учителів мотивували
інвестувати більше зусиль у власний
професійний розвиток порівняно з іншими
країнами оср Німеччина зрушила з рівня
нижчого від середнього зчитання у 2000
році дорівнює вищого за середн зчитання
у 2015 році здебільшого таке зростання
сталося завдяки підвищенню результатів
найслабших учнів і учнів з
несприятливими передумовами для навчання
в іншій частині світу у Бразилії 2003
року були найнижчі результати Піза
більше ніж половина всіх учнів мала
базовий рівень сформованості
математичної грамотності або й
нижчий менше ніж один учень зі 100 був
на найвищому рівні Бразилія поставила за
мету досягти рівня не нижче за середній
для країн оср до
2021 року за рік до святкування 120ї
річниці Незалежності країни у 2015 році
найслабші учні Бразилії здобули
результати на 34 бали вищі ніж 2003 року
цей результат еквівалент одному
навчальному року і таких високих
результатів країна досягла навіть
незважаючи на те що учнів у сьомому або
старших класах стало майже на 1 мільйон
більше Бразилії Є над чим попрацювати
щоб досягти своєї мети високих
навчальних результатів і стовідсоткового
залучення до освіти 15-тирічних
підлітків країна використовує результат
Піза щоб оцінювати свій прогрес у
глобалізованому світі стандарти якості
освіти не можуть обмежуватися
національними кордонами країни можуть
вчитися одна В одної ефективні політики
можуть бути локалізовані і підігнані під
національні особливості кожна країна чи
економіка може підвищити навчальні
результати та створити більш інклюзивну
освітню систему Піза показує що такі
результати є не лише мрією вони є
досяжною метою
як працює піза- Програма міжнародного
оцінювання
учнів хоча Піза і була започаткована
організацією економічного
співробітництва та розвитку з осередком
у Парижі Однак до підготовки дослідження
долучаються освітні експерти з усього
світу насправді з часу заснування
програми у 2000 році кожна з понад 80
країн економік учасниць дослідження
сприяла його розвитку найкращі
представники цих країн створювали Тести
які могли б складати підлітки з усього
світу дослідження з'ясовує Якою мірою
підлітки можуть використовувати те що
вони вивчили в школі для виконання
завдань реального життя галузями
дослідження є природничо-наукові
дисципліни математика читання а також
деякі інші інноваційні галузі наприклад
спільне виконання завдань або фінансова
грамотність країни самі ініціюють свою
участь у
дослідженні якщо вся країна не може
взяти участі в такому масштабному
дослідженні долучитися до Піза можуть
окремі її регіони коли участь країни в
дослідженні погоджує керівна рада Піза
формують перелік закладів учасників
учнів обирають випадковим чином так щоб
вони представляли всю систему освіти
були
15тирічними навчалися в сьомому або
старших класах підлітки складають тест
мовою якої
навчаються учнів не просять відтворювати
дати чи імена вивчені в школі натомість
Вони мають використати знання і уміння
щоб інтерпретувати тексти розв'язувати
математичні задачі чи пояснювати певні
природні явища з наукового погляду за
результатами дослідження Учні не
отримують індивідуальних оцінок але їхні
здобутки стають частиною усереднених
даних усієї країни незважаючи на гучні
публікації які з'являються кожні три
роки коли оголошують результати
дослідження Піза не створена для
рейтингування країн Це дослідження
показує те чи стають заклади освіти
більш або менш ефективними в підготовці
своїх учнів до подальшого навчання чи до
ринку праці це дослідження про те чи
сформовані в 15-тирічних підлітків
соціальні емоційні вміння які їм
доведеться застосовувати в житті як от
уміння спілкуватися чи працювати з
іншими людьми а ще Піза про те як
результати оцінювання стають мільйонами
одиниць даних які необхідно скласти для
того щоб побачити образ з найбільш
ефективних систем освіти загалом
ефективні системи - це ті які дають
широкі можливості для навчання і
найміцнішу підтримку в реалізації свого
потенціалу всім дітям а не тільки тим
які мають гарні передумови для навчання
Піза має на меті не тільки показати те
які це системи але й підтримати країни в
прагненні навчитися з досвіду таких
систем вибудовувати більш справедлив та
інклюзивну
освіту
як Піза програма міжнародного оцінювання
учнів допомагає у розробленні освітніх
реформ кожні три роки результати Піза
показують що можливо зробити в освіті
країни із задоволенням навчаються на
досвіді інших погляньмо що було зроблено
в
Німеччині 2000 року країна із сумом
дізналася що кожний п'ятий учень не
досягав навіть базового рівня
сформованості читацької
грамотності також дізналися про
величезний розрив у результатах багатих
і бідних дітей цей показник був
найбільшим серед усіх країн
оср цей пізашок змусив політиків у
галузі освіти приймати рішення школи
повного дня перестали бути винятком а
стали
правилом уряд презентував навчальні
стандарти і створив систему оцінювання
для вимірювання рівнів досягнень цих
стандартів учителів мотивували
інвестувати більше зусиль у власний
професійний
розвиток порівняно з іншими країнами оср
Німеччина зрушила з рівня нижчого від
середнього зчитання у 2000 році дорівнює
вищого за середні читання у 2015 році
здебільш чого таке зростання сталося
завдяки підвищенню результатів
найслабших учнів і учнів з
несприятливими передумовами для навчання
в іншій частині світу у Бразилії 2003
року були найнижчі результати Піза
більше ніж половина всіх учнів мала
базовий рівень сформованості
математичної грамотності або й
нижчий менше ніж один учень зі 100 був
на найвищому рівні
Бразилія поставила за мету досягти рівня
не нижче за середній для країн оср до
2021 року за рік до святкування 120ї
річниці Незалежності країни у 2015 році
найслабші учні Бразилії здобули
результати на 34 бали вищі ніж в 2003
року цей результат еквівалентний одному
навчальному року і таки високих
результатів країна досягла навіть
незважаючи на те що учнів у сьомому або
старших класах стало майже на 1 мільйон
більше Бразилії Є над чим попрацювати
щоб досягти своєї мети високих
навчальних результатів і стовідсоткового
залучення до освіти 15тирічних
підлітків країна використовує результат
Піза щоб оцінювати свій прогрес у
глобалізованому світі стандарти як ясті
освіти не можуть обмежуватися
національними кордонами країни можуть
вчитися одна В одної ефективні політики
можуть бути локалізовані і підігнані під
національні особливості кожна країна чи
економіка може підвищити навчальні
результати та створити більш інклюзивну
освітню систему Піза показує що такі
результати є не лише мрією вони є
досяжною
метою
як працює піза- Програма міжнародного
оцінювання учнів
хоча Піза і була започаткована
організацією економічного
співробітництва та розвитку з осередком
у Парижі Однак до підготовки дослідження
долучаються освітні експерти з усього
світу на справді з часу заснування
програми у 2000 році кожна з понад 80
країн економік учасниць дослідження
сприяла його розвитку найкращі
представники цих країн створювали Тести
які могли б складати підлітки з усього
світу дослідження з'ясовує Якою мірою
підлітки можуть використовувати те що
вони вивчили в школі для виконання
завдань реального життя галузями
дослідження є природничо-наукові
дисципліни математика читання а також
деякі інші інноваційні галузі наприклад
спільне виконання завдань або фінансова
грамотність країни самі ініціюють свою
участь у
дослідженні якщо вся країна не може
взяти участі в такому масштабному
дослідженні долучитися до Піза можуть
окремі її регіони коли участь країни в
дослідженні погоджує керівна рада Піза
формують перелік закладів учасників
учнів обирають випадковим чином так щоб
вони представляли всю систему освіти
були 15тирічним навчалися в сьомому або
старших класах підлітки складають тест
мовою якою
навчаються учнів не просять відтворювати
дати чи імена вивчені в школі натомість
Вони мають використати знання і уміння
щоб інтерпретувати тексти розв'язувати
математичні задачі чи пояснювати певні
природні явища з наукового погляду за
результатами дослідження Учні не
отримують ін дуальних оцінок але їхні
здобутки стають частиною усереднених
даних усієї країни незважаючи на гучні
публікації які з'являються кожні три
роки коли оголошують результати
дослідження Піза не створена для
рейтингування країн Це дослідження
показує те чи стають заклади освіти
більш або менш ефективними в підготовці
своїх учнів до подальшого навчання чи до
ринку праці це дослідження про те чи
сформо в 15тирічних підлітків соціальні
емоційні вміння які їм доведеться
застосовувати в житті як от уміння
спілкуватися чи працювати з іншими
людьми а ще Піза про те як результати
оцінювання стають мільйонами одиниць
даних які необхідно скласти для того щоб
побачити образ найбільш ефективних
систем освіти загалом ефективні системи
- це ті які дають широкі можливості для
навчання і найміц підтримку в реалізації
свого потенціалу всім дітям а не тільки
тим які мають гарні передумови для
навчання Піза має на меті не тільки
показати те які це системи але й
підтримати країни в прагненні навчитися
з досвіду таких систем вибудовувати
більш справедливу та інклюзивну
освіту
як піза- програма міжнародного
оцінювання учнів допомагає у зробленні
освітніх
реформ кожні три роки результати Піза
показують що можливо зробити в освіті
країни із задоволенням навчаються на
досвіді інших погляньмо що було зроблено
в
Німеччині 2000 року країна із сумом
дізналася що кожний п'ятий учень не
досягав навіть базового рівня
сформованості читацької
грамотності також дізналися про
величезний розрив у результатах багатих
і бідних дітей цей показник був
найбільшим серед усіх країн
оср цей пізашок змусив політиків у
галузі освіти приймати рішення школи
повного дня перестали бути винятком а
стали
правилом уряд презентував навчальні
стандарти і створив систему оцінювання
для вимірювання рівнів досягнень цих
стандартів
учителів мотивували інвестувати більше
зусиль у власний професійний розвиток
порівняно з іншими країнами оср
Німеччина зрушила з рівня нижчого від
середнього зчитання у 2000 році до рівня
вищого за середні читання у 2015 році
здебільшого таке зростання сталося
завдяки підвищенню результатів
найслабших учнів і учнів з
несприятливими передумовами для навчання
в іншій частині світу у Бразилії 2003
року були найнижчі результати Піза
більше ніж половина всіх учнів мала
базовий рівень сформованості
математичної грамотності або й
нижчий менше ніж один учень зі 100 був
на найвищому рівні Бразилія поставила за
мету досягти рівня не нижче за середній
для країн оср до
2021 року за рік до святкування 120ї
річниці Незалежності країни у 2015 році
найслабші учні Бразилії здобули
результати на 34 бали вищі ніж 2003 року
цей результат еквівалентний одному
навчальному року і таких високих
результатів країна досягла навіть
незважаючи на те що учнів у сьомому або
старших класах стало майже на 1 мльн
більше
Бразилії Є над чим попрацювати щоб
досягти своєї мети високих навчальних
результатів і 100 відсоткового залучення
до освіти 15-тирічних
підлітків країна використовує результат
Піза щоб оцінювати свій прогрес у
глобалізованому світі стандарти якості
освіти не можуть обмежуватися
національними кордонами країни можуть
вчитися одна В одної ефективні політики
можуть бути локалізовані і підігнані під
національні особливості кожна країна чи
економіка може підвищити навчальні
результати та створити більш інклюзивну
освітню систему Піза показує що такі
результати є не лише мрією вони є
досяжною
метою
як працює піза- Програма міжнародного
оцінювання учнів
хоча Піза і була започаткована
організацією економічного
співробітництва та розвитку з осередком
у парижжі Однак до підготовки
дослідження долучаються освітні експерти
з усього світу насправді з часу
заснування програми у 2000 році кожна з
понад 80 країн економік учасниць
дослідження сприяла його розвитку
найкращі представники цих країн
створювали Тести які могли б складати
підлітки з усього світу дослідження
з'ясовує Якою мірою підлітки можуть
використовувати те що вони вивчили в
школі для виконання завдань реального
життя галузями дослідження є
природничо-наукові дисципліни математика
читання а також деякі інші інноваційні
галузі наприклад спільне виконання
завдань або фінансова
грамотність країни самі ініціюють свою
участь у
дослідженні якщо вся країна не може
взяти участі в такому масштабному
дослідженні долучитися до Піза можуть
окремі її регіони коли участь країни в
дослідженні погоджує керівна рада Піза
формують перелік закладів учасників
учнів обирають випадковим чином так щоб
вони представляли всю систему освіти
були
15тирічними навчалися в сьомому або
старших класах підлітки складають тест
мовою якою
навчаються учнів не просять відтворювати
дати чи імена вивчені в школі натомість
Вони мають використати знання і уміння
щоб інтерпретувати тексти розв'язувати
математичні задачі чи пояснювати певні
природні явища з наукового погляду за
результатами дослідження Учні не
отримують індивідуальних оцінок але їхні
здобутки стають частиною усереднених
даних усієї країни незважаючи на гучні
публікації які з'являються кожні три
роки коли оголошують результати
дослідження Піза не створена для
рейтингування країн Це дослідження
показує те чи стають заклади освіти
більш або менш ефективними в підготовці
своїх учнів до подальшого навчання чи до
ринку праці це дослідження про те чи
сформовані в 15-тирічних підлітків
соціальні емоційні вміння які їм
доведеться застосовувати в житті як от
уміння спілкуватися чи працювати з
іншими людьми а ще Піза про те як
результати оцінювання стають мільйонами
одиниць даних які необхідно скласти для
того щоб побачити образ найбільш
ефективних систем освіти загалом
ефективні системи це ті які дають широкі
можливості для навчання і найміцнішу
підтримку в реалізації свого потенціалу
всім дітям а не тільки тим які мають
гарні передумови для навчання Іза має на
мет не тільки показати те які це системи
але й підтримати країни в прагненні
навчитися з досвіду таких систем
вибудовувати більш справедливу та
інклюзивну
освіту
як Піза програма міжнародного оцінювання
учнів допомагає у розробленні освітніх
реформ кожні три роки результати Піза
показують що можливо зробити в освіті
країни із воленням навчаються на досвіді
інших погляньмо що було зроблено в
Німеччині 2000 року країна із сумом
дізналася що кожний п'ятий учень не
досягав навіть базового рівня
сформованості читацької
грамотності також дізналися про
величезний розрив у результатах багатих
і бідних дітей цей показник був
найбільшим серед усіх країн
оср цей за шок змусив політиків у галузі
освіти приймати рішення школи повного
дня перестали бути винятком а стали
правилом уряд презентував навчальні
стандарти і створив систему оцінювання
для вимірювання рівнів досягнень цих
стандартів учителів мотивували
інвестувати більше зусиль у власний
професійний розвиток порівняно з іншими
країнами оср Німеччина зрушила з рівня
нижчого від середнього зчитання у 2000
році до рівня вищого за середн зчитання
у 2015 році здебільшого таке зростання
сталося завдяки підвищенню результатів
найслабших учнів і учнів з
несприятливими передумовами для навчання
в іншій частині світу у Бразилії 2003
року були найнижчі результати Піза
більше ніж половина всіх учнів мала
базовий рівень сформованості
математичної грамотності або й
нижчий менше ніж один учень зі 100 був
на найвищому рівні Бразилія поставила за
мету досягти рівня не нижче за середній
для країн оср до
2021 року за рік до святкування 120ї
річниці Незалежності країни у 2015 році
найслабші учні Бразилії здобули
результати на 34 бали вищі ніж 2003 року
цей результат еквівалентний одному
навчальному року і таких високих
результатів країна досягла навіть
незважаючи на те що учнів у сьомому або
старших класах стало майже на 1 мльйн
більше Бразилії Є над чим попрацювати
щоб досягти своєї мети високих
навчальних результатів і стовідсоткового
залучення до осві 15тирічних
підлітків країна використовує результат
Піза щоб оцінювати свій прогрес у
глобалізованому світі стандарти якості
освіти не можуть обмежуватися
національними кордонами країни можуть
вчитися одна В одної ефективні політики
можуть бути локалізовані і підігнані під
національні особливості кожна країна чи
економіка може підвищити навчальні
результати та створити більш інклюзивну
освітню систему Піза показує що такі
результати є не лише мрією вони є
досяжною
метою
як працює піза- Програма міжнародного
оцінювання
учнів хоча Піза і була започаткована
організацією економічного
співробітництва та розвитку з осередком
у Парижі Однак до під говки дослідження
долучаються освітні експерти з усього
світу насправді з часу заснування
програми у 2000 році кожна з понад 80
країн економік учасниць дослідження
сприяла його розвитку найкращі
представники цих країн створювали Тести
які могли б складати підлітки з усього
світу дослідження з'ясовує Якою мірою
підлітки можуть використовувати те що
вони вивчили в школі для виконання
завдань реального життя галузями
дослідження є природничо-наукові
дисципліни математика читання а також
деякі інші інноваційні галузі наприклад
спільне виконання завдань або фінансова
грамотність країни самі ініціюють свою
участь у
досліджені якщо вся країна не може взяти
участі в такому масштабному дослідженні
долучитися до Піза можуть окремі її
регіони коли участь країни в дослідженні
погоджує керівна рада Піза формують
перелік закладів учасників учнів
обирають випадковим чином так щоб вони
представляли всю систему освіти були
15тирічними навчалися в сьомому або
старших класах підлітки складають тест
мовою якою
навчаються учнів не просять відтворювати
дати чи імена вивчені в школі натомість
Вони мають використати знання і уміння
щоб інтерпретувати тексти розв'язувати
математичні задачі чи пояснювати певні
природні явища з наукового погляду за
результатами дослідження Учні не
отримують індивідуальних оцінок але їхні
здобутки стають частиною усереднених
даних усієї країни незважаючи на гучні
публікації які з'являються кожні три
роки коли оголошують результати
дослідження Піза не створена для
рейтингування країн Це дослідження
показує те чи стають заклади освіти
більш або менш ефективними в підготовці
своїх учнів до подальшого навчання чи до
ринку праці це дослідження про те чи
сформовані в 15-тирічних підлітків
соціальні емоційні вміння які їм
доведеться застосовувати в житті як от
уміння спілкуватися чи працювати з
іншими людьми а ще Піза про те як
результати оцінювання стають мільйонами
одиниць даних які необхідно скласти для
того щоб побачити образ найбільш
ефективних систем освіти загалом
ефективні системи - це ті які дають
широкі можливості для навчання і
найміцнішу підтримку в реалізації свого
потенціалу всім дітям а не тільки тим
які мають гарні передумови для навчання
Піза має на меті не тільки показати те
які це системи але й підтримати країни в
прагненні навчитися з досвіду таких
систем вибудовувати більш справедливу та
інклюзивну
освіту
як Піза програма міжнародного оцінювання
учнів допомагає у розробленні освітніх
реформ кожні три роки результати Піза
показують що можливо зробити в освіті
країни із задоволенням навчаються на
досвіді інших погляньмо що було зроблено
в
Німеччині 2000 року країна із сумо
дізналися що кожний п'ятий учень не
досягав навіть базового рівня
сформованості читацької
грамотності також дізналися про
величезний розрив у результатах багатих
і бідних дітей цей показник був
найбільшим серед усіх країн
оср цей пізашок змусив політиків у
галузі освіти приймати рішення школи
повного дня перестали бути винятком а
стали правилом
уряд презентував навчальні стандарти і
створив систему оцінювання для
вимірювання рівнів досягнень цих
стандартів учителів мотивували
інвестувати більше зусиль у власний
професійний розвиток порівняно з іншими
країнами оср Німеччина зрушила з рівня
нижчого від середнього зчитання у 2000
році дорівнює вищого за середні читання
у 2015 році
здебільшого таке зростання сталося
завдяки підвищенню результатів
найслабших учнів і учнів з
несприятливими передумовами для навчання
в іншій частині світу у Бразилії 2003
року були найнижчі результати Піза
більше ніж половина всіх учнів мала
базовий рівень сформованості
математичної грамотності або й
нижчий менше ніж один учень зі 100 був
на найвищому рівні Бразилія поставила за
мету досягти рівня не нижче за середній
для країн оср до
2021 року за рік до святкування 120ї
річниці Незалежності
країни у 2015 році найслабші учні
Бразилії здобули результати на 34 бали
вищі ніж 2003 року цей результат
еквівалентний одному навчальному року
і таких високих результатів країна
досягла навіть незважаючи на те що учнів
у сьомому або старших класах стало майже
на 1 мльйон більше Бразилії Є над чим
попрацювати щоб досягти своєї мети
високих навчальних результатів і
стовідсоткового залучення до освіти
15тирічних
підлітків країна використовує результат
Піза щоб оцінювати свій прогрес у
глобалізованому світі стандарти якості
освіти не можуть обмежуватися
національними кордонами країни можуть
вчитися одна В одної ефективні політики
можуть бути локалізовані і підігнані під
національні особливості кожна країна чи
економіка може підвищити навчальні
результати та створити більш інклюзивну
освітню систему Піза показує що такі
результати є не лише мрією вони є
досяжною
метою
як працює Піза програма міжнародного
оцінювання
учнів хоча Піза і була започаткована
організацією економічного
співробітництва та розвитку з осередком
у Парижі Однак до підготовки дослідження
долучаються освітні експерти з усього
світу насправді з часу заснування
програми у 2000 році кожна з понад 10ти
країн економік учасниць дослідження
сприяла його розвитку найкращі
представники цих країн створювали Тести
які могли б складати підлітки з усього
світу дослідження з'ясовує Якою мірою
підлітки можуть використовувати те що
вони вивчили в школі для виконання
завдань реального життя галузями
дослідження є природничо-наукові
дисципліни математика читання а також
деякі інші інноваційні галузі наприклад
спільне виконання завдань або фінансова
грамотність країни самі ініціюють свою
участь у
дослідженні якщо вся країна не може
взяти участі в такому масштабному
дослідженні долучитися до Піза можуть
окремі її регіони коли участь країни в
дослідженні погоджує керівна рада Піза
формують перелік закладів учасників
учнів обирають випадковим чином так щоб
вони представляли всю систему освіти
були 15тирічними навчалися в сьомому або
старших класах підлітки складають тест
мовою якою
навчаються учнів не просять відтворювати
дати чи імена вивчені в школі натомість
Вони мають використати знання і уміння
щоб інтерпретувати тексти розв'язувати
математичні задачі чи пояснювати певні
природні явища з наукового погляду за
результатами дослідження учні не
отримують індивідуальних оцінок але їхні
здобутки стають частиною усереднених
даних усієї країни незважаючи на гучні
публікації які з'являються кожні три
роки коли оголошують результати
дослідження Піза не створена для
рейтингування країн Це дослідження
показує те чи стають заклади освіти
більш або менш ефективними в підготовці
своїх учнів до подальшого навчання чи до
ринку праці це дослідження про те чи
сформовані в 15-тирічних підлітків
соціальні емоційні вміння які їм
доведеться застосовувати в житті як от
уміння спілкуватися чи працювати з
іншими людьми а ще Піза про те як
результати оцінювання стають мільйонами
одиниць даних які необхідно скласти для
того щоб побачити образ найбільш
ефективних систем освіти загалом
ефективні системи - це ті які дають
широкі можливості для навчання і
найміцнішу підтримку в реалізації свого
потенціалу всім дітям а не тільки тим
які мають гарні передумови для навчання
Піза має на меті не тільки показати те
які це системи але й підтримати країни в
прагненні навчитися з досвіду таких
систем вибудовувати більш справедливу та
інклюзивну
освіту
як піза- програма міжнародного
оцінювання учнів до допомагає у
розробленні освітніх
реформ кожні три роки результати Піза
показують що можливо зробити в освіті
країни із задоволенням навчаються на
досвіді інших погляньмо що було зроблено
в
Німеччині 2000 року країна із сумом
дізналася що кожний п'ятий учень не
досягав навіть базового рівня
сформованості читацької
грамотності також дізнали про величезний
розрив у результатах багатих і бідних
дітей цей показник був найбільшим серед
усіх країн
оср цей пізашок змусив політиків у
галузі освіти приймати рішення школи
повного дня перестали бути винятком а
стали
правилом уряд презентував навчальні
стандарти і створив систему оцінювання
для вимірювання рівнів досягнень цих
стандартів
учителів мотивували інвестувати більше
зусиль у власний професійний
розвиток порівняно з іншими країнами оср
Німеччина зрушила з рівня нижчого від
середнього зчитання у 2000 році до рівня
вищого за середні читання у 2015 році
здебільшого таке зростання сталося
завдяки підвищенню результатів
найслабших учнів і учнів з
несприятливими передумовами для навчання
в іншій частині світу у Бразилії 2003
року були найнижчі результати Піза
більше ніж половина всіх учнів мала
базовий рівень сформованості
математичної грамотності або й
нижчий менше ніж один учень зі 100 був
на найвищому рівні Бразилія поставила за
мету досягти рівня не нижче за середній
для країн оср до 202
року за рік до святкування 120ї річниці
Незалежності країни у 2015 році
найслабші учні Бразилії здобули
результати на 34 бали вищі ніж 2003 року
цей результат еквівалентний одному
навчальному року і таких високих
результатів країна досягла навіть
незважаючи на те що учнів у сьомому або
старших класах стало майже на 1 мільн
більше Бразилії Є над чим попрацювати
щоб досягти своєї мети високих
навчальних результатів і стовідсоткового
залучення до освіти 15-тирічних
підлітків країна використовує результат
Піза щоб оцінювати свій прогрес у
глобалізованому світі стандарти якості
освіти не можуть обмежуватися
національними кордонами країни можуть
вчитися одна В одної ефективні політики
можуть бути локалізовані і підігнані під
національні особливості кожна країна чи
економіка може підвищити навчальні
результати та створити більш інклюзивну
освітню систему Піза показує що такі
результати є не лише мрією вони є
досяжною
метою
Лілія Гриневич Київський університет
імені Бориса Гринченка проректорка з
наукового педагоічної та міжнародної
діяльності Сергій Горбачов освітній
омбутсмен
і Пані Ольга Будник це фонд президента
України з підтримки освіти науки та
спорту радниця уповноважена
фонду Руслан Васильович Гурак голова
державної служби якості
освіти трансляції
[музика]
немає
можемо починати да Раз
два Таню Дякую що ти зробила мою частину
роботи представила всіх учасників тому
що часу в нас обмаль 40 хвилин і плюс
один учасник дискусії тому Хочеться
швидше перейти власне до обговорення
результатів а оприлюднених сьогодні
години тому Наші ряди суттєво порішили і
я думаю що люди пішли власне
обговорювати результати досліджень
і Ну я я так думаю що саме це є причиною
рішення наших рядів а і Піза вже активно
обговорюється в соцмережах з зокрема у
Фейсбуці ті результати які ми сьогодні
отримали які можна по-різному трактувати
і які ми як
А учасники сьогоднішньої дискусії які
є які представляють певні там певні
політичні сили які є засновниками
співзасновниками неурядових благодійних
організацій мають інтерпретувати і мають
використовувати в першу чергу для тих
освітніх політик за якими має рухатися
наша держава
а пані Лілія я почну з вас тому що саме
ви як міністрка освіти в 2016 році
підписали тристоронню угоду з oecd між
між ecd міністерством освіти науки
України і українським центром оцінювання
якості освіти і під час підписання цієї
угоди Я зацитую ваш коментар який ви
дали
а завдяки цій програмі тобто завдяки
Пізі Ми отримаємо серйозну додаткову
інформацію що допоможе правильно
визначити слабші та сильніші місця нашої
системи освіти і вибудувати орієнтири за
якими далі формуватиметься освітня
політика України ми зараз працюємо над
концепцією нової української школи та це
2016 рік
А яка базуватиметься саме на
компетентнісному підході тому Піза може
дати для України дуже багато Я
сподіваюся що наші вчителі які
ознайомляться з завданнями Піза минулих
років також зрозуміють на прикладі цього
інструментарію що означає
компетентнісний підхід в змісті освіти і
в оцінюванні А ми вочевидь
зможемо оцінити те про що ви говорили
радше вже в наступній Пізі яка буде в
25-му році тому
що саме тоді 15річні Підлітки Які вже
прийшли в нову українську школу будуть
її писати Утім на вашу думку Чи вдалося
дослідженню Піза вплинути на нову
українську школу зважаючи на той
результат який ми отримали цього
року Дякую я вітаю всіх колег в цій залі
і перед тим як відповідати на ваше
важливе питання Я хочу висловити
неймовірну вдячність команді всіх людей
які в таких неймовірно непростих умовах
змогли провести пізу і Україна стала
учасницею цього важливого
дослідження тим більше зараз нам
потрібно верифікувати нашу освітню
політику і освітня політика Вона
відповідає на потреби тоді коли вона
базується на конкретних даних і вся ця
інтенція Обов'язково взяти участь у Пізі
І це ще починав Сергій Миронович Квіт і
в це була Ганна Новосад дуже залучена Я
пам'ятаю я ще була головою комітету з
питань освіти і науки Верховної Ради
України і вже тоді були зроблені основні
перші кроки для того щоб ми зайшли в
пізу після революції гідності тому що
ідея була в тому щоб перестати ховати
голову в пісок і тішити себе різними
міфами подивитися на себе у
зрізі провідних освітніх систем світу
тому що якщо ми маємо європейські
євроатлантичні прагнення та рештою що
там якщо ми прагнемо щоб наші діти мали
успішну самореалізацію
це означає що нам потрібно розуміти Де
ми знаходимося у цій шкалі у порівнянні
з іншими
системами і я переконана що власне оця
ее політика яка базується на даних нам
дає можливість зараз верифікувати яким
чином перезавантажувати реформу нова
українська школа
тому що реформа нова українська школа
яка достатньо успішно йшла в початковій
школі перервалася
ковідом тому що звичайно
діти в початковій школі під час
дистанційного навчання зазнають
неминучих навчальних втрат потім
відбувався період непідтримки самої
реформи А далі війна І от зараз через ці
наслідки війни і виклики війни ми маємо
зважаючи на всі ці вхідні дані і
орієнтуючись на дані Пізи верифікувати
нашу освітню політику тому я вважаю що
сьогодні нуж на основі цих досліджень
має відповісти на питання яким чином
подолати цей розрив в доступі до якісної
освіти між сільськими і міськими дітьми
тому що ми перетворюємося все більш в
сегреговану систему освіти і це тільки
означає те що наші попередні дані які ми
отримували з попередньої Пізи вони
погіршилися в частині доступу до якісної
освіти і ми це частково передбачали тому
що сільське населення до дистанційної
освіти теж мало менший
доступ друге
питання стан дітей Я впевнена що наші
результати читання Які по іршилися теж
пов'язані з станом наших дітей які
травмовані війною тому що саме
прояви когнітивні прояви психоемоційного
стресу передбачають Коли людина не може
дитина не може концентруватися на якісь
інформації відтворювати і
запам'ятовувати її і з цим нам теж треба
буде працювати Це лише два приклади але
дані спізи настільки багатогранні і
важливі що ми можемо працюючи над ними
дуже багато цінної інформації саме зараз
взяти для себе для
коригування напрямків освітньої
політики дякую пані Лілія Сергію я до
вас з наступним питанням продовжуючи ту
лінію яка почала яку почала пані Лілія
А які сьогодні політики мають змінитися
і як оце коригування і зміна підход до
нової української
школи має відобразитися на політиках і я
що ви як Як представник комітету з
освіти і науки плануєте з цим робити Та
дякую я почну теж з якихось таких
приємних слов Я пам'ятаю жовтень
Минулого року я заїхав до українського
центру оцінювання якості до Тані щось
там спитати про освітні втрати До речі
ми щось обговорювали і вона каже Дивись
от зараз якраз там от от от там якась
там вебкамера там десь там пишуть пісу Я
кажу що пишуть пісу Я кажу ми що беремо
участь вона Да беремо е ну це великий
респект і насправді і тій команді яка це
зробила в 22-му і тій команді яка
започаткували від Лілії Михайлівни Я
бачу і Вадим Анатолійович тут був і
Валерій Іванович тут був і всім командам
регіональних центрів ну це максимально
важливо бо ну ті дані - це аргумент
аргумент спілкування ну зокрема
наприклад для мене як для депутата
Верховної Ради аргумент спілкуванні з
колегами в залі які кажуть навіщо щось
змінювати в нас така класна система
освіти попри все цей аргумент досі лунає
цей ну певною мірою міф досі є в нас так
все супер класно В нас так багато
переможців міжнародних олімпіад
подивіться і так далі І так далі це
супер сильний аргумент це Точка входу в
дискусію бо Максимум що в нас було До
того як була піса - це нерелевантне
порівняння шкіл за рейтингами ЗНО все
більше в нас нічого не було як
порівнювати різні там ну якісь там
системи освіти Тим більше що зараз в нас
драматично збільшується кількість цих
розривів класичні розриви про які ми
говоримо село місто профтех там сильна
якась там Академічна школа до них
додаються діти ВПО Діти за кордоном діти
з прифронтової території діти де є
онлайн діти де є бнed діти де є офлайн
нормальний діти які бігають до
бомбосховища і так далі І так далі тому
я не впевнений Я впевнений точніше що це
дослідження поки що вці нові розриви
унікальні На жаль унікальні для нашої
системи освіти у порівнянні з іншими
системами освіти вони ще не виміряли це
але основні розриви Вони тільки
збільшились І що от Ну якщо до політик
повертатися ну зрозуміло що це реформа
старшої профільної школи Ну і взагалі
реанімація ну ж я не кажу продовження
реформи я Ну думаю що чесно буде
використовувати тер термін реанімація
нової української школи реформа старшої
профільної школи яка з моєї точки зору
ну скла ну ж є складовою але ну це
найскладніше Якщо говорити про кожну
Ланку освіти в середній школі це саме
старшопрофільну
зробити нарешті звернути увагу на
педагогічну освіту підготовку і
перепідготовку бо ми завжди постійно
говоримо перепідготовка перепідготовка
про підготовку ми говоримо менше ми
вчимо по старих лекалах а потім перепід
п готовка там по нових Яка ще досі не
запрацювала досі немає в нас ринку цієї
перепідготовки в нас досі традиційні
зазвичай траєкторії третя дуже важлива
Політика - це наше спільне завдання Якщо
ми тут подивимось Хто тут сидить то тут
ми сидимо всі в бульбишці нам не треба
нікому от я говорю Всі для всіх речі
абсолютно очевидні Ну ми всі знаємо що
Піза важлива ми знаємо що в нас освітні
втрати ми це знаємо ви вийдіть на вулицю
Я не кажу спитайте що таке піса не кожен
вчитель це відповість але важливість тих
речей важливість з точки зору безпеки і
майбутнього нашої держави і наших дітей
Вона не є усвідомленням в суспільстві
нашому ви підіть до го голів громад
наприклад який є засновниками школ ви
покажіть наприклад підіть на нам всім
треба це робити я слово підіть кажу я не
роздаю завдання Я кажу що це наше
завдання щоб тут була не тільки освітня
бульбашка ця щоб на асоціації міст вони
бачили що відбувається з сільською
освітою щоб це було усвідомленням щоби
нам простіше було переконувати чому в
нас такий викривлений на насправді зараз
закон про ту ж саму старшу профільну
школу він відрізняється від того що ми
приймали спочатку в законі про повну
загальну середню освіту Бо мало
комунікації ми всі один одного розуміємо
ми всі візьмемось за руки і підемо там
далі але ми не всі ми не не все
суспільство і от цього Мені здається не
вистачає і нам цю помилку не треба
повторювати нам треба цю інформацію
максимально спрощено доносити до всіх до
батьків до засновників школ це от одне з
основних завдань наши в тому числі в
Раді нам це кому в першу чергу а кожному
своя історія Ну нам Ну мені в Раді
депутатам доносити там я на окрузі
працюю наприклад з головами громад там з
батьками в нас в кожного є своя супер
велика аудиторія супервелика але
експертно обговорювати в колі освітян ну
це ні про що ну це важливо але це не про
нормальне ну продовження якогось ну
якісь результати подальше та тому що і
заперечення тієї ж реформи старшої
профільної школи в тому числі через
недокомунікацію та того про що це
реформа і навіщо вона потрібна а руслане
державна служба якості освіти Також
займається дослідженнями та і одне з них
ви навесні провели це був перший етап
трирічного загальнодержавного
зовнішнього моніторингового дослідження
якості освіти в умовах саме воєнного
стану і на серпневій конференції ви
презентували результати цього
дослідження Яке багато в чому корелює з
тим що ми сьогодні
отримали з результатів Піза
А як на вашу думку дані дослідження
презентованого вами доповнюють висновки
міжнародного дослідження Піза і чи є
можливо якісь
розбіжності ну які не очевидні та про
які ми зараз Ось так через дві години
після презентації дослідження Пізи не
можемо що говорити А ви уже розумієте що
так вони є вітаю
друзі Ви
знаєте презентація цього дослідження
викликає у мене трішки Такі амбівалентні
емоції я спробую пояснити чому перше що
результати Піза практично підтверджують
всі ті наші Дослідження які ми зробили
протягом 23го року а саме моніторинги
щодо
навчання під час війни і тут саме
головне потрібно сказати що і опитування
вчителів і директорів шкіл і тестування
Які ми провели учнів шостих і восьмих
класів показали абсолютно однакові
тенденції абсолютно оддинакові І власне
Тут у мене є певне занепокоєння тому
що ми повинні інколи кричати про ці
результати Ну насправді кричати
насправді ми повинні не тільки говорити
з вчителями і з директорами шкіл а певно
ця комунікація має бути на всіх рівнях і
якщо ми не усвідомимо що є певна
проблема ми її не зможемо вирішити
більше того якщо можна вести дискусію
щодо інструментарію оцінювання питання
які є в Пізі то ті тести які побудовані
були нами і питання для учнів
шостих-восьмих класів Вони повністю
відповідають програ
рамі навчання дітей в наших нашій
базовій
школі тому тут Я погоджуюся з спікерами
і говорю про те що ми маємо дуже
серйозно поговорити не тільки на цій
платформі але і за межами цих платформ
про виклики які є За наслідками
результатів всіх які ми оприлюднували і
в серпні і зараз це перше але друге У
мене є і може десь і в захист цього
дослідження Я би хотів сказати декілька
слів і я попробую теж пояснити чому
справа в тому що
м коли
ми проводимо це дослідження то
очевидно що питання як які були
поставлені під час дослідження Піза вони
всі побудовані на компетентнісному
підході Якщо так проаналізувати питання
вони більшість їх стосується
застосування знань та міркуван
якщо провести кореляцію з тестами шостих
і восьмих класів яку проводила Дежа які
проводила державна служба якості освіти
то найкращі результати показали діти на
знання правил в шостих і восьмих класах
з математики і української мови а там де
стосувалося питання застосування і
міркування то ця крива різко знижувалася
Тому очевидно що наші діти не працюють з
цим інструментарієм і не знають як його
використовувати на практиці тому
висновок У мене дуже простий в цій
частині або Ми змушені змінити свою
філософію і змінити орієнтири і цілі до
яких ми йдемо в системі освіти і тоді я
більше як переконаний що якщо Ми змінимо
ці цілі то наші діти швидше і краще
будуть показувати результати Я
переконаний що будуть показувати кращі
результати саме в дослідженні Піза Це
перша частинка або друга частинка
у нас в стандарті задекларований
компетентнісний підхід но інколи не
вистачає ні методик ні практик як його
застосувати на практиці під час навчання
дітей і тут ми маємо з вами об'єднати
всіх свої зусилля особливо в частині
інститутів підвищення кваліфікації для
того щоб людською мовою пояснити наш
стандарт наш компетентнісний підхід і
донести його до кожного вчителя до
кожного учня і навіть до їхніх батьків і
тільки коли так ми об'єднаємо зусилля то
наступне дослідження Пізи я більше як
переконаний будуть набагато кращі
результати І набагато позитивніші тому Є
над чим працювати Дякую всім за те що
долучилися до цього дослідження
неймовірна робота змістовна робота Я
думаю ми продовжимо її аналізувати і
більше того гарантую що під час е
рекомендацій щодо внутрішньої системи
забезпечення якості до кожної школи ми
зможемо рекомендувати уже виклики які
прописані тут у
дослідженні даному дослідженні Дякую
Можливо плануєте робити якесь порівняння
результатів ми не планували робити
порівняння результатів тому що вони
підтверджують практично один одного і це
буде зовсім не зовсім коректно робити
такі порівняння але багато речей багато
тенденцій які ми зможемо показати уже
після після
результатів Дякую Аню до тебе поставлю
наступ наступне запитання і зараз буде
трохи дивно почуватись роблячи цю
підводку до запитання Утім благодійний
фонд
севед одним з своїх з ключових векторів
визначив роботу з підлітками тобто
власне з тими хто і писав дослідження
Хто брав участь в дослідженні Піза Ти
багато їздиш регіонами це одна з твоїх
фокусних тем а-а які ти бачиш
потреби які озвучують підлітки або не
озвучують або ти це просто прослідковуєш
і
свідомо діяльність фонду націлена на
маленькі селища і містечка сьогоднішні
результати досліджень довели що це
правильна стратегія але як можна цей
розрив шалений в тому ж читанні який
дорівнює птьом рокам як його можна
мінімізувати цей розрив у між лищами і
містами Дякую Оленко вітання всім і чому
Оленка почуває себе дивно тому що ми це
разом робимо Оленко власне є директоркою
фонду і для тих хто не знає чим Ми
займаємося Ми допомагаємо громадам які
постраждали від війни відновлювати
доступ до освіти як в інфраструктурний
спосіб так і допомагати налагоджувати
відновлювати власне освітній процес у
софтовий спосіб ми працюємо на Київщині
Чернігівщині це те де почали працювати
коли ЗСУ звільнили північ а миколаївщина
харківщина та
Дніпропетровська область і частина з цих
регіонів вони не ввійшли в у вибірку
Пізи і Ну з того що я бачу це якісь
побутові спостереження там ситуація
значно значно гірша Оленко Ти запитала
про підлітків ми дійсно визначили їх для
себе ключовою аудиторію з якою ми
працюємо безпосередньо я поясню трішки
пізніше чому але от я зараз не буду
оперувати якимись національними даними
цифрами я буду говорити про те що я бачу
коли ми їздимо в найменші села які
деокупували в на в розбиті села наві 0%
Але там є діти Є підлітки А коли ми
почали працювати в Чернігові Це був десь
травень 22-го місто лише оговтувалося
після звільнення області і 27 34х шкіл
росіяни прицільно або там знесли взагалі
або ну сильно побили а схоже ситуація
була в області що ви бачили е ну місто
ще таке реально в шоці зрозуміло чому
але діти починають потихеньку сходитися
до шкіл Ну нічого не працює але вони
просто гуртуються навіть біля повністю
розбитих шкіл у нас є серія фото де в
цілі в майданчик баскетбольний Діти
прийшли грають на фоні абсолютно
знесеної бомбами школи грають в
баскетбол і така історія була просто по
кожній школі І знаєте Ми раніше багато
обговорювали Чому діти не хочуть іти в
школу те що ми зараз бачимо від
Чернігова до снігурівки від Апостолова
до червоної долини всі хочуть іти в
школи тому що
їм просто нереально бракує якогось хоча
би спілкування тому як на мене потреба
номер один така ну якби велика це внятна
політика відновлення доступу до освіти в
нас цей діалог Мені здається трошки
монополізований міністерством
відновлення хотілось би краще розуміти а
як ми оцей доступ саме в освіті плануємо
відновлюти та коли це почнеться а друге
що що ми бачимо власне та У фонді
Це бажання хоча би якихось
офлайнактивностей ну мон цього року на
початку вересня видали дані мільйон
онлайн навчається ще мільйон згрубше та
в змішаному форматі переважно теж онлайн
А в нас є програма У фонді називається
ative ми вісім тижнів Працюємо з дітьми
з деокупованих територій Якщо коротко
вчимо їх робити власні проєкти які були
би про відновлення про покращення життя
в їхніх громадах Куди не
приїдемо
Вознесенськ снігорівка Баштанка
березнигувати залізся на Київщині ну
малюсенькі села які були в окупації всі
нам кажуть це перший раз коли ми
зібралися в офлайні навіть ті кому не
можна да бо у них онлайн але вони хоча
би там на годинку в день коли немає
загрози Вони збираються і
ну дуже легко впровадити якісь супер
суворі вимоги всі сидите вдома Та бо в
школі нема укриття але це трошечки
якийсь шлях внікуди тому як на мене
використовувати значно активніше
можливості позашкілля це зараз
просто Маст Ну і третє е з того що ми
бачимо ці підлітки вони дуже Загублені і
їм дуже
бракує власної причетності до Ну до
перемоги назвемо це так до до
відновлення до якоїсь активності яка
була би про повернення е життя а і це
насправді така знаєте критична історія
тому що це саме та вікова категорія Всі
ви знаєте це якась очевидність але вони
зараз роблять вибір і їх чекають скрізь
від Польщі до Чехії до Литви до Латвії а
і їх заберуть залюбки і якщо ми не дамо
їм якийсь інструмент А чому вони тут
потрібні от прям тут і зараз не через
5ть років коли в нас буде політика якась
та а прямо зараз через якісь швидкі
програми через мобілізацію всіх
громадських організацій які можуть
працювати з підлітками а вони ну ну
скоріш за все ну або поїдуть або
залишаться в
тому стані та в якому вони є зараз і
останнє Я це забула сказати власне Ми
багато говоримо про
емоційно-психологічну підтримку є
національні програми але щось Ну не
працює от багато шкіл де ми працюємо які
де діти були в окупації я їх всіх
запитую коли вже ну трішечки пройшов час
і так якось їх делікатно питаю розкажіть
про ваш як як це було Та як ви це
пережили окупацію і Чи можете ви
говорити про це зараз вони кажуть Ну
ее зараз вже Можемо і коли їх питаюш що
їм потрібно кажуть Ми хочемо щоб з нами
говорили хтось щоб з нами хтось
професійно вів цю розмову і от до
прикладу є таке село Катюжанка на
Київщині Та вони там був пункт наступу
русні на Київ ця школа пережила жахливі
речі і там мені діти кажуть ну до нас
при жала одна організація один раз з
нами провели один тренінг а потім навіть
на зв'язок з нами не виходили та тому
коли ми кажемо про великі національні
компанії психологічноемоційної підтримки
ну варто думати А як їх зробити так щоб
вони були системними та аби вони
працювали перш за все з тими дітьми і
зокрема підлітками які це все прожили
Дякую
ле Дякую Аню
а пане Сергію служба освітнього
омбутсмена отримує чимало Запитів від
різних категорій від вчителів від
освітніх управлінців
від батьків і знаю навіть що від дітей
також мене це особисто захоплює коли
бачу як 13-14-тирічні діти пишуть а
запити на Міністерство освіти або на
служби освітнього
омбутсмена ви були одним з перших хто
почали працювати
з обговорювати публічно питання освітніх
втрат і працювати власне з цим питанням
Що на вашу думку потрібно в першу чергу
зробити аби забезпечити якісну освіту
яка
гарантується Конституцією України та аби
нею забезпечити
а дітей України і тих які живуть в
містах і особливо тих які не мають
доступу такого до якісної освіти тобто в
селах Дякую е я під хочу підтримати пані
Анну от те що вона говорить можна дуже
коротко сформулювати у зверненні до
дітей до підлітків твоя освіта крок до
перемоги От і оцей месдж ми маємо
транслювати
па думку перед тим як відповідати власне
на запитання хочу нагадати про те що де
наші діти бо дослідження
Піза це дійсно дуже крута штука але ми
маємо розуміти аналізуючи застосовуючи
ці дані що ці дані
є частковими і ми маємо розуміти про що
йдеться отже
давайте подивимося де наші діти діти які
постійно проживають на тих територіях де
вони раніше були і там вже і навчаються
ну це здебільшого це західні центральні
області України діти які знайшли
прихисток в Україні тобто які в Україні
залишаються але перемістилися і для цих
дітей окрім проблем які пов'язані з з
усіма дітьми це відключення І
відсутність доступу до а-а гаджетів і
інші проблеми додається ще проблема
психологічної адаптації проблеми булінгу
до при до приїжжих і або навпаки таке
також трапляється на превеликий жаль і
це все треба враховувати коли ми
говоримо про компенсацію відновлення
освітніх втрат
далі діти які знайшли прихисток за
кордоном на жаль Ці діти через очевидні
умови проведення
дослідження Піза не Потрапили у вибірку
бо мали я от спеціально уточнив
увакуленко що мали прийти діти фізично
до центрів опитування і пройти
опитування тест от А це величезна
кількість наших дітей і з ними є окремі
проблеми
я дуже сильно цим переймаюся бо маємо
величезну кількість звернень і дуже
важливо розуміти А що взагалі
відбувається там за кордоном з нашими
дітьми стосовно освітніх
як почувають себе батьки як почувають
діти бо я думаю що дехто читав мій
вчорашній допис який був викликаниї Ну
просто кричущоу інформацію з однієї з
шкіл де дітям на 25 грудня поставили
дітям пятого класу на 25 грудня
поставили іспити 14 іспитів 25 грудня
дітям пятого
класу Ну це треба Треба було
додуматися до такого от це факт Ну є
конкретні прізвище імена я не стану
називати школу щоб там не ганьбити вже
бо Та вони трошки отямилися Бо коли
прочитали мій допис вони трошки
відкотили от але це але Це жахіття От і
це стосується дітей за кордоном які є
окремою групою і дуже важливо мати
дослідження і оприлюднити їх А як
взагалі там почуваються наші діти це
дуже серйозна
проблема далі група дітей які
знаходяться на на деокупованих
територіях ми знаємо пані Анна це от
тільки що дуже яскраво сказала я її
цілком підтримую бо ну це те саме що ми
маємо в зверненнях знищені українські
підручники зруновані школи немає людей у
Харкові рік тому після деокупації була
проблема три місяці не могли виплатити
заробітну плату не тому що грошей не
було а тому що в бухгалтерії не було
людей кому нарахувати і ми величезну
кількість часу і зусиль витратили на те
щоб просто добитися щоб людям виплатили
заробі гроші які вони мали отримати і це
є проблемою але оце категорії дітей на
яких ми маємо вплив ми маємо туди доступ
А є категорії дітей які перебувають на
тимчасово окупованих територіях які
очевидно не потрапили до цього
Дослідження які знаходяться поблизу чи в
зоні бойових дій або діти які вкрадені
Росією і вивезені з території України Це
дуже серйозні теми на які треба дуже
багато говорити я нагадав це тому що ми
маємо розуміти дослідження Піза показує
Скажімо так середню температуру А ми
маємо розуміти що кожна палата Вибачте
має свої особливості
бо якість освіти наших дітей
хворіє дуже сильно хворіє і через ковід
і через
е незгод негоди війни і будемо казати
про інші речі Отже що треба робити
АА треба діяти на всіх рівнях Отже
дивіться має діяти вчитель я не буду тут
розписувати що може зробити вчитель може
багато що може зробити вчитель просто
працюючи з дітьми має діяти школа на
рівні логістики на рівні навчання
вчителів підтримки вчителів має діяти
громада підтримуючи школи забезпечуючи
їх створюючи умови не навантажуючи школи
дурнуватою звітністю абсолютно зайвою і
дуже важливо щоб громади розуміли
проблеми шкіл бо ми маємо дуже багато
неприємних випадків коли ну говорять
деякі А Та нам що нам та освіта Ну то
таке От і нарешті на рівні держави треба
при ухвалювати певні зміни треба
обов'язково комунікувати треба вносити
зміни до Я маю на увазі і Міністерство і
кабінет міністрів і Верховну Раду нам є
що змінювати і ми постійно в комунікації
ми знаємо що там треба дуже багато чого
зробити і все це має бути у постійній
взаємній комунікації
рівнів це все має бути в постійній
комунікації з родиною яка має і впливати
на систему освіти і отримувати зворотній
зв'язок від системи освіти це має бути в
постійній комунікації з суспільством і
медіа Оце так би могла виглядати Ну не
ідеальнона Но але на мій погляд працююча
схема як треба відновлювати освітні
втрати Але що ми маємо наразі От
дивіться давайте подимо зараз я вас
трошки засмучу але це треба Ось що ми
маємо
ми маємо бар'єри між рівнями освіти
вчитель не може достукатися до директора
директор не може достукатися до голови
громади громада не може достукатися
до до рівнів законодавчої виконавчої
вищої влади ми маємо такі приклади і ви
їх чудово знаєте з іншого боку родина
агресивно висловлюється до школи школа
навпаки оця вічна тема да школа каже що
батьки винні що діти не навчаються
батьки кажуть що школа не те робить з
іншого боку
суспільство Ну будемо відверто казати
доволі часто хейтить освіту освіта також
В боргу не залишається медіа так само
Короче кажучи маємо отаку ну доволі
неприємну картину От дивіться як Воно б
мало бути як тут на а отак пове
отак мало би бути а воно у нас отак поки
що дуже багато де На жаль і завершуючи
свій виступ Тут є що робити Я хочу
підтримати Артура який говорив про
освіту як професійний філолог я хочу
сказати одну дуже просту річ яка яка
будучи впровадженою дозволить нам
підвищити рівень читацької
компетентності от що
власне Що роби робити з читанням Вибачте
я розумію що я не прихильник простих
рішень але тут рішення настільки
очевидне що просто треба його впровадити
хоча це викличе величезний спротив і
звинувачення в тому що ми хочемо знищити
українську літературу а вихід насправді
дуже
простий треба вивчати літературу а не
історію літератури бо те що зараз
вивчається в школі не є літературою це
Історія і теорія літератури на рівні
другого курсу філологічного факультету
навіщо а діти наші не можуть нормально
сприйняти текст інтерпретувати Зробити
висновки тому Тут треба дуже сильно
діяти дуже рішуче і дуже активно хоча Я
чудово розумію реакцію і на мій виступ І
на те що доведеться робити але іншого
виходу немає Якщо ми хочемо щоб наші
діти читали розуміли прочитане і робили
висновки з прочитаного
дякую дякую Сергія А я користуючись
нагодою що тут зібралася
а така в хорошому сенсі освітянська
бульбашка запрошую всіх завтра
долучитися онлайн або ж підійти до нас
занною після
презентації дослідження
і долучитися до презентації програм для
старшої профільної школи які ми У фонді
на напрацьовували на прикладі
Житомирського ліцею де є нові підходи
абсолютно до вивчення і мови і
літератур Ми теж очікуємо що буде багато
дискусій з цього приводу
Утім впевнені в тому що потрібно з цим
експериментувати і потрібно показувати
нашим дітям нові можливості які би
відповідали їх реальним потребам а Ольо
Я іду до
тебе фонд президента з це підтримка
освіти науки
а чи має якісь плани В розрязі того
дослідження яке сьогодні
презентувалося можливо якось діяльність
фонду там ви ви плануєте підкоригувати
на цей рік з огляду на ті результати які
ми сьогодні отримали і загалом розкаж
кілька слів про ключові вектори
діяльності фонду тому що думаю що людям
це так також цікаво Дякую Олено і дякую
пані Тетяні за можливість долучитися до
цієї дискусії я би напевно хотіла її
трошечки повернути частково в інше русло
перед тим як перейти безпосередньо до
фонду і в тому числі про його діяльність
насправді коли ми говоримо про
результати ми їх бачимо Ну от зараз ми
так з вами обговорюємо в достатньо
негативному ключі в тому плані що нас
справді є виклики є певні питання в
системі освіти в контексті якості освіти
над якими нам треба сукупно попрацювати
Але в той же час якщо подивитись на
рейтинг України якщо подивитись на дані
в порівнянні з попереднім оцінюванням ми
маємо так само незнецінювати роботу тих
вчителів які в супер складних умовах
не Ну скажімо так не здали позиції
Принаймні з тим щоби забезпечити
навчальний процес як такий це раз
по-друге ми
насправді пан Сергій згадував тут про
переможців міжнародних олімпіад Я щойно
спеціально перевірила звідки ці діти які
отримали цього року відповідно нагороду
і це якраз те що робить фонд то там є
багато учнів які проходили навчання не
тільки на території умовно безпечній
України а в тому числі достатньо багато
дітей з Харкова або Харківської області
з Одеської області що говорить нам
насправді про те що навіть в умовах
війни навіть в умовах ковіду під
ракетними обстрілами і так так далі ми
не знизили принаймні тих показників які
дозволили представити Україну на
міжнародній арені і якщо ми говоримо про
діяльність фонду то Ми якраз про те щоби
продовжувати підтримувати сильних і
заохочувати до того щоби вчителі мали
можливість отримати відповідну
відповідне визнання тому що в нашому
розумінні одна із
проблем якщо ми говоримо сукупно про
результати Пізи Це в тому числі
престижність професії Лілія Михайлівна
говорила про те що по-хорошому політики
ма мали би формуватись на тих даних які
ми отримуємо якщо ми Заходимо в формат
політик і визначення того що би мала
зробити держава ну на вскидку якщо ми
говоримо про швидку реакцію на
результати Пізи то ми тут бачимо
декілька питань питання децентралізації
і продовження цієї реформи з точки зору
того щоб оцінити чи проблема в тому що
ми її не дозавершили і і ще не до кінця
сформовані опорні школи і можливість там
підкоригувати якість освіти Чи Питання в
тому
що можливо сукупно треба переглянути
формат децентралізації в освітній
реформі і дати відповідь на питання чи
справді голови громад готові відповідати
за якість освіти Чи вони в цьому
зацікавлені і чи вони розуміють рівень
своєї відповідальності в цьому і чи
треба тут вносити якісь зміни окреме
питання - це власне підготовка самих
вчителів які викладають та якби і в
цьому
ж в результатах оцінювання там є дані
про те що насправді зараз дуже багато
вчителів проходять перепідготовку тобто
так чи інакше вони достатньо активну
участь беруть в підвищенні кваліфікації
і тут можна поставити питання А чому їх
навчають да тобто чи достатньо цих знань
Які вони отримують в режимі аслин та
якби того щоби вони могли покращити
якість
освіти окремо ми говоримо про формат
залучення до професії та вчительства як
такого і повертаючись до ну ці питання
скоріше належать до Міністерства освіти
і науки з тим щоби визначати на базі цих
даних вже свою політику і розуміння того
що треба робити повертаючись до того що
робить фонд президента з підтримки
освіти науки та спорту ми займаємось
переважно
питаннями інтернаціоналізації освіти і
можу відповісти чому Да бо дуже багато
завжди є закидів до нас чому ми не
займаємось там внутрішніми питаннями
тому що в принципі президент відповідає
за міжнародну політику і за сферу
національної безпеки і оборони і
відповідно це імплементовано в
діяльність фонду І з точки зору тих
проектів які є на сьогодні
Ми свідомі того щоб Скажімо так у нас
могли випускатись в тому числі вчителі
нової формації нової якості для цього
треба піднятися на рівень вище і
зрозуміти а хто власне і в який спосіб
управляє тими закладами освіти які які
готують педагогічних
працівників саме з цією метою ми
запустили окрему програму розвитку
лідерського потенціалу саме керівників
закладів вищої освіти з тим щоби вони
для себе змогли переглянути і вибудувати
ту стратегію яка дозволить на себе
подивитись зі сторони і зрозуміти що
саме варто змінити в контексті
підготовки в тому числі педагогічних
працівників повертаючись до теми
заохочень і
визнання крім того що є окремі програми
які сприяють власне визнанню тих
вчителів які підготували переможців
міжнародних олімпіад незважаючи на те що
їх можливо не настільки багато як би нам
хотілось але вони є і вони сукупно не
зменшились в своїй кількості якщо ми
знову ж таки будемо порівнювати навіть з
роками до війни вони не зменшились
сьогодні також в своїй
кількості якщо ми говоримо про теж що є
країни в яких ситуація набагато краще то
фонд Президента про те щоби залучати цей
досвід і мати можливість сюди в тому
числі запрошувати якщо потрібно
іноземних викладачів до викладання з тим
щоби розширювати взагалі можливість тут
в Україні отримувати знання навички
зовсім іншого формату і з тим щоби
ставати трошечки ближче до тих країн які
показують кращі результати тому
сукупно якщо говорити більш глобально да
якби
ми
максимально готові сприяти тому щоби і
розвивати дослідження в сфері тієї ж
педагогіки інноваційної педагогіки в
який спосіб вона може і має бути
впроваджена в тому плані щоби сам формат
подання інформації змінювався змістовне
наповнювання наповнення адаптувалось до
потреб часу і що робити з тим щоби діти
себе почували достатньо безпечно тому що
що сьогодні ми точно маємо говорити про
те що безумовно знання важливі але те в
якому стані знаходяться і вчителі які
навчають і діти які навчаються це теж
окрема історія і окрема робота для
Міністерства з тим щоби забезпечити
власне цю безпеку і ментальну і фізичну
в кожному закладі освіти тому що коли ми
бачимо цей великий розрив в тому числі
між сільською і міською місцевістю це
означає що з великою іймовірністю та там
діти не виходять на в офлайн навчання і
це дуже часто пов'язано з різними
факторами в тому числі з наявністю
відповідних укриттів але навіть якщо
вони там наявні Питання в тому чи
вчителі знають і розуміють як реагувати
і вивести дітей на той рівень спокою
який їм дозволить продовжити навчання
наприклад після ракетних обстрілів які
так чи інакше відбуваються щодня І тут
ми повинні розуміти що коли ми говоримо
про вчителя про школу про директора то
рівень того що вони повинні у нас
зростає кожного дня та якби і от кожного
разу коли ми донавантажуємо повинні
повинні повинні ми маємо розуміти які
заохочення Ми даємо у відповідь і яку
підтримку Ми даємо у відповідь для того
щоб вони могли виконати всі ті пункти
повинні Тому все що стосується супроводу
діяльності в тому числі вчителів і тих
хто їх готує це якраз
ті програми які фонд президента
підтримуєякую пані ля Можна я вас також
запитаю оскільки Оля підняла питання
підготовки педагогічних кадрів ви як
перша проректорка університету одного з
провідних педагогічних університетів
країни вочевидь вже зі своєю командою
обговорювали якісь стратегії того як має
змінитися підхід до навчання майбутніх
вчителів поділитися якимись своїми
думками з цього приводу
Так у нас завжди була проблема що
реформа нова українська школа І взагалі
зміни в
освіті вони на жаль не були
натхненними середовищем академічним і
університетським і виходить так що в
реальному житті змінюється школи а до
університетів дуже часто ці зміни вони
прохо вже якусь
трансформацію І лише тоді коли вже
починають писати статті на базі
даних змін які відбулись в навчальних
закладах починається усвідомлення цих
змін тому на привеликий жаль я згодна що
в університетському
середовищі
інколи Я б сказала часто На жаль поки що
ча сно так
по-перше велике значення надається
теорії А я б сказала історії теорії тому
що наприклад наша реформа яка базується
на засадах конструктивізму
який працює всюди у світі і ми
намагаємося сконструювати з найкращих
методик педагогічних технологій підходів
на основі принципу
детиноцентризму який дуже притаманний
саме для української
освіти тобто тут дуже дуже багато
конструктів цієї
реформи що що робити Я вважаю що
підвищення кваліфікації
викладачів які готують майбутніх
учителів має також величезне значення
і ось тут дати адекватну пропозицію для
них це досить вимогливо окрім того
хотілося б щоб Дослідження які
відбувається в наших університетах також
були спрямовані на потреби реформи і на
виріст До речі при нагоді хотіла б усіх
присутніх запросити долучитися скоріше
всього в дистанційний спосіб Бо це буде
такий захід в очному режимі маленький
але дуже важливий для нас у
понеділоквіівторок а саме в понеділок
буде основна
сесія андрас шляйхер і багато колег з
п'яти провідних освітніх систем
будуть ділитися своїм досвідом
моделювання старшої профільної школи і
на основі цього досвіду ми маємо
створити власну старшу профільну школу і
сьогодні Піза нам дає також
дані над якими варто замислитися при
формуванні цієї моделі Я думаю що є дві
Вибачте бо це вже не тільки про
викладачів Але я розумію що час Аня нам
дозволила до четвертої тому я так Ага
дозволила собі ще кілька питань я тоді
хочу сказати дві важливі речі щоб
донести саме про пізу як джерело для нас
для джерело даних
Піза відображає наше
суспільство оці всі
нерівності оці всі
е-е
блискучі результати і
найгірші величезні
розриви і ми повинні зрозуміти що наше
завдання Звісно добре якщо ми
підготували переможців міжнародних
олімпіад і приємно якщо там є українські
діти і потім їх нагороджують Але
будувати це суспільство будуть всі і
якість життя у ньому буде залежати від
усіх
і успішні країни характеризуються тим що
там оці розриви між найкращими і тими
найслабшими не є такими драматичними і
вели як як як як зокрема у
нас тому я вважаю що треба дуже серйозно
поставитись до цього
питання і в Пізі в питальниках є багато
індикаторів які зараз от от академічне
середовище університет середовище
повинно серйозно вивчити і ми маємо
чітко запропонувати шляхи як ми будемо
змінювати ці диспропорції і наші різниці
у порівнянні з провідними освітніми
системами починаючи від становища
вчителя починаючи від нашої зацикленості
з одного боку на кількості годин на
кожен предмет ви бачите що це не так вже
й залежить і на кількості того скільки
дітей повинно бути у
класі коли ми сперечаємося п'ять чи
10 Але разом з тим ми маємо зрозуміти
інші речі які пов'язані з самими
методиками
викладання і прийти до усвідомленого
політичного рішення про ядро
знань ядро знань які в цьому світі де
знання дуже примножуються ми маємо дати
дітям у нас є великий шанс бо в нас
тривалість навчання збільшиться на один
рік давайте цей шанс правильно
використаємо
е тобто величезна кількість показників
системи освіти які виписані блискуче Я б
сказала в цьому звіті нам дає
можливість Я б сказала навіть змінити
архітектуру системи української освіти і
в цьому сила даних і останнє
компетентнісний підхід Я дуже багато бо
в мене зараз багато часу
ее порівняно з часом Коли ви були
міністром маєте на увазі Я дуже багато
спілкуюся з вчителями і з директорами
шкіл по роду
діяльності Повірте я ставлю в цих
аудиторіях одне питання скажіть мені
будь ласка що таке компетентності От
недавно в нас була велика аудиторія Ми
поставили таке питання одиниці мають
розуміння що таке
компетентності Ми сьогодні відкриваємо
наші підручники нової української школи
для п'ятого-шостого класу і ми не бачимо
практикоорієнтованих
завдань які необхідні для формування
компетентностей Піза заставляє нам
подивитись от в це дзеркало Пізи і
зрозуміти багато речей над якими ще
потрібно працювати дидактичним
забезпеченням освіти реальним змістом
навчанням
учителів
І ще що дуже є
важливим ця Піза показала що ми
переможний народ який перемагає і
українська система освіти незважаючи на
те що її треба удосконалювати заради
наших дітей які є іншими
інакшими дуже стійка тому От ця
стійкість мабуть є основним таким такою
домінантною ознакою Пізи для
України тільки швиденько я відповім на
також на ваше запитання Дякую Лілі
Михайлівна яка мені яка рік тому
запросила мене провести курс для
магістратури Грінченка який називається
управлінські аспекти дотримання прав в
освіті От я якраз зараз закінчив цей
курс От і Спілкуючись з директорами з
вчителями ну цікаві речі я бачу що люди
не дуже розуміють що таке права їм треба
це розповідати але я взяв слово Для того
щоб вас закликати колеги Хто з вас має
можливість має досвід Ідіть до
педагогічних університетів пропонуйте
свої курси бо дуже не вистачає
практичних знань тим хто навчається в
цих особливо Ну директори і досвідчені
вчителі які в магістратурі там більш Ну
там вже трошки простіше бо вони вже
мають досвід а от студенти які просто
приходять їм на голову така хоп
заповнення класного журналу або х щось
ін конкретні речі ідіть допомагайте
навчатися майбутнім вчителям дякую
Дякую Сергію у мене питання останнє і
воно таке На Десерт і досить
суперечливе ми говорили сьогодні про
здебільшого академічні розриви та про те
на скільки балів ми відстаємо від країн
ecd в природничих дисциплінах До речі
Сергію це теж цікаво та що природничі
дисципліни мають найменший розрив це я
да вас до вас як вчителя фізики там це
теж цікавий феномен можемо пізніше
трішечки обговорити а щорік відставання
в математиці там два роки в читанні Ми
сьогодні більше говорили про це Але є
одна
м сфера яку ми не зачепили це власне
добробут дітей добробут не дітей а
15-тирічних підлітків це вже не зовсім і
діти і результати Піза показали що діти
з нижчими академічними результатами є
щасливішими і задоволенішими ми життям і
це Ну така
цікава цікавий результат та я не знаю як
його правильно трактувати які колеги У
вас є думки з цього з цього
приводу Аню Ти ти хочеш
почати які в мене є з цього приводу
думки Піза дуже чітко говорить що все
Потрібно ділити чи враховувати
культурний контекст та національні
особливості і тому коли наші діти
говорять чи якісь інші діти говорять що
вони найщасливіші то треба питати Та що
таке щастя що таке добробут знову ж таки
з нашого з тобою Оленко досвіду ми
їздимо безкінечно по цим крихітним
малесеньким селам діти були там девть
місяців окупації на миколаївщині Руслан
Васильович це ви говорите Вибачте пані
Анна просить вас не говорити одночасно з
нею я
перекладаю
[музика]
і діти пережили окупацію діти бачили
багато чого і коли ти їх спитаєш як вони
вони кажутьце все добре коли ти їх
питаєш як вам Ну як життя чого б ви
хотіли вони не знають це діти от Ми
нещодавно були в селі центральне на
миколаївщині воно тільки за назвою таке
це 3 години від Миколаєва по абсолютно
розбитій дорозі і ти такий їдеш 20 киме
ямища а по бокам Мінні поля ти доїжджаєш
до центрального Це неймовірно світлі
діти але коли я запитала директорки діти
коли-небудь до війни де вони як як було
їхнє життя кудись виїжджали кажуть якщо
в батьків була можливість їздили на два
дні в Залізний Порт Ці діти мало чого
бачили Та оці діти про яких ми говоримо
про ці розриви між селом і містом коли
ти не знаєш як може бути тобі твоє життя
здається нормальним тобі здається
нормальним твоє вбиральня на вулиці тому
е повертаючись до попереднього питання
Ось ось цей е розрив Село і місто він
зараз для нас стає супер критичним і
скажу чому якщо ви подивитесь на дані
мон а більшість дітей які виїхали це
діти з великих міст і вони ну ймовірно
якщо нічого кращого не стане продовжить
виїжджати діти в селах зазушаються і це
для нас ну і проблема і можливість
це це питання до тих хто хоче на нього
дати відповідь Та це не обов'язково
кожен мене репліка не про питання коли
кажуть що панельні дискусії некорисні я
ніколи не бачив такої кількості людей
які одночасно гуглять слово
компетентність це дуже круто
А ну це можна що до питання ну це можна
такий трохи викривлений ефект данінга
Крюгера ну говорити насправді і мені
здається що тут щось є
ее ну для мене це не дивна інформація
насправді ну це типова інформація ми як
дорослі люди теж знаємо ну подіб подібні
речі Да коли ти щось від себе відганяєш
або про щось не знаєш навіть то Ну
навіщо про це це бути unхпі Тому це теж
Ну якась така штука я ж думаю що це не
тільки не думаю а по даних це ж не
тільки притамана Україні ситуація це
притамана будь-якій країні де діти які
менш результати демонструють більше ее
рівень щастя Чи задоволеності від життя
ну це теж індикатори параметри з яким
треба працювати І ще одна штука яку
треба усвідомлювати Навіть якщо ми всі
разом будемо зараз суперсильно працювати
е а я сподіваюсь що так і буде
не треба очікувати що наступна піса нам
дасть якісь там супервеликі результати
Бо насправді
шлеф проблем який несе війна і ковід
будуть нас наздогоняти ще дуже і дуже
довго і сподіватись що от жовтень
Минулого року продемонстрував нам все що
нам забрала в нас війна ну це точно ні і
давайте будемо свідомі цього і не будемо
ідеалізувати що в 25-му чи шостому році
коли ми будемо будемо Наступного разу
брати навіть якщо все буде ідеально від
від сьогодні все стане дуже добре це ну
дуже довгий шлях безумовно руслане ви
теж хотіли
Оля добре Я з вашого дозволу маленьку
провокацію внесу е тому що насправді е
візьми трошки ближче мікрофон Мені
здається що це не не добре Е та я внесу
маленьку
провокацію ми насправді в цій залі
зустрічаємось не вперше плюс-мінус в
подібні компанії але теми обговорень у
нас не завжди співпадають Сьогодні ми
обговорюємо результати Піза І кажемо про
те що як важливо нам підняти як якість
освіти і зовсім ще недавно ми сиділи тут
і обговорювали в тому числі
необхідність впровадження
соціально-емоційних навичок в навчання і
говорили про те що в принципі та не такж
то вже й важливо які там результати з
математики там умовно чи там з інших
предметів мають наші діти Головне щоб
вони себе почу вали там більш захищеними
більш емоційно розвинутими могли мали
більші навички адаптивності в світі і
так далі сукупно Насправді я не хочу
сказати що щось одне важливіше ніж інше
Це про те що викликів і того що би могла
дати система освіти кожній окремій
дитині насправді дуже великий спектр і
те що вона дає І на що власне ми робимо
акцент залежить від того що диктує нам
наша загальна політика і наше бачення
якою ми хочемо бачити цю дитину яку
формує система освіти та якби і в який
спосіб вона допомагає їй в майбутньому
реалізувати себе і в тому
числі безумовно ми в цьому зацікавлені
продовжила своє життя в Україні
тому про те чи діти щасливі коли вони
менше витрачають часу на навчання І
менше зусиль Ну напевно щасливіші бо у
них є більше часу в принципі там десь
займатись іншими речами е наскільки вони
щасливі в житті після того да тут же ж
якби немає градації порівняння наприклад
їх уже більш дорослому зрілому віці коли
вони вже чогось досягли або не досягли Я
думаю що ключове питання і справді
найбільша напевно проблема в цій історії
це з тим щоби дати можливість Рівного
доступу до цієї освіти абсолютно всім
дітям і в цьому контексті ми справді
мали би абсолютно щиро і відверто
проговорити про те
чи доцільно і в який спосіб нам все-таки
формувати мережу закладів освіти і як
вона має
виглядати дати чесну відповідь про те чи
в кожному селі має бути школа чи
все-таки не в кожному Чи це впливає
сукупно
на те як ми забезпечуємо Власне цей
доступ І що важливіше чи чи логістичні
питання чи все-таки якість освіти і
після того коли ми дійдемо згоди Я думаю
що нам стане зрозуміло яким шляхом ми
йдемо і чого ми досягаємо бо одночасно
всіх показників по всіх рейтингах Ну я
не знаю чи можливо досягти тому тут
питання кого Ми формуємо Дякую Руслан
дуже хоче доповнити Я коротко я доповнюю
відразу друзі це дуже слушне запитання І
в мене тут є дві те якщо ви дозволите
перше ми ж провели дослідження
соціально-емоційних навичок тобто м'яких
навичок разом з організацією
економічного співробітництва і розвитку
і ми на початку року будемо мати
висновки де ми можемо побачити А де
навички Краще ці формуються в місті чи в
селі і тут теж можна продовжити в цій
частині дискусію але я би хотів
повернутися до теми може теж Вона дуже
дискусійна Ми завжди намагаємося рівними
підхо дами іти і в місто і в село а воно
не працює Тому у нас є унікальні
можливості створення окремих
індивідуальних освітніх програм для
сільської школи може варто їх
використовувати може таку програму
потрібно робити типовою Може потрібно
враховувати контекст хто є в цьому селі
Який вчитель є в цьому селі бо як би ми
скільки не говорили але вчителя якщо
немає і немає середовища освітнього про
яки Ганна згадувала то ми не будемо мати
того результату який хочемо і третє що я
би хотів сказати
друзі Ми зараз намагаємося вгадати що
буде в майбутньому ми бачимо що війна і
ковід найбільше впливає на дітей
молодшої школи Тобто діти шостого класу
показують гірші результати чим діти у
восьмому класі тобто очевидно що
ситуація буде ще
погіршуватися ми маємо це зрозуміти і
дати собі завдання як ми можемо
адаптувати нашу систему освіти в умовах
війни бо ми таке враження що увійшли у
війну і продовжуємо бути так ніби нічого
не трапилося а насправді дуже серйозний
вплив має війна на систему освіти і
друге що маємо дочекатися нуми мусимо
перемогти інакшого виходу у нас немає
тільки ми переможемо тоді можемо ще
більш активно братися за систему освіти
тому всім Перемоги нам дякую дякую
Таню нам треба Наступного разу ще більше
часу тому що не багато цікавих тем для
обговорення Я дуже добре пригадую
презентацію результатів Піза в 2019 році
це було 3 грудня і тоді всі говорили про
те що результати Піза 2018 а розбили той
міф про дуже якісну і потужну радянську
освіту Да і всі всі тоді це давали таким
летмотивом Пізи а 2018 а Піза 2022 для
мене особисто я думаю для всіх учасників
дискусії теж це без жодного пафосу
е про героїзм українських підлітків які
10 жовтня після обстрілу Пішли писати
тест про героїзм українських вчителів
які уже два роки більше насправді тому
що почалося це ще під час ковіду
працюють а на дві а той Три ставки і
очно і в офлайні про героїзм
українського центру оцінювання якості
освіти і вашої команди Таню якій вдалося
це зробити
і
а і безумовно Це дороговказ для всіх нас
для державотворців які працюють над
освітніми політиками і для насправді
кожного і кожної із нас ми можемо
говорити що ми можемо ми маленькі люди
та але наприклад в розрізі результатів з
читання що ми можемо зробити прямо
сьогодні це купити книгу показати дітям
приклад
того як розвивати як розвивати навички
читання і завтра до миколайчика який за
новим календарем саме завтра не 19-го
покласти своїм дітям книгу або
задонатити і підтримати книгарні які
збирають книги для сільських бібліотек
які в абсолютно жахли стані Тому все
залежить від нас Дякую вам всім за цю
чудову
дискусію
і до скорих
[оплески]
зустрічей
якую я щиро дякую
колегам які поділилися своїми думками
чергово переконуюся що в нас є надія
Тому що кожний і кожна Хто тут сидів
правда сподіваються і правда готові
працювати для того щоби в Україні все
було значно краще з математичною
читацькою природнич науковою грамотністю
аніж це було мені зараз така зачіпка яку
дала Лілія Михайлівна про компетентності
і про те що вже все прогуглили що всі
прогуглили що таке компетентності а а
власне є в нас наступна панель для того
щоби
поговорити про те які саме і на якому
рівні ці компетентності сформовані в
українських підлітків над чим варто
працювати предметникам як саме це робити
А також про те А як взагалі проводилося
це дослідження від організаторів від
людей які мали змогу на це все дивитися
прямо в жовтні 22го року і власне Я
запрошую черго наступних спікерів до
цієї панелі першим модератором цієї
панелі буде Василь Терещенко це
заступник директора українського центру
оцінювання якості
освіти мій заступник продовжуємо далі
пані Алла корнейко це регіона
регіональна координаторка Піза в Україні
представляє вона Волинський інститут
післядипломної педагогічної освіти в
Україні пані Алла досвідчений
регіональний координатор адже з першого
циклопіза в Україні пані Алла наша
координаторка
Андрій миляник це заступник директора
Львівського регіонального центру
оцінювання якості
освіти математик за фахом тому чекаємо
від вас всього цікавого про математику
пані Поліна Ткач професорка Національної
академії Національної гвардії України
пані поліна з першого циклу дослідження
працює
екзаменаторкою нашою старшою
екзаменаторкою вже впродовж років тобто
пані Поліна точно знає як відповідали
українські учні на завдання Піза і вона
екзаменаторка з читання А ще з
креативного мислення сьогодні пані
Поліна Не відчинять нам двері до
креативного мислення але до читання
сподіваємося і Пан Руслан Шаламов це
заслужений учитель України представляє
Харківський науковий ліцей обдарованість
е Пан Руслан працює з нами вже після
пілоту вже фактично в другий рік та і
Пан Руслан старший екзаменатор з
природнич наукових дисциплін Я вже
бачила щойно заголовки деяких публікацій
про те що природа в нас на високому
рівні пане руслане чекаю від вас
інсайтів Дякую е Тетяна за представлення
е насправді зараз зібралося товариство
яке знає про Піза набагато раніше ніж
Вся Україна і коли сьогодні ми отримали
звіти доступ до повного до короткого
звіту то насправді колеги е робили це
своїми руками і багато про що
здогадуватися могли ще на етапі
перевірки відкритих тестових завдань
яких дуже багато у
тестах пізівських але почнемо перед тим
як перейдемо спілкуватися з колегами які
займалися перевіркою тестових завдань
спочатку пропоную поговорити з пані алою
яка фактично одна з тих одна з тих людей
хто змогли в тих скла обставинах які
склалися восени 22-го року провести
дослідження на місцях і ми тут говоримо
про волинщину про Перепрошую про
Волинь Де були свої регіональні
особливості пов'язані з проведенням
Звісно що в цьому випадку не йдеться про
регіони херсонщину дніпропетровщину дуже
близькі до зони бойових дій але на
Волині була своя специфіка от пані Алло
Що було найскладніше для вас як для
організатора на регіональ рівні у межах
забезпечення якісної процедури збирання
даних в школах безпосередньо
чи чути Мене чути чути Ну Шановні колеги
наш досвід напевно має стати або такою
маленькою ілюстрацією або великою
квінтесенцією досвіду всіх регіональних
координаторів тих що безпосередньо
організовували дослідження на місцях
скажу вам чесно я от згадувала про те як
все було так І сьогодні мейнстрім трішки
ми в ретроспекції було таке Що вдарялися
так от ми під почали підготовку до Піза
ми ж пам'ятаємо ще до повномасштабного
вторгнення Ми отримали вибірку Я
пам'ятаю на середину лютого в нас уже
навіть комунікування було із закладами
освіти е часом я з такою навіть злістю
думаю якби ми легко і добре провели те
дослідження Якби не якби не ворог тому
що ми були вже ми були дуже грамотні і
інформаційно технічно технологічно ми
проводили другий цикл пі в масштабах
України от особливо Особисто я це вже
була мала мала бути мало бути моє
четверте дослідження бо ж два пілота і
два основних етапи але я прекрасно
розумію історія не любить умовного часу
і тому говоримо про те що реально було
було важко було важко проблеми
посипалися Ну напевно що відразу навіть
трішки не так коли почалось
попевномасштабне втурнення спочатку був
вакуум спочатку було ціла купа емоцій
спектр емоцій
від небажання вірити в те що це Може
реально відбуватися до лютої ненависті
до ворога потім певний вакуум потім
нерозуміння того що відбувається і от
липень вже сьогодні згаданий лист від
реіна від українського центру і фраза
український центр розглядає можливості
провести дослідження і зразу вам скажу
що відбувалось на місцях а на місцях
зразу два табори один табір - це такі
обережні реалісти які кажуть яка Піза
воююча країна неможливо А другі такі
зухвалі Напевно що оптимісти які кажуть
не просто можливо а треба просто життєво
потрібно бо ми ж працюємо на перспективу
ми ж працюємо все-таки на майбутнє Ну а
проблеми почалися після того як другий
табір дякуючи сяючий посмішці і завжди
отим сяючим очам Тетяни Сергіївни яка
провела онлайн Зустріч Я дуже добре
пам'ятаю ту онлайн Зустріч вона звичайно
дала переконання і перемога перемогу
отримав табір оптимістів саме тих що
кажуть що обов'язково проведемо і
проведемо добре І потім на нас
посипилися проблеми перша проблема
проблема кадрова ми вже спілкувалися з
закладами освіти в нас уже були свої
люди на кого ми хотіли орієнтуватися
це і керівники закладів і координатори в
закладах власне з проведення дослідження
адміністратори комп'ютерні вчителі
інформатики з'ясувалося коли ми провели
звірку стану речей Ми зрозуміли що певна
кількість цих людей відсутня на робочому
місці відсутня з поважних причин вони
воювали ее ми провели кадрові заміни
потім з'явилася Друга проблема проблема
вибірки Ми отримали вибірку дуже добре
Була вибірка основних закладів дві
вибірки запасні
ну організатори на місцях знають була
вибірка першого порядку запасні першого
порядку запасні другого порядку разом ми
в області мали майже 40 закладів і коли
ми почали аналізувати з'ясувала що ми
можемо провести дослідження лише в семи
з цих закладів Ну перше алгоритми заміни
використовувалися а потім у нас нібито
Лова область але це умовний тил тому що
ми маємо д більш як 200восоткілометровий
кордон із васалом російським з
білорусами і те що було за кордоном те
що було на території Білорусі 22-й рік
це орди десятки тисяч
озброєних ворогів які звичайно е-е ну
Були таким страшенним подразнюючим
фактором Ми боялися другого відкриття
північного фронту і наша військова
адміністрація в березні місяці приймає
рішення про заборону е фізичного
перебування тобто офлайнового навчання
заборона фізичного перебування в
закладах які знаходяться поблизу е
білоруського кордону 50кілометрова Зона
А в нас це територія так густо заселено
це 30% загалом наших закладів освіти
якщо подивитись по вибірці Піза то це ее
з 39 можливих 21 заклад знаходився на
території саме 50 кмрової зони тобто
проводити дослідження не можна далі
звична проблема для всіх укриття Ми ж не
готувалися до війни укриття були далеко
не в усіх ще ві ві відкинулося кілька
закладів в результаті сім закладів ми
знайшли в тих семи закладах ми проводили
дослідження третя проблема - це були
діти Сьогодні вже про цю проблему
говорили хоча майтилова умовно тилова
область але наші теж діти батьки втікали
від війни
евакуація переселення за кордон дуже
великої кількості
е сімей з учнями все це призвело до того
що із вибіркою власне вже з учнівською
вибіркою з учасниками безпосередніми
також була проблема Ну але це були
проблеми організації які ні в що не йшли
вже власне з проблемою виконання
проблема виконання проблема проведення
то це вже ми всі торкнулися тому що так
сталося що графік Піза співпався з
найлютішим періодом Ось цього
енергетичного терору який влаштував
ворог і Я особисто пам'ятаю той день 10
жовтня Сьогодні його вже двічі згадували
чи навіть тричі різні спікери 10 жовтня
страшний день Я особисто прийшла в
заклад освіти проводити Піза я дійсно
особисто працювала в аудиторії і я
пам'ятаю я прийшла з тривогою потім ми
разом з учнями А це був потужний заклад
нас було понад 50 чоловік разом з учнями
з вчителями з директором зрештою того
закладу ми 4чотири години сиділи в
укритті причому не просто ми були в
укритті А ми хвилювалися ходили з
телефонами шукали wi-fi шукали інтернет
тому що ми вже чули що відбувається ми
чули як страждає на той момент
страждають всі регіони Ми знали що
відбувається в Києві Ми знали як і те як
Горіли автівки гинули люди Це все було в
той страшний день З того дня ми пере
перенесли звичайно тестування таких
перенесень ще було кілька а далі кожне
тестування практично кожне тестування
співпадало з тривогою і був у нас
випадок коли ми проводили закінчували
тестування о
20:30 наші діти сиділи тестувались вони
були виснажені вони були втомлені але
все-таки вони гарно тестувались пані Ало
Ми сьогодні говорили про результати але
за результатами насправді ми розуміємо
що стоять ті 15-тирічні Підлітки Які у
цей складний час прийшли і тут питання
таке наскільки тільки важко можливо було
працювати з батьками це одне частина
питання а друга частина питання от ви
сказали що були безпосередньо присутні у
пункті тестування де проводилося
дослідження от на вашу думку і за вашими
спостереженнями як діти сприймали
конкретно цю ситуацію коли вони змушені
під
е повітря під час повітряних тривог
чекати закінчення тестування От і їхнє
самопочуття з одного боку і з іншого
боку Можливо у вас є якийсь інсайт від
дітей я ж впевнений що ви спілкувалися
після проведення от яке їхнє враження
від тестів е з якими вони
працювали ви знаєте е я не можу говорити
звичайно стовідсоткову гарантію я давати
не буду але моя особиста впевненість в
тому що наші діти працювали максимально
щиро і максимально на повну потужність
своїх можливостей дуже високе Ну
по-перше дійсно Я працювала і не один
раз я була в закладі освіти і я бачила
Елементарно найяскравіший показник
скільки часу наші діти використовували
для виконання тестів Вони сиділи досить
довго Ну ми знаємо що є часом умовно
дуже сильні математики які за 10 хвилин
Все як-небудь можна вирішити і побігти
собі відпочивати Ні Такого не було в
мене навіть було таке враження що наші
діти з початком повномасштабного
вторнення дуже серйозно подоростішали
вони досить серйозно ставилися до того
що вони беруть участь в цьому
дослідженні е щодо батьків той страшний
день 10 жовтня ми дійсно не проводили
після тих обстрілів не проводили
тестування тому що от в той день в той
заклад батьки з'їхалися і забрали дітей
а далі я знаю От в нас був випадок
наприклад коли те що дитина потрапила до
вибірки дослідження стало для однієї
родини одним із факторів прийняття
рішення про повернення з закордону в
воюючу країну
діти так Ви знаєте це було ну для мене
наприклад це було показник це дуже
показово і це батьки прийняли рішення
тобто батьки Також мені здається вони
мож може навіть і пишалися тим що таке
серйозне проводиться дослідження а для
дітей може це був дійсно від сил такий
до мирного часу і до того що буде після
перемоги це їм було потрібно я от зараз
абсолютно переконана що крім того що ми
отримали результати які будуть підставою
для освітніх політик Ну те все що ми
прекрасно розуміємо Піза Ще нам показала
нашу живучість Піза показала те як ми
вміємо виживати стійкі стійкістю ми живі
і ми будемо жити і наші діти однозначно
орієнтувалися беручи участь в цьому
дослідженні орієнтувались на те що воно
згодиться для перспективи воно згодиться
для майбутнього дякую дякую пані Ало і
хочу зауважити що сьогодні уже звучало
кілька разів і від Андреаса шляйхера і
від гійома буске про те що наші дані
дані України дуже чисті і фактично ні
багато хто сумнівався у тому що ми
зможемо провести все на високому рівні і
отримати ті дані які можна буде
порахувати і отримати відповідний
результат однак нам це вдалося і вдалося
це значною мірою завдяки тому що в
регіонах У нас є прекрасна команда
регіональних координаторів яких сьогодні
представила закладі освіти вчителі
комп'ютерні адміністратори однозначно ті
що безпосередньо Як то кажуть ті що
працюють в полі вони безпосередньо вико
нували левову частку роботи вони молодці
абсолютно і тут коли ми говоримо про
команду Піза ми Звісно що можемо
говорити про український центр де певна
частина людей безпосередньо до проєкту
Піза задіяні але водночас це велика
команда уже освітян які залучені на
місцях і це насправді потужна спільнота
яких пов'язала Піза і частиною цієї
спільноти є ці люди які зараз продовжать
нашу розмову зокрема це ті
хто мав можливі сть працювати з
безпосередніми відповідями наших учнів і
Почнемо ми з Андрія меляника мого колеги
з Львівського регіонального центру
оцінювання якості освіти він сьогодні
представить нам пропоную поговорити про
результати з
математики пан Андрій відомий Експерт у
цій сфері І хоча Андрій не писав звіту
безпосередньо у звіті ми маємо матеріал
з математики який створила
проаналізувала і представила для вас
наша старша екзаменаторка яка Сьогодні
на жаль не змогла бути з
нами Юлія простакова вона уже другий
цикл з нами і вона прекрасні матеріали
запропонувала у звіт у додатку А ви
зможете ознайомитися з цими матеріалами
але Андрій уважно знає як Піза Точніше
він досконало знає як Піза проводилася і
він прекрасно знає ці результати от
Андрію на твою
думку плакати сміятися чи посипати
голову попилом як то кажуть оскільки
Математика була провідною галуззю І
власне ми цього циклу довідалися про неї
найбільше от на твою думку де проблеми
найбільші чи можна з ними впоратися чи
взагалі реально Це В нинішніх обставинах
коли ми живемо в умовах
війни Дякую е Я би сказав так широко
відомий в вузьких колах так
то
скромна коли ми говоримо
про результати з математики в Пізі
то я не бачу якихось причин для трагедії
чи причин Для радості
це є таке беземоційне все інше Це є
насправді
якісь ставлення Так це це наше ставлення
до тих результатів а результат є такий
як є і коли ми говоримо про конкретні
результати Василю дай наступний слайд
щоб
відразу центральна
[музика]
Центральна
зараз Андрію продовжуй ми з'ясуємо зараз
проблему Ну можна говорити про дві
проблемні лінії одна проблемна лінія
Стосується власне змісту математики ну
завжди завжди важливо коли ми говоримо
пані Алла говорила про процедури
а друге крило будь-якого дослідження
будь-якого оцінювання - це зміст так і
дуже конкретну проблему ми маємо з двома
лініями з лінією теми відсотки пропорції
робота з даними ймовірності
е але ще раз наголошу що це є проблемні
області в тій математичній підготовці
15-тирічних які висвітлила Піза це не
означає що в нас нема там проблем з е
тригонометричними рівняннями та
нерівностями на які Піза не звертає
уваги бо для Пізи важливішим є е
широковживані у життєвих ситуаціях теми
а це саме і є відсотки робота з даними
математична
статистика представлення даних на Піза
на це звертає особливу
увагу друга лінія з якою
[музика]
Піза висвітлила що є проблеми - це
вміння аргументувати доводити логічно
міркувати обґрунтовувати свої відповіді
та
висновки Я переговорив з Юлією
простаковою перед своєю доповіддю щоб ну
так
доволі узгодити ті питання Бо насправді
вона працювала з даними вона формувала
звіт вона формувала цей додаток і Юлія
погодилася з тим також що дуже багато
наших учасників ну прям
ігнорують прохання чи вимогу до них а
отримавши якусь число числову відповідь
спробуйте це нити спробуйте
це навести аргументи на її
підтвердження це
Ну немає немає цієї культури щоб це
пояснювати коли ми говоримо
про вплив це надалі і про зв'язки
наприклад з зовнішнім незалежним
оцінюванням чи національним
мультипредметним тестом то ті зв'язки
теж є однозначні
бо
бо дуже коротенька тема в програмі
математики зовнішнього незалежного
оцінювання яка має таку дуже довгу назву
комбінаторика теорія ймовірностей та
математична
статистика на неї невелика кількість
завдань є і дуже часто вчителі та і
репетитори кажуть Ну навіщо на це
звертати увагу вага тих завдань
невеличка якщо ми проігноруємо цю тему
то нічого страшного не станеться в
глобальному сенсі Давай краще на
планіметрію функції рівняння нерівності
числа і вирази на глобальні теми
звертати увагу ситуація змінюється бо ті
завдання в нмт і в ЗНО стають звичними
Вони стають вони стабільно є їх часом є
більше часом менше Але до цього вже учні
звикають і і ігнору насправді стає
менше чи є проблема з вмінням
аргументувати доводити чи вона
висвітлюється в зовнішньому незалежному
оцінюванні так
останнє останні рік це був 2020 рік коли
в нас
була відкрита частина з розгорнутою
відповіддю абсолютно чітко показує що
від 60 до 90% учасників на ті частині де
можна набрати від чотирьох до шести
балів отримують нулі
тобто половина ігнорує а ще якийсь
відсоток не може набрати навіть одного
елементарного балу тому проблеми які
висвітлює
Піза і проблеми які показує зовнішнє
незалежне оцінювання і національний
мультипредметний тест абсолютно
ідентичні що з тим можна робити
е-е
я буду дуже конкретні речі ну як ви
бачите
конкретні конкретні теми І абсолютно
конкретні способи вирішення Ми наприклад
у своєму авторському колективі е ввели в
тему сьомих Ну от звідки проблема з
відсотками і звідки проблема з з
ймовірностями відсотки вивчають в
п'ятому-шостому класі ймовірність
вивчають в дев'ятому класі де ті
відсотки треба буде використовувати і
отой трирічний розрив Часовий
е учні пробують вивчати ймовірності не
знаю забувши вже про відсотки так отой
трирічний розрив треба чимось заповнити
і ми пропонуємо наприклад в програмі
сьмого-9в'ятого класу ми Прописали тему
фінансова грамотність де ті
відсотки будуть вивчати на предметній
темі на на цікавій і
зрозумілій тим учням базової школи
теми один варіант вирішення варіантів
може бути дуже
багато як вирішити
е-е проблеми з аргументуванням і
проблеми з доведеннями теж треба
формулювати завдання таким чином щоб там
була не тільки числова відповідь А
щоб було пояснення А звідки ще та
числова відповідь взялася А про аргу
наведіть аргументи на підтримку отого
вашого висновку Ми теж над цим працюємо
ми своїм авторським колективом
Стараємося формулювати завдання у
контрольних роботах Таким чином
Щоб стимулювати і
заохочувати учнів до вирішення до власне
такого розв'язання тих завдань е
[музика]
коли Хто би мав бути читачем в першу
чергу Ну коли ми кажемо що там наприклад
звіт будуть читати всі ну не вірю коли
ми кажемо що звіт будуть читати всі
вчителі не вірю в першу чергу звіт мали
би читати розробники програм розробники
підручників розробники посібників
задачників І власне опосередковано
впливати на вчителів Таким чином тобто
якщо в підручнику буде от сформульовано
Таким чином завдання вчитель хоче не
хоче мусить то завдання давати учневі і
самому з ним розбиратися ще одним
активним читачем це будуть розробники
зовнішнього незалежного оцінювання Ну
мало того що вони є активними там
читачами і впроваджувачами вони в першу
чергу є активними писачами так Бо бо
вони той той звіт той звіт пишуть і на
підтвердження от наступний слайд якщо
можна того
що Ну можливо цей слайд стане стимулом
для
е ширшого читання для ширшого кола
читачів наприклад репетитори
зацікавляться звітом наприклад
випускники шкіл зацікавляться звітом бо
от є два завдання одне завдання з Піз
12го року інше завдання зовнішнього
незалежного оцінювання 20-го року
е дуже подібні завдання за фабулою за
формулюваннями хоча зношне завдання
набагато математично більш
е ну більш математичне Ну так і є бо там
треба та Піза хоче більш життєве
завдання ЗНО хоче більш завдання
математичне і навіть результати їхні є
дуже дуже подібні якщо пізівське
завдання зробили
43,6% учасників в 12-му році то зношно
зробили
38,3 учасника у 2020 році
А як заклик Прочитайте звіт Подивіться
завдання раптом в
24му році ви таке завдання зустрінете у
своєму національному мультипредметному
тесті і буде вам щастя з іншого боку що
це означає це означає що рухаємося
думаємо і працюємо ми в одному керунку в
одному керунку з пізою а це означає що
зуль та буде дякую дякую Андрію Ну я тут
хочу зауважити ще що фактично перед вами
ті колеги мої які крім всього іншого є
розробниками державних нових державних
стандартів для нової української школи і
кожен із них долучився продовжує або пра
створював підручники і тому коли Андрій
говорив про авторський колектив то
йдеться про новий підручник Я так
розумію де будуть Можна припустити
імплементовані основні ідеї нової
української школи і ідеї Пізи відразу
відразу скажу що От наприклад ми зараз
пишемо підручник сьомого сьомого класу і
в тому підручнику кожен параграф
розпочинається з життєвої ситуації яку
обговорюють учні кожен з Ну я не знаю як
це нашому автору Олександру школьному
вдалося Ну бо він писав оту теоретичну
частину але ну неймовірно В нас немає
параграфа дає тільки е Тільки от якась
теоретична математика чиста математика
кожен параграф починається життєвим ну
це от абсолютно пізівський підхід екую
Дякую Андрію це супер і тут хочу сказати
що заважимо товариство що Піза 2018 року
Піза 2022 року і Піза 2025 року це
будуть ті цикли Пізи де ми фактично
будемо тестувати тестували і
тестуватимемо учнівство яке вчилося за
старими програмами за старим стандартом
і лише в
28му році здається якщо 25-й 20 29й рік
ми зможемо протестувати врешті тих учнів
і учениць які проходть проходитимуть
навчання за курсом нової української
школи і фактично ті які зокрема
вчитимуться за підручниками нового
покоління сподіваємося Ну і зауважу що
е те що регіональні корди наторед пані
Алла була дуже важливий контекст тут
який що це інститути післядипломної
педагогічної освіти які зараз фактично
працюють у напрямку того щоб формувати
вчителів для нової української школи і
сподіваюся що ці Результати будуть
донесені які озвучені описані
представлені у звіті будуть донесені до
вчительства і вони зацікавляться звітом
е крім математиків Я впевнений звітом
зацікавляться І е представники читацької
галузі яка була минулого циклу провідної
і сьогодні у нас Поліна Ткач Моя
колежанка моя землячка і ко ми
співпрацюємо тісно зокрема як автори
підручників зокрема так Поліно питання
таке читання минулого разу нас
порадувало певною мірою все-таки наші
сподівання виявилися більш
песимістичними в 18-му році ніж ми
отримали насправді А цього циклу ну
щонайменше Я не очікував такого різкого
падіння от зі спостережень тебе як Стар
екзаменатора З чим це пов'язано які
проблеми головні От ти бачиш як практик
і Можна з цим щось
зробити так Ну насправді не можу сказати
що вони були очікуваними не можу сказати
що вони були неочікуваними такі
результати
насправді
перша перша проблема з якою ми
стикнулись під час пере Вірки на яку
звернули увагу експерти які перевіряли
роботи
це надзвичайна збільшилась кількість
копійованих
робіт порівняно з попереднім циклом ну з
попереднім циклом це зрозуміло тому що
там була паперовий варіант да
переписувати часто лінуються наші
підлітки Тому це було зрозуміло але ця
кількість збільшилась навіть порівняно з
пілотним етапом Який теж був
в принципі
е
комп'ютерним Друга проблема з якої про
яку уже насправді говорили говорили
неодноразово
це графічні об'єкти в минулому звіті
дуже багато про це було написано І
взагалі Ну багато говорилося тому що
вперше ця проблема постала ви знаєте що
на жаль в текстах У нас дуже мало
використовується графічних об'єктах тому
я принагідно прорекламую попередній звіт
2018 року де дуже багато і Я особисто
писала про графічні об'єкти а сьогодні
хотіла зупинитися на проблемі вкладок
тому що комп'ютерний формат передбачає
те що є дуже багато
текстів які оформленні у вигляді вкладок
комп'ютерних вкладок ну уявімо собі як в
Гуглі причому оці вкладки вони різні є
підвкладки я їх так для себе називаю не
знаю як вони правильно називаються є
якісь покликання так які висвітлюють
якісь підказки і таке інше так от попри
те що наші діти Я впевнена 100%тково що
кожного дня працюють в інтерне ну
працюють тобто як щось роблять в
інтернеті і якимось чином взаємодіють з
гу тим же Гуглом і з цими вкладками
краще ніж їх батьки
орієнтуються Попри це під час виконання
завдань чомусь вони страшенно в цих
вкладках
плутались Просто видно з самих
відповідей що вони не
орієнтуються в скажімо з якого тексту
брати да Тобто який текст взяти з якої
вкладки де шукати Що робити з тими
вкладками і на це треба звертати увагу
тому що на жаль дуже мало завдань такого
типу які б готували наших дітей саме
використовувати
комп'ютерні оці
ну формати да чи як це назвати
середовища Для саме виконання завдань не
для розваг не для якихось задоволень Да
не для пошуків ну чогось для себе чисто
а саме для виконання завдань
А і ще одна проблема про яку уже вже
неодноразово сьогодні навіть згадували
це проблема того що замість інтеграції
інтерпретації замість аналізу наші діти
узагальнюють переказують
моралізаторствують е страшенна кількість
таких відповідей типу
ее навчатися корисно природу треба
берегти причому це відповіді завжди
актуальні як ви розумієте але вони не
дають відповіді на ті завдання які
постають
І тут також привернула увагу Що нового
насправді нового з'явилося через те що
от комп'ютерний формат передбачає те що
майже всі тексти до завдань були
множинними майже не було одиничних
текстів а множинні - це тексти коли
дається кілька текстів два інколи навіть
три тексти і треба щось якимось чином в
цих текстах зорієнтуватися для відповіді
на запитання
і наші діти не вміють вибирати
інформацію орієнтуючись на деталі вони
не звертають увагу на якісь певні
обмеження формат Піза передбачає формат
завдань передбачає що є чіткі обмеження
для тобто треба не просто знайти
будь-яку інформацію не треба не просто
визначити якусь загальну ідею А треба
знайти
якусь якусь інформацію яка базується на
деталі в тексті І от пошук деталій
Зазвичай це
[музика]
велика проблема І ще на що звернули
увагу експерти це
дуже наші діти вводять себе в контекст в
контекст завдання Оце те чого скажімо на
що ми або не звернули увагу в
попередньому циклі А або такого не було
в тако в такій кількості діти вводять
себе в контекст завдання в контекст
тексту І замість того щоб відповідати на
завдання за текстом вони починають
розмірковувати на проблему тексту на
проблему завдання е оцінювати завдання
говорити там цікаве їм це завдання чи
нецікаве або скажімо розмірковувати про
якусь проблему яка сказана е про яку
йшлося в тексті і розказувати що Вони
думають про цю
проблему це теж І до речі в цьому
аспекті є ще така такий момент про який
теж казали стрес у дітей е те що вони
рефлексували на ситуацію було дуже
багато відповідей такого типу
як от ми виконуємо ці завдання а в
країні війна Навіщо це потрібно
або що тобто такі завдання були Ой не
завдання Вибачте відповіді на завдання і
це показує
звісно Скажімо так унаочнює одну з
причин чому ми бачимо такий
результат
бороба щодо
боротьби насправді якщо можна наступний
слайд зверніть
увагу от це цей слайд я не чесно кажучи
не пам'ятаю показувала його сьогодні чи
ні Можливо я передбачаю події але
Зверніть увагу що найбільше я не
математик Я не дружу з
з цифрами але е найбільші от відсотки да
найбільші оці кольорові блакитний і
рожевий колір це рівні читання 1а і
2 і от будь ласка якщо можна наступний
слайд відповідь на питання Чому так від
вається яку я для себе бачу ну крім
зрозуміло уже було проговорено про
онлайн затяжний і про війну безперечно
це величезний величезний чинник того Ну
чому так відбувається але зверніть увагу
типові завдання в українських
підручників для цього звіту я робила
огляд українських підручників
і тут двічі типові завдання друга
колонка має називати рівні читання
називатися рівні читання Піза зокрема о
а і 2 і от ви бачите типові завдання да
сформулюй тему про що ти довідався
складіть план доберіть заголовок і
відповідно
ті ті вміння які
формує формується у дитини да тобто
уміння розмірковувати на простіте теми
уміння розпознавати головну тему і таке
інше Таким чином фактично фактично ми
отримуємо те що ми закладаємо
а І власне іншої відповіді У мене немає
попри те що сьогодні уже згадував Пан
Руслан на попередній панелі згадував про
те що в стандарті прописані абсолютно
всі вміння Піза в новому Я маю на увазі
державному стандарті які необхідно
формувати
і але при цьому ситуація така от Дякую
Поліно і ситуація
зміниться одним словом я дуже на це
сподіваюсь Ну
чому фактично ситуація має змінитися бо
Як бачите картину яку показала Поліна
Борисівна проаналізувавши наші
підручники ну досить сумна і сьогодні
про це уже вже говорив Артур пройдаков
зокрема що наші підручники класичні це
підручники де типові питання про що тема
Про що ідея і історія літератури або що
А читання - це те що в Конче необхідно
для того щоб Наші учні могли вчитися і
засвоювати не тільки мовно-літературний
матеріал а і природничий Ну от якщо
подивитися на наші підручники з
природничих наук то це багато тексту це
багато тексту який містить додаткову
інформацію деталі формули от сла як
заслужений вчитель України який ще й
вчитель практик який що працює в одному
з чудових закладів на Харківщині от на
вашу
думку проблема читання впливає вплинула
на те якими результати маємо з
природничих
наук
так Добрий день колежанки і
колеги Насправді я задавав собі завжди
питання про те чи мо можуть бути
якісь гарні результати з математики чи
природничих наук у людини яка не вміє
читати адже читання то є перша дія яку
ти робиш Коли ти стикаєшся із завданням
я міркував над тими завданнями і моя
відповідь уже частково тут була озвучена
я просто її зараз доведу до кінця ту
відповідь яку я для себе сформулював з
приводу от тих результатів які ми маємо
та невелике статистично невелике
зниження з математики і природничих
дисциплін І значне зниження із читання і
я вам хочу сказати от що дослідження
світові впливу локдаунів на системи
освіти довели що під час локдауну
статистично збільшилася понад ніж вдвічі
частота відвідування
молоддю з соціальних мереж а соціальні
мережі - це Short messages це не
пролонгріди і то навіть ті Short
messages часто не читаються повністю а
читаються тільки їхні
хайлайти
і у нас в Україні це
посилилося сидінням вдома під час
початку війни і під час цього сидіння
вдома messes стали нашим мейнстрімом І
зовсім ми перестали звертатися до тексту
як такого Ну тому що ті повідомлення які
пишуть в соцмережах то не можна Їх
назвати повноцінним текстом після того я
звернувся ще раз до наших завдань ми як
старші екзаменатори дякувати богові мали
доступ до тих завдань і дивилися на них
і я подивився на завдання з математики і
природи зовсім е іншим поглядом я не
дивився на зміст А я дивився на форму
Вони переважно складаються з дуже
коротких текстів і
ее інфографіки умовно да
найрізноманітнішої графіків таблиць схем
діаграм
тощо а завдання із читання складаються
із текстів
доволі об'ємних причому різного сенсу в
тому числі і природничого
змісту і звичайно що починаючи читати ті
тексти
е колеги я вам скажу
я Ну от я сам ловив себе весь час на
думці що я коли доходжу до дна першого
тексту а їх треба ще два прочитати щоби
починати відповідати на завдання Я вже
втрачаю дедо там зміст тобто мій
більш досвідчений скажемо так Розум і
більше звикший до лонгрідів Бо я їх
прочитав більше просто живу довше ніж 15
років в цьому світі і весь час щото
читаю і то я уже трошечки спсутий отим
от всім Ну локдауном і так далі а ну під
час війни погодьтеся у перші місяці наші
когнітивні здібності ну різко впали прям
я ну У мене точно і в кола мого оточення
дуже сильно бо ми не могли якби автори
всяких там текстів і стандартів і різних
речей Ну я не міг писати тексти і не міг
їх читати потім воно якось відновилося
не знаючи повною мірою і тому оті
результати з читання то насправді і да і
оті результати типа з
математики Можна прибрати цю цей
красивий слайд і показати
наступний він не буде такий красивий але
все-таки він буде більш змістовний
А то наші результати Подивіться будь
ласка ви ж бачите там посередині Україна
значить природнича зверху а читання
знизу насправді результати з читання їм
можна вірити а результатам з природи не
дуже сильно бо там читати треба було
Менше якби результат якби завдання з
природи були написані Так же розлого як
і завдання з природи як завдання з
читання ну Повірте ніхто би їх не став
би читати а
і я абсолютно погоджуюся з тими
попередніми ораторами яких вже називали
і цитували які говорили що ми не так
вчимо там да і не так і мої давні
дискусії з Василем про те скільки творів
має бути в програмі Да і про те що їх
має бути так мало щоби кілька уроків
протягом семестру можна було присвятити
просто читанню вголос поролям тексту
твору щоби призвичаїти дитину до
лонхріду до бачення багато буков на
сторінці і не лякатися того і не
нудитися від того а навпаки проникати
вглиб і отримувати від того кайф то
слухайте якщо навіть ми дорослі так ну
якби уже відвикаємо Від того і в мене
тоді виникає питання якщо далі так піде
От так далі піде світ і так іде
розвиток то чи мусимо ми торкатися
лонгрідів взагалі і в принципі чимуже
нам переходити на інфографіку де ми От
Швидко Все бачимо і
я насправді зараз не маю відповіді для
вас е якби від себе як від учителя але я
знаю про те що результати Піза коли всі
говорили сьогодні
е ну так умовно кажучи в колишньому
вчителі А я в теперішньому ін так не
полишаю ту професію я вам скажу для мене
результати Піза то не є результати моїх
учнів і учениць то є мої результати якщо
і мої власні учні і учениці цього року
не змогли взяти в тому участь я все одно
вважаю то моїми результатами тобто
нашими вчительськими і насправді не
треба виховувати дітей треба виховувати
себе діти все одно будуть на тебе
схожими і якщо я говорю з вчителями Я
дуже багато зустрічаюся і проводжу
різних тренінгів я пропонуючи вчителям
прямо в залі давати відповіді на ці
питання Піза і типу Піза і те що я бачу
я прекрасно розумію що наші результати
Ну ще слухайте дуже класні тому що
насправді нашим всім організаціям і от
залі буде панель після нас якщо на них
вистачить часу після наших промов але
Вистачить я Сподіваюся громадські
організації які долучаться до підготовки
вчителів Ну і мало Надії але все-таки є
інститути післядипломної освіти може
бути то я вам хочу сказати що треба
учити вчителів насправді на курсах
читанню із
розумінням як провідній на скрізній
навичці тому що з тим є проблеми у
вчителів усіх предметів а надто У
вчителів
літератури якби то не дивно було Ну я
просто про то бачу і помічаю Треба
підготувати курси прямо для вчителів і
примусити їх проходити курси Бо у нас
знаєте зараз написано 30 годин на рік
має кожний пройти і 5 рік 150 годин
суперово і зз них 10% обов'яз
обов'язково інклюзія 10% обов'язково
психологоемоційна підтримка і так далі а
скільки відсотків фахової підготовки має
бути ніде не написано слухайте вчитель
біології Може взагалі жодної години не
прослухати із новітньої біології і при
тому бути атестованим підвищеним
кваліфікаційно Це не дурня Скажіть мені
будь ласка і то я про пізу по тому що
вчитель-фахівець в першу чергу а вже в
другу чергу Там всяке інше І софтскіли -
це дуже круто Але про хардскіли теж не
треба забувати і для вчителів в першу
чергу і не дивлячись на те що будь-які
метапредметні
навички важливіші ніж будь-які предме
тні тим не менше вчитель в своїй
професійній діяльності має покладатися
на свої предметні навички і тому читання
з розумінням і всі решта
11 наскрізних умінь от прям по кожному
із них треба зробити
курс чують мене да представники
громадських організацій зараз прямо по
кожній і запропонувати його для вчителів
і примусити їх обов'язково пройти Ці
курси і тоді їх атестувати І вот тоді
результати нашого вчительства спізи
покращаться А результати наших нашого
учнівства тоді перевищать всі наші очі
руслане Васильовичу сьогодні звучить
скільки таких пропозицій що здається
після представлення звіту всі будуть
говорити тільки про те скільки
революційних ідей прозвучало але один
момент Тетяна сервна
буквально руслане наступний цикл 25го
року це провідною галуззю буде
природничу науковіід пліни Що б ви
порадили зараз на що звернути увагу
освітянам і зокрема от нагадаю що
рамковий документ із природничо-наукової
галузі уже оприлюднено Це дуже цікавий
документ і якщо вже говорити про те що
нам можна робити то можливо хоча б із
цим документом лонгрідом як ви кажете
ознайомитися
хочете від мене ще пропозиції
даже забагато але і ще якихось Та я той
нгрт подолав і він прям таки вражає і на
наступний цикл дослідження ми матимемо
безумовно новий підхід до укладання
завдань з природничої галузі він буде
компетентнісним Я хочу завершити просто
словам в мене немає жодної соціальної
мережі тут і я ними не користуюся бо Ну
я просто лякаюся за себе бо я боюся
Short messages але в мене є друзі які
мене весь час тримають в курсі І от я
хочу вам прочитати допис
директорки дуже класної за назвою І
взагалі одної із приватних Київських
шкіл тут а це у відповідь на мій тренінг
по компетентнісноорієнтованих завданнях
які я провів ви всі були задоволені
компетентнісноорієнтоване навчання
перешкоджає формуванню картини світу
дитини на жаль воно формує саме людину
минулого обома руками підтримую думку що
державний стандарт на жаль застаріла
історія для майбутнього України і
подібні заходи я б рекомендувала
державним школам а не нашим приватним бо
ми вже пішли маю надію вперед Від такого
подібного Я би не закінчував Я би сказав
би так закінчити треба бо ми вже пішли і
ми знаємо куди школа школа очо
Дякую школа очолювана от такою
директоркою і там далі я маю ще 10000
дописів о такого плану як всі
розтікаються мислею подреву що
компетентності то застаріле для України
слухайте тобто ну Вся Європа певно ніц
не розуміє в освіті і Піза не про то я
вам хочу сказати що головне для мене як
для людини абсолютно закоханої в пізу
прям
ідейно я вам хочу сказати що Піза - це
про майбутнє це про справді про майбутнє
і переможці в Пізі Подивіться будь ласка
це ті хто живуть реально в
2023 році сьогодні А ті хто внизу Вони
живуть десь і ти кого виключили Таня ти
говорила сьогодні і ми аплодували да
наші пришелепкуваті сусіди це дві країни
які з усіх боків оточені майбутнім і
насправді війна наша іде не тільки і
навіть не стільки за нашу незалежність
як за наше майбутнє за те щоб ми жили в
майбутньому а вони хочуть це майбутнє
зупинити але ми знаємо що час не спінити
ми безумовно переможемо і в Пізі Ми
звичайно будемо кращими то товариство Ви
побачили яка суперова команда Пізи з
середини і Я впевнений що наступні
результати Якими б вони не були з
природничої галузі зокрема як провідної
вони все-таки покажуть що наша система
освіти стійка тому що її формують
зокрема і такі люди які з якими ми
познайомилися Дякую друзі наступна
[оплески]
панель так друзі продовжуємо наступна
панель І власне модератор цієї панелі
пан Роман Шиян він заступник директора
команди підтримки від новлення та реформ
Міністерства освіти і науки України Я
перепрошую що читаю просто ця назва
нещодавно змінилася
моя ще Роман не запам'ятав А я Тим паче
далі в нас віцеголова громадської
організації едкемп Україна Олена
масалітіна ми вже говорили про те що в
Піз є сестричка і Пані Олена це хрещена
мама сестрички прошу голова правління с
март освіта Галина титаш це і мама і
сестричка і хрещена багатьох освітніх
проєктів керівник тренінгового центру
освіторі Юрій
гайдученко це і тато і братик і багато
що в нас тут така сімейна історія
вимальовується багатьох освітніх
проектів співголова батьки сос
організації яка сьогодні повідомить нам
батьківський погляд на те що ми робимо
це мачуха мачуха в нашій чудовій
освітянській родині і директорка Go
Global Тетяна
Коврига вони займаються дуже такою
потужною діяльністю зокрема пані Тетяна
написала мені щойно повідомлення все з
читанням печально але тепер я знаю що
робити власне розкажіть нам про це прошу
друзі Дякую Так приємно бути в цьому
родинному
колі Я мабуть почну з кількох добрих
новин і ці добрі новини зводяться до
того
що ми маємо
зараз завершуємо зараз цикл державних
стандартів які занурені в цю всю увесь
цей Піза скажемо так контекст по-перше
ми були достатньо далекоглядними і коли
ми щойно починали цю роботу с років тому
Андреас ляхр якось сказав що добрий
стандарт робота над добрим стандартом
триває 7 років оце ми зараз наближаємося
до того моменту
щоб щоб визнати що те що ми робимо Це
добре І ця група розробників стандарту
була інфільтрована агентурою
українського центру оцінювання якості
спочатку А коли е сталася Піза
2018 То ми ще й туди до кооптували
е цих все як вони називається правильно
державних екзаменаторів так головних
екзаменаторів і отой стандарт базової
середньої освіти
був ними опрацьований а потім
обговорений з кожною галузевою групою і
далі ці наші колеги брали участь у
допрацюванні цього документа Ну і
зрозуміло що зараз це все продовжується
в стандарті профільної середньої освіти
е і який от зараз зараз завершується
його громадське обговорення е і я вважаю
що це що це вже така ви відповідь на
випередження на питання того які
політики Нам потрібні для того щоб е
відповісти на ті виклики які ми бачимо
зараз за результатами Піза е зрозуміло
що все це з покрите дуже щільною вуаллю
спочатку ковіду і зараз війни і очевидно
що будь-які дані пов'язані саме з тим і
тому те що ми побачимо Я дуже сподіваюся
що в 28му 29 28му році Так Василь
порахував буде вже Піза за
нушим от і ми тоді побачимо якісь
позитивні позитивні зрушення в
результатах і очевидно що ми тоді не
зможемо стверджувати що це тому що ну ж
так спрацювало але принаймні Ми
сподіваємося що нуж буде таким
позитивним чинником для того аби Це аби
це
власне сталося оцей оця позитивна
позитивна динаміка звертаючись до
документа це вже я зараз переходжу до
діалогу звертаючись до документа от в
цій стислі стис стислий документ який
дає узагальнення і основних
результатів на звертає на себе увагу
пункт п'ятий про те що Наші учні
задоволені життям про це вже говорили
сьогодні на попередніх панелях про те що
вони в відчувають приналежність до своїх
закладів освіти і цей білонгн в нашому
контексті Це просто дуже якась така
жорстка річ Можливо вона частково дає
відповідь на питання Чому Наші учні
зберігаю намагаються зберегти зв'язок зі
своїм закладом навіть якщо перебувають
далеко від нього е і про те що булінгу в
нас не так багато Як виявилося е і все ж
таки психологічний добробут наших
підлітків погіршився І я хотів би
звернутися до вас Олено з огляду на ваш
досвід роботи з цією
проблематикою
соціально-емоційноетичного аспекту ее
щоб ви поділилися оцим сестринським
досвідом про те як
дослідження досен зможе доповнити і
можливо допомогти знайти відповіді на
оці власне на оцей спектр питань який ми
тут бачимо е і одразу з до з вашого
досвіду в
Ну давайте може почнемо з цього а тоді
вже я е маю ще одне питання до вас добре
Доброго дня друзі знаєте українське
прислів'я е про сало сало як сало що
його пробувати та чули таке от досен як
досен але я вам пропоную зараз його
попробувати перш ніж ми будемо про це
говорити Скажіть будь ласка як ви ви ще
відчуваєте свої когнітивні здібності на
цей момент зараз Давайте так хто
відчуває свої когнітивні здібності
можете махнути будь ласка рукою Дякую
Добре так ми зараз з вами зробимо одну
дуже-дуже просту практику
от попробуйте сісти так щоб ви відчували
все спину
сідниці стегна щоб ваші ноги стояли отак
на підлозі відчуваєте Як ви спираєтесь
на
стілець так пройдіться будь ласка Так
увагою швиденько по тілу від в маківки
до стоп чи у вас скрізь все добре може
вам десь захочеться порухатися
розслабитися якщо хочеться прикрити
можна очі трошечки або
закрити і знайдіть ті місця де Вам може
бути не дуже комфортно і щось з ними
зробіть от прям почухайте
розслабте щось зробіть Щоб стало Добре
дякую Можна повернутися назад і
завершуючи цю практику знайдіть прямо
біля себе
мінімум чотири поверхні різні тактильні
на дотик і прям обома долонями так
Доторкніться Ну допусим там штани у вас
да одна тактильне одне відчуття спинка
стільця прям от прям двома долонями не
соромтеся так тепер пощупайте сусіда
сусідку чотири нам треба О
кра двома
долонь що ми з вами зроби били ми зараз
з вами трошечки махнули другим крилом от
правильно сказав пан Роман і в
попередній панелі колеги говорили
фактично Піза це мегаважливо але це якщо
тільки Піза це якби ми летіли махаючи
тільки одним крилом дослідження
соціально-емоційних навичок - це друге
крило Якщо ми будемо махати двома
крилами одночасно Ну нам легше буде
летіти дальше в нас получиться краще що
таке дослідження соціаль емоційних
навичок воно власне цього року тільки
вперше в усьому світі запустилося
і Україна одразу приєдналася якщо до
Піза мийшли якийсь час то до до Сен ми
приєдналися одразу результати
міжнародного дослідження будуть уже в
квітні національного будуть у
червні як Воно пов'язане як воно корелює
з дослідженнями Піза І навіщо нам воно
взагалі потрібно це вже не секрет ця
Прекрасна аудиторія яка тут сьогодні яка
нас слухає може онлайн дивиться ще Ми
прекрасно знаємо вже Що рівень
успішності рівень академічних досягнень
дуже прямо залежить від того наскільки
захищеними Наскільки в добробуті
Наскільки в безпеці почуваються наші
діти і з дорослими це працює рівно так
же от якщо ви відчуваєте що вам десь
некомфортно у вас не влізе вже все те що
ми тут хочемо вам зараз Іще
дорозказувати до кінця Цього дня тому на
звичайно важливо звертати увагу на те як
розвиваються соціально-емоційні навички
Андреа шляйхар який дуже багато уваги
приділяє підтримує Україну Він сварить
уже нас весь час за використання терміна
м'які навички каже забудьте його м'які
навички - це вже нові тверді навички це
те Без чого далі вже ми в світі не
поїдемо але якводиться завжди найкраще
коли ми знаходимо певний баланс що
дозволяє зробити дослідження соціаль
емоційноетичного навчання воно показує
нам що сприяє формуванню
соціальноемоційних навичок А що
перешкоджає як ми це можемо для себе
використати для того щоб скорелювати це
з результатами дослідження Піза і
подумати про академічні досягнення ми
можемо накласти і подивитися що в
освітньому процесі на уроках в
підручниках в комунікації з дітьми в
організації освітнього процесу що ми
робимо такого Що заважає нашим дітям
розвивати соціально-емоційні навички і
очевидно треба це або змінити або
прибрати А що допомагає ці
соціально-емоційні навички розвивати
е уже завершилось дослідження
10612 осіб його пройшло 196 закладів
освіти було
залучено весь досвід проведення
дослідження такий же як колеги
розказували на попередній панелі тому що
це дослідження здійснюється в
партнерстві з українським центром
оцінювання якості освіти із державною
службою якості освіти едкемп став
національним центром ее акредитованим
організацію економічного співробітництва
та розвитку для проведення цього
дослідження Що відбувається зараз в
цьому от процесі в підтримці да
накачуванні цього фактично крила е
дослідження соціально-емоційних
навичів уже розпрацьовується так званий
проект який називається школи досен в
чому їхня суть от зараз коли ми
проводимо це дослідження весь
інструментарій він належить організації
економічного співробітництва та розвитку
і ну він просто використовується школи
не мають можливості подивитися ці
опитувальники і поміряти на собі що
побачити свої результати бо результати
всі ми отримуємо в узагальненій картині
от школи до н це будуть заклади освіти
які отримують весь цей інструментарій
зможуть ним користуватися виключно для
свого педколективу для своїх дітей і
розуміти картину конкретно по їхній
школі конкретно по їхньому колективу
буде розроблений це теж згадували пане
руслане бачите ваша ідея ви тільки
озвучили вже реалізується от Як ви гарне
працюєте е буде розроблений онлайн-курс
з навчання соціально-емоційних навичок
нові програми хоча вони вже є
затверджені міністерством
використовуються як курси за вибором от
але будуть доступні в більшою мірою що
ще важливо розпочинається пілотування
соціально-емоційного навчання і програм
у закладах вищої освіти і передусім ми
сфокусовані на закладах вищої
педагогічної освіти тому що для того щоб
допомогти педагогам До речі знаєте що
виявилося у пілотуванні програми
соціально-емоційноетичного навчання яка
йде в Україні з 2019 року ро що у наших
педагогів у нас бо я відношу себе до
цієї когорти є величезна проблема з
відстеженням того що ми відчуваємо у
тілі навіть не на рівні емоцій Хоча з
емоціями В нас теж проблема ми не завжди
можемо озвучити назвати емоцію управляти
емоцією
але абсолютно драматичним є те що наші
педагоги не усвідомлюють зв'язку з тіло
з тілес
не можуть зчитувати те що нам тіло
посилає а це є база для того щоб
стабілізувати се ну цей стан і
перебувати в добробуті в безпеці тому з
пілотування з закладами вищої освіти і
запроваджуватиметься ще одна велика
проблема з соціально-емоційними
навичками поширений мів що їх не можна
вимірювати начебто от тверді навички ми
навчились вимірювати в нас є інструменти
в нас є тести це легко робити як
поміряти навички добробуту
соціально-емоційні і так далі є певні
інструменти спільно з організацією
економічного співробітництва та розвитку
ми їх розробляємо пілотуємо вже зараз у
школах зі зворотнім зв'язком від батьків
колег і дітей але буде ще вимірювання
засобами гри це така інновація і ми її
відплотовуємо зараз на платформі з
подолання освітніх втрат І розривів
повір де вся взаємодія з учнівством буде
побудована не на зовнішні мотивації Ну
ми завжди шукаємо шляхи як мотивувати
дитину як зробити так щоб вона прийшла
на заняття з подолання освітніх втрати
розворивів там залишилася не зіскочила
от то от якраз там ми пілотуємо ці
інструменти і я думаю скоро більше про
них розкажемо Дякую я ще пропоную
впродовж наступної однієї хвилини
закрити питання гендеру з огляду на ваш
досвід зокрема в експертизі стандарту
вже згаданого мною там була така досить
жорстка дискусія авторію стандарту з
навколо ваш ваших
пропозицій але ще трохи шок контенту
перед тим як ви дасте відповідь на це
питання оце речення коли хоча гендерний
розрив із читання трохи скоротився однак
відбулося це лише тому що результати
дівчат знизилися сильніше ніж результати
хлопців І що з цим
робити у дослідженні яке на Ми сьогодні
отримали і величезна вдяка всій команді
яка це зробила і саме дослідження і сам
його фізично оприявлення все на
найвищому рівні там в кількох місцях є
оця фраза що гендерні розриви не
змінилися суттєво за 4тири роки і
Насправді це дуже і дуже сумний
сигнал що це означає це означає що ми
ніяк не до Ну бо нібито як не змінилось
здається що нібито це добре Ні це не
добре це дуже погано що ситуація з
гендерними розривами ніяк не змінилася
бо це означає що ми абсолютно ніяк не
допомагаємо нашим
дітям отримати те що вони мають отримати
як це проявляється І що ми можемо швидко
і легко з цим зробити От недавно тільки
Міністерство освіти і науки проводило
для очільників і очільниць департаментів
відділів освіти обласних і
міських велику подію про те як
впроваджується стратегія гендерної
рівності в освіті була присутня перша
леді було дуже багато цікавих практичних
висступів але що я вам друзі
скажу от Якщо так насправді кожен і
кожна з вас уже сьогодні може зробити
дещо для того щоб коли ми отримаємо
результати наступного дослідження Піза
Ми прочитали там рядочок що в нас
зменшилися гендерні розриви знаєте що це
от от просто від сьогоднішнього дня
припиніть будь ласка говорити і думати в
ключі ти ж дівчинка Ти ж хлопчик а ці
носочки шкарпетки Для кого Для вам для
кого для дівчинки чи для хлопчика а
Математика - це більше чий предмет для
хлопців А я не математик я філолог от
припиніть робити такі
речі і ви побачите як це позитивно буде
впливати тому що насправді оця проблема
яку ми маємо і це величезний розрив там
по кілька років іде розрив між знаннями
дивіться хлопці в нас в математику
більше да а дівчата в читанні це все
наслідок тих соціальних стереотипів в
нашому суспільстві які є які нав'язують
певні моделі поведінки хлопчикам і
дівчаткам і це робимо ми з вами а
відкрию вам величезний
секрет
насправді там де в якійсь діяльності не
задіюються геніталії це дуже мало таких
видів робіт де потрібно використати саме
геніталії чоловічі чи жіночі урешті
немає значення хлопчик чи це дівчинка і
пора припинити нам іти по тих
стереотипах які ми їхали роками а
подумати про наших дітей і це величезний
потенціал насправді якщо ми допоможемо
хлопчикам більше розвивати навички
читання дівчаткам розвивати більше
навички з математики це більше дасть їм
можливість досягати академіч усп і
благополуччя Як вам такий поворот
дякую дякую
Галь в мене до вас два питання які
пов'язані з вашим досвідом в цій сфері
по-перше це оцей актуальний досвід про
втрати і тут вже дуже багато вами
зроблено зокрема вашої громадської
організації у взаємодії з іншими під
парасолькою багато заходів
відбувалося І що нас тут чекає в
найближчому майбутньому у зв'язку з тим
що ви сьогодні почули і надихнулися цим
а також цікаво було б почути про Той
досвід вашої
комунікаційної з вашої комунікаційної
сфери ви багато писали Про Піза 18-го
року і в цьому в порівнянні які аспекти
теперішнього звіту були б
найбільш Аль для того щоб їх
комунікувати там все актуальне все
потрібно комунікувати Дякую Дуже за
запитання і дякую за цей звіт тому що в
мене вдома До сих пір стоїть звіт за
рік мене не чути та чути з вкладочками я
його читаю щось собі відмічаю потім
повертаюся в залежності від того що ми
зараз обговорюємо приміром Минулого року
не Минулого позаминулого року ми
планували проект живі письменники
батькам ми пробували щось зробити для
того щоб зацікавити дітей читанням і я
якраз з посібничка
Пізи виймала інформацію про те як
читання вдома батьків в молодшому віці
впливає на те які потім діти отримують
результати з читецької грамотності е ну
і для нас наприклад всі результати які
там які публікуються в Піз вони дуже
важливі а в частині подолання освітніх
втрат ми скористалися цим Таким чином
оце зараз розповім тому що ми два роки
робимо такі кетчапи для дітей в перший
рік ми робили їх очно в у Львові і в
онлайні а другий рік виключно в онлайні
на платформі mle з окремими матеріалами
і в тому числі з живими уроками з
вчителями тільки з української мови і
математики і в нас був трошки такий
челендж знаєте тому що це були літні
курси е Діти влітку вчилися 40 годин ну
погодьтеся це такий Трошки треба мати
комітмент Хто хоче влітку вчитися всі
хочуть влітку відпочити вати а діти
вчилися і вчилися вони тому що завдання
яке Ми поставили в основу на на
платформу і в принципі все і весь підхід
він був пізаорієнтований тобто я
пам'ятаю коли ми зустрічалися з нашим
методистом Юрієм чеп'юком коли він не
працювував ці матеріали і я тримала
посібничок Пізи кажу Юра нам треба Отакі
завдання Оце отаке воно має бути власне
приблизного плану завдання ми ї розклали
і зворотний зв'язок який ми отримали від
дітей це було те що їм було дуже цікаво
навіть влітку ходити і вчитися е з
української мови е оскільки в нас була
тільки українська мова і
математика ми пішли в частину текстів
тому що проблема з тим що наші діти не
вміють якісно читати і аналізувати
тексти ми знали ще раніше з циклу 2018
року і е все те ядро знань яке ми собі
розклали і зрозуміли що ми би хотіли
щоби Діти опанували ми пок ми зробили
так щоб вони опановували це через тексти
Чесно кажучи реакція була різною деякі
діти казали Господи Це що скільки читати
батьки казали вчителям слухайте А можна
ми тут коми будемо вчити а не оце тексти
читати але ми залишаємося на тому що
оцей текстоцентричний підхід коли діти
все-таки навіть в умовах задач у нас
Іноді були такі умови задач знаєте
написані що дітям було складно зрозуміти
про що тому що там було багато тексту А
тобто ми рухаємось до того що оці
навички во вони є абсолютно ключовими і
вони є супер важливими Але зараз я
знаєте Оленка тут вправу проводила я так
подумаю що я напевно вам зараз розкажу
історію про носорогів Ну але трошечки
пізніше друга річ яку ми запланували яку
Ми зараз робимо вона також важлива саме
в контексті читання це національний
проект пишемо есе а і ми почали над ним
працювати Ще два роки тому до
повномасштабного вторгнення тому що ми
бачили результати ЗНО про те що діти не
вміють Писати ми Звернулися до
американської організації National
writing Project і в них прекрасні
абсолютно прекрасні інструменти але коли
ми їх подивилися Ми зрозуміли що це не
тільки інструменти для навчання письма
але і інструменти для навчання якісного
читання Ну і далі обіцяні носороги
давайте
обіцяніносороги дітей вчать писати
тексти через читання інших текстів
наприклад видається збірка з трьох
текстів про носорогів плюс інфографіка
Ну давайте вже не будемо чіпати
інфографіку ясно що вони завжди всюди її
дають перший текст діти читають про те
що Знаєте от носорогам загрожує
вимирання тому що їхні носи відрізають а
тому що їх потім дорого продають Е Там
наводяться докази про те що Ось бачите
науковці рятують кожного року так багато
насорогів вони рятують тому що вони їм
відрізають Ріг А це ж Не так боляче
насправді ну як ніг таки підрізати
дитина має знайти А ну тобто Вона має
мати своє ставлення Вона має знайти
докази на підтвердження до цієї тези і
посилатись на джерела Хто це каже про що
це йдеться
ну після першого тексту Зазвичай діти
думають Господи треба рятувати носорогів
значить треба більше науковців які
будуть відрізати носорогам роги другий
текст він теж про носорогів але він
трошки про інше він про те А навіщо
носорогам Роги і коли діти його читають
вони такі розуміють Слухайте ну так А це
ж потрібно Тому що тут він може корінці
якісь виколупувати тут воду може
виколупувати А нащо нам мертві нестроги
якщо вони не зможуть собі води
знайти третій текст він уже про льний
контекст він про те що А чому насправді
полюють браконьєри за цими бідними
сорогами Може не треба роги відрізати
може треба взяти у Фокус взагалі
проблему з
цим в роботі з кожним текстом Це просто
один приклад один приклад власне з
методики і ця методика буде в відкритому
доступі ми все опублікуємо десь ближче
до кінця січня тому що ми уклали наші
збірки текстів ми розуміємо знаєте що
якщо американці обговорюють чи можна
пити воду з-під крану тема для нас зараз
не дуже актуальна чи можна пити воду
з-під крану або там чи добре дарувати
дрони знаєте на на свята та Боже хоч би
чим більше Дронів би подарували тобто
їхній контекст відрізняється від нашого
контексту ціком очевидно що ці збірки
вони публіцистичних текстів і ми також
уклали і художніх текстів він буде
зовсім скоро в у відкритому доступі це
власне те що робиться для знаєте як це
для вирішення цих проблем Ми пробуємо ці
всі інструменти в школах в яких наші
вчительки які опрацьовують ці матеріали
працюють то вони каже що все як залізли
в теми з носорогами то потім їм три
уроки на Це пішло дуже подобалося дітям
писати тому що це було нестандартно і
цікаво Але друге питання яке озвучують
нам наші пані вчительки вони такі
дивляться і кажуть пані Галино А куди це
в програму от де нам знайти ці години
читати тексти з носорогами куди його Я
кажу подумаємо про це потім давайте
Спершу ми це опишемо а потім будемо
шукати варіанти
рішень Мені здається що тут потрібно
багато зусиль зріз різних з різних
знаєте там кутків Тобто хтось може
принести інструменти адаптувати і
пропонувати завдання політиків
державотворців дивитися вибирати
поширювати не поширювати тобто
долучатися до цього і друга частина
комунікаційна яку ви про яку ви
запитували Ну давайте чесно от я
відкрила свою стрічку в Фейсбуці мені
навіть мої друзі які журналісти пишуть
Галя це правда Так що довгі тексти люди
вже не будуть читати все скорочу
ну тобто це інформація яка точно зараз
буде і затребувана і я насправді трохи
рада що от багато людей починають
говорити про це і починають звертати
увагу на те що є проблеми з читанням є
проблеми з розумінням великих текстів є
проблеми навіть з способом як Ми
обираємо Аргументи і на що ми
зупиняємося що ми використовуємо що не
використовуємо як побудовані наші про
програми як навчають наші вчителі Хвала
їм і честьми знаємо їх дуже багато
прекрасних Отто в нас же ж в кечапах хто
викладають наші ж прекрасні вчителі і не
тільки в нас а взагалі по всій Україні
тобто ну тут дуже багато матеріалу і
особливо що мене От знаєте так рякає і
засмучує це величезний розрив пов'язаний
соціально економічним станом і
пов'язаний з село і велике місто тобто
оці цифри вони прямо драматичні тому що
до приклад до нас Ми Знаєте біткалися до
нас приходить дитина в кечаб і ми
розуміємо що
наша програма розрахована на ядро знаня
і компетентнісні завдання але довкола
одного року навчання А до нас приходить
дитина з двома роками втрат ну тобто два
роки ри роки Окей що робити з ними як
працювати з ними Тобто це така знаєте
серйозна комплексна проблема І я думаю
що тут буде багато-багато комунікаційних
рішень дякую дякую вам дуже
Юрко я ви теж Ну взагалі громадська
спілка о світорі
в цьому консорціумі громадських
організацій має свою нішу яка пов'язана
з роботою із
учителями і недавно був оцей курс який
ви зробили з колегами з українського
центру оцінювання якості який стосувався
освітніх втрат
також у вас також є великий досвід в
бекграунді принаймні на моїй пам'яті це
з проектом навчаємось разом коли було
багато роботи з керівниками яка зараз
наскільки мені відомо теж буде
перезавантажуватися як на ці всі ваші
плани вплине те що ви
тут Ну те що ви дізналися зі звіту Піза
і
які можливо якийсь є шокконтент від
якого ви відштовхнетеся для того
щоб мотивувати ваших потенційних
слухачів з числа керівників
вчителів Дякую пане роману вітання
колеги
насправді сидів і згадував
приказку Дякую Боже що я не москаль от
сьогодні всі вчителі української
літератури української мови мабуть
відчули на собі якийсь такий докер
можливо Да що щось не так робили і
мабуть вчителі математики по під час
оголошення попередніх результатів Піза
теж відчували якісь докори сумління Що
Мабуть Щось робили не так так і дуже би
хотілося щоби у нас під час оприлюднення
результатів Піза не відбувалося
перекладання Хто наступний та вчителі
природничої галузі Бо насправді маємо
дуже багато викликів і Щиро дякуємо
команді української
інституту українського центру оцінювання
якості освіти за ці результати тому що
маємо власне з чим працювати І мабуть те
що ми маємо вже оприлюднені результати
двох досліджень вони нам допомагають
виробити більше навчальних стратегій для
того аби наступні результати були значно
кращими так і ось власне про виклики і
про дискусію навколо цих викликів
Хотілося би
щоби власне в нашій освітній спільноті
розпочався відкритий діалог про те що
робити з цими результатами які рішення
можуть допомогти нашим вчителям нашим
освітянам І власне е заради кого ми це
все робимо заради кого ми проводимо ці
панелі наші діти і наше майбутнє а один
із викликів з яким ми працюємо вже е
понад півроку - це подолання освітніх
втрат ми аналізували разом з
міжнародними експертами власне до
оприлюднення Піза е всі були одноголосні
в тому що найбільше освітніх втрат в
різних країнах у тому числі і в Україні
це навички письма і читання тому один із
курсів є над яким ми зараз працюємо
разом з великою тренерською кагортою
курс має назву наздоженемо і в цьому
курсі 100 тренерів з усіх регіонів і
куточків нашої України допомагають
вчителям напрацювати конкретні
інструменти які допоможуть вже сьогодні
зараз нашим
учням долати освітні втрати в укриттях
під час повітряних тривог і під час
проведення уроків тому власне це перше
е подивитися на результати і визначити
чітко для нас які ж стратегії Що ми
робимо далі якщо це проблема з
наскрізним вмінням яке задеклароване вже
в двох державних стандартах це читання
зрозуміння то Мабуть це виклик не тільки
для вчителів а це виклик для розробників
модельних програм це виклик для авторів
підручників подивитися на контент нашої
навчальної літератури і зрозуміти де в
цій навчальній літературі місце для
тренування цього наскрізного вміння так
Чи достатньо ми приділяємо уваги на
уроці для того аби навчити дитину читати
і ось ця одвічне перекладання А хто ж з
вчителів буде відповідати за розвиток
навичок читання е насправді це наш
спільний виклик і якщо ми будемо
працювати з цими з цим викликом разом і
кожен вчитель на своєму уроці буде
приділяти час для розвиток цього
наскрізного вміння читання з розумінням
то ми точно матимемо в наступних
результатах значно кращі показники а
також один із викликів з яким ми
сьогодні працюємо разом із тренерською
кагортою разом з з міжнародними
експертами і українськими експертами Це
власне покращення процесу дистанційного
навчання і один із курсів громадської
спілки освіторія дізнайся якраз про
якісне цифрове навчання і про те яким
чином в цьому процесі Ми тренуємо
ключові компетентності і наскрізні
вміння і забігаючи наперед Пан Руслан
сьогодні попередній панелі дуже багато
говорив про компетентнісні завдання один
із наших курсів
якраз нуж базова середня освіта має
цілий модуль як присвячений власне тому
як навчити вчителю
компонувати компетентнісноорієнтовані
завдання тому власне
після сьогоднішньої панельної дискусії
Ми сподіваємося що вчителі таки зможуть
переглянути ці
онлайн-курси з експертами в тому числі
яких ми бачили сьогодні різни панельних
дискусіях практики які точно знають яким
чином компонуються ці завдання на що
потрібно звертати увагу і спільними
зусиллями
це зусилля не тільки вчителів ще раз
Хочу
привернути власне до цього меседжу увагу
це наша синергія синергія авторських
колективів синергія розробників
модельних програм синергія розробників
державного стандарту Попереду ще один
стандарти він також врахує результати
Піза і зокрема вчителі
які озброєні усим тим інструментаріям
зможуть таки допомогти учням сформувати
необхідні наскрізні вміння і в тому
числі читання з розумінням і ми точно
Побачимо в наступних результатах значно
вищі
показники дякую дякую Юрію ми бачимо що
тут всі працюють на випередження ніхто
не чекає результатів Піза для того щоб
якусь політику пропонувати
ее
Олено я завжди дуже уважно ставлюся до
думки яку носієм якої є є батьки сос ця
громадська організація яку ви разом з
Оленою Бондаренко створили свого часу е
і коли відбувається якась така запекла
дискусія з будь-якого освітнього
питання То я туди заглядаю на відміну
від деяких інших спільнот куди заглядати
буває шкі просто то
власне оця ніша ваша ніша ніша з точки
зору
батьків насправді є дуже важлива може
навіть недооцінена
часто я наведу такий приклад коли ми
обговорювали питання
оцінювання то мене трохи шокувала опінія
яку приписують батькам про те що от
мовляв не морочте мені голову цими
вашими
вербальними оцінками скажіть мені мені
чітко Це сім чи вісім от в цьому якесь
таке сакральна віра в числа І отут дуже
багато цифр в цьому звіті Скажіть будь
ласка як ви і ваші ваша спільнота яку ви
лідером якої ви є Що для вас означає цей
звіт ці дані чи вони актуальні для вас і
чи можливо їх треба
розтлумачувати батькам щоб вони Ну не
будучи Проф фахівцями в цій сфері
розуміли це
е ліпше яка з цього може бути користь
для батьків знаєте для батьків це
абсолютно не стало ніяким шоком тому що
ще з перших місяців ковідного періоду ми
всі зрозуміли що все в наших руках все
що ми можемо зробити поки держава буде
там
продумувати плани дій писати
стратегії аналізувати втрати думати на
Ти які їм дослідження проводити Ми
зрозуміли що все в наших руках і вступ
нам неминучий для наших дітей і ми маємо
го готуватися до ЗНО готуватися до
вступу А для цього нам потрібні
репетитори тому я вам скажу відверто що
те що сьогодні ми почули ці результати
ну для нас не стало абсолютно ніяким
шоком ми абсолютно розуміємо всі ці
втрати які є тому що ми кожний день з
нашими дітьми і для вчителів це все
очевидно А знаєте ми інтуїтивно це все
відчуваємо все бачимо і партизанськими
рухами робимо на своїх місцях хто що
може хто може сплачувати кошти він
винаймає репетиторів хтось займається
самостійно з дитиною хтось нічого не
робить і воно так от собі йдеться тому
сказати що шок ні Єдине що б хотілося б
вірніше Я б сказала чого б точно не
хотілося б щоб за результатами Пізи а
2022 Ми не отримали
Е як
дії написання річної якоїсь там
стратегії оголошення року читання
введення додаткового модулю там в ЗНО
вимирювання читання на там за за хвилину
і так далі щоб ми не повернули
секундомери в перший клас
для знаєте рахування кількості слів тому
що читання - це те що дає інформацію дає
розуміння як користатися цією
інформацією Ну от На жаль іншого способу
отримання інформації як читання
спілкування комунікування ну ну поки що
немає Можливо будуть інші варіанти
будемо говорити про
інше Мені сьогодні що відгукнулось і І я
впевнена що батьківська громада вона
абсолютно це сприймає розуміє розуміє що
треба змінювати все що в школах
відбувається з українською літературою і
те що сьогодні сказав пан Артур і те що
говорили сьогодні спеціалісти це
настільки на часі Я просто не розумію що
треба нам зробити щоб ці зміни відбулися
нуно ми стільки говоримо про українську
літературу ну Вибачте вивчення
української літератури закінчується на
вивченні біографії автора який народився
страждав писав помер в принципі і і 30
текстів за рік якщо наприклад в
американській школі це буде два-три
твори на рік і це буде глибинне вивчення
Це дійсно буде читання в голос по ролях
і ще й виставу наприкінці року будуть
поставлять і ще батьків запросять в
актовий зал для того щоб подивитися як
ми опанували і і відчули цей твір
тому з одного боку я насправді дуже
радію що ми говоримо про про те які
проблеми в нас є а з іншого боку Я не
розумію ну от чотири роки ми маємо от ми
мали результати шок Піза з математикою в
18-му році от добре отримали 19 А що ми
зробили ми змінили якісь підходи до
вивчення Ми там підручники змінили Ми
провели там глибинне якесь
там навчання для наших вчителів що ми
зробили і мені не хочеться щоб з
читанням Через роки коли ми будемо
обговорювати інші результати Пізи Ми так
само от сиділи і і визнача да проблеми є
ми тільки говоримо про проблеми для
батьківської спільноти дуже важливо
почути наприклад що тегія мо нам буде
написана наприклад до кінця січня Кабмін
прийме всі рішення до
березня потім все це буде робитися з
подолання цих втрат департаментами
управліннями освіти Шановні батьки 1
вересня Ви отримаєте готове рішення
дайте конкретні
нам дії дайте конкретні строки тому що
ну збиратися обговорювати Що в нас
погане Але добре що ми знаємо що у нас
погано це прекрасно але за кількістю
обговорень ми попереду наприклад в усіх
країнах і мені здається що треба вже
якісь конкретні дії для цього робити а і
батькам потрібні конкретні результати Ну
от я вам скажу наведу такий приклад у
Києві вже кілька канікулярних періодів
Київ пропонує вчителям на тиждень робити
подолання освітніх втрат тобто
запрошувати учнів з певних предметів щоб
вони проходили там опановували ті втрати
які є там наприклад з математи з фізики
з хімії і вчителі це роблять безкоштовно
це ненормальна ситуація а тому що
виходить що немає фінансування на ту
варіативну частину яку можна було б
залучити на оплату вчителям які б могли
в якийсь там певний період проводити ці
заняття
для вирішення питань втрат Мені здається
що ми стільки багато говоримо стільки
знаємо прекрасних маємо прекрасних ідей
Ну може треба якось згуртуватися і щось
зробити бо поки що Ми всі робимо десь
окремо десь на якихось там
А нішах це вистрілює є прекрасні
результати але якогось глобального
прориву так і не про виходи ну дивіться
на моїй пам'яті це вже ее це вже
третя чи четверта панель в різних
форматах в різних аудиторіях за участю
різних громадських організацій причетних
до того чи іншого питання е і тому я
думаю що ми на правильному шляху в
пошуку партнерства громадські
організації серед тут принаймні троє
присутніх які свого часу підписали
консорціум нам би ще і дії від влади
такі
конкретні От дивіться вчителям заплатять
за те що вони будуть допомагати вашим
дітям опановувати освітні втрати в мене
ще є ідея може ми поширимо те що
пропонував Руслан для вчителів навчити
вчителів читати ну повернути вчителів до
читання так скажемо ям'якше коли ми
зміни То може нам може нам щось подібне
спробувати зробити з батьками ж ну якось
не лише орієнтуватися на на на їхніх
дітей але також на батьків щоб їхню ну
скажемо їхню обізнаність доповнити ще
розумінням цих конте асолютно
згодна Зараз ми закі Давай ми в нас ще
буде невеличке тобто для батьків знаєте
От вам експертам для вас важливо
обговорення стратегії плани дій все А
нам конкретні результати і ми дуже
просимо дайте якусь конкретику Зараз ми
завершимо коло з Тетяною і тоді я ще
надам можливість задати питання один
одному або перекласти лист Як так хотіла
е Тетяно я звертаюся до вас як до
директорки громадської організації Go
globл теж помітного гравця в цій сфері з
з великим досвідом в зокрема із питань
е подолання втрат з фокусом на
старшокласниках
на прифронтових
територіях
з акцентом
на залучення різних стиххолдерів до
взаємодії що якраз відповідає цьому
викликові який Олена поставила щойно
перед нами
ее от з вашої точки зору як результати
Піза 22 вплинуть на
стратегії вашої організації
і зокрема на з вашого з огляду на ваш
комунікаційний досвід як це як
громадські організації могли б
комунікувати свою діяльність в цій сфері
яку ми сьогодні обговорюємо для того щоб
це ну посилило наше становище в загалом
в в
суспільстві Так дякую за ваше питання і
за піднятий спектр проблем е вітання
всім і колегам і присутнім в залі хочу
насамперед подякувати
Тані за запрошення і їй і її команді за
те що вони зробили і за те що вони
спромоглися зробити це в під час війни
на початку
ее насправді результати дослідження мене
не здивували е це було очікувано після
ковіду країна в війні це є але хотіло би
почати з
іншого навіть не як директорка
громадської організації А як мама яка
вчора прийшла додому Ввечері побачила
двох дітей одній дев'ять другій 19 та
яка 19 сиділа І намагалася допомогти тій
які дев'ять читати вслух
е чотири листки
тексту І коли я Спочатку думала що вони
якийсь віршик вчать здалеку але коли я
вслухалася я зрозуміла що мені самій
напевно треба разів зодва
прочитати про себе щоб потім я
спромоглася його прочитати
вслух Я вибачаюся але ну треба щось
міняти це я зараз просто от це навіть не
про втрати Це не про показники Пізи це
про сутність того в чому ми живемо і з
чим живуть наші діти і що ми робимо для
того аби це змінилося або не змінилось
це перше тепер повертаю
до роботи тих складових які є так
дійсно
багато вже сьогодні говорили багато
розуміємо що би мало бути і як би мало
бути у нас дійсно дуже багато дискусій
але дуже би хотіло перейти в щоб ми всі
перейшли в практичну площину і не скажу
що не робиться не скажу що нас
Міністерство не чує тому що ми маємо
власний досвід
коли там кілька місяців тому ми як
гогobal зрозуміли що освітні втрати - це
Та ну вже не такий невиправний да на на
той момент не те щоби не виправний Да що
це вже факт з яким нам всім працювати ми
ініціювали обговорення ініціювали
створення робочої групи ми проводили
страцесію і більшість колег були на ній
присутні і віддали в роботу має бути
стратегія подолання освітніх втрат Я
сподіваюся що найближчим часом ми все ж
цю стратегію побачимо і там якраз хують
результати сьогоднішнього дослідження І
саме головне не стратегія Як черговий
папірець а саме головне що ми отримуємо
конкретний інструментарій який нам
дозволить з цим працювати Тому що
питання в насамперед що що мене болить
Да я не скажемо так я не вихідець із
громадської сфери я нещодавно в цьому і
я трошки по-іншому на це все
дивлюся Ми кожен на свої кожен в своїй
сфері кожен на своєму рівні робить на
звичайно багато
е колеги розробки і онлайн і офлайн і
можливості але це все треба поєднати нам
всім треба відкинути свої якісь особисті
свої якісь нарощення свого капіталу
своєї організації Але для того щоб це
зробити нам потрібен вектор і сказати да
нам має сказати держава ось Ми зараз в
пункті А нам Треба рухатися в пункт б
Ось такі інструменти які будуть
сповідувати які будуть спущені в
формальну освіту в неформальну освіту
ось інструментарій і ось ми всі працюємо
тільки Ну у вас є можливість працювати
на прикордонних в прикордонних громадах
будь ласка у вас є прифронтові будь
ласка ви можете на національному рівні
ідіть на національний рівень але тоді ми
будемо чітко розуміти цей інструментарій
і замір і де ми зараз є І куди ми маємо
пройти
ее це не тому що ми там чогось не хочемо
тому що Ну я буду відверта Да ми можемо
скільки завгодно розмовляти але треба
вже щось робити і це робити не тому що
ми не робимо а тому тому що нам треба
поєднувати зусилля нам треба чіткий
Вектор від держави куди ми рухаємося
вони його знають але Ну напевно треба ще
раз щось
прокомунікувати зібрати нас усіх і як то
кажуть знаєте в
роздати по пасочки в в тій пісочниці в
якій тобто не в кожен в своїй
пісочницілоточки розда лопаточки роздати
і і всіх і всіх звести на в одну
пісочницю і зрозуміти куди ми копаємо
Нащо Ми копаємо і що ми будуємо тут цей
ме це це цей конгресхол вже давно вико
виконує руль цієї пісочниці де час від
часу всі збираються Ну так в принципі у
кожного з нас є лопатки і ми тут копаємо
але питання все одно До цього треба
повернутися Куди куди А І думаю що в
кожного із нас є своє розуміння як би то
мало бути Але знову ж таки ми робимо Да
дуже багато і і сенсові речі і дуже
глибокі речі але це все треба поєднати
тому що кожен із нас Ну окей я зараз
кажу що там тільки за останніх чотири
місяці Ми пропрацювали там з 7 000
підлітків Ну але ж в межах країни і тої
проблематики це не та цифра е да яка
потрібна Навіть якщо ми тут зараз всі с
ковпом зберемося Ну нехай це буде там не
знаю ну 270 000 Але знову ж таки в
об'ємах країни це е насправді мало але в
мене ще буде Одна регарка про інше ми
працюємо з підлітками от ці 7 000 власне
про які я сказала це якраз підлітки це
15 16 17 років це старші класи ми зараз
фокусуємося на прикордонних і
прифронтових територіях
особливо 20тикілометрова зона це ну в
принципі діти які ковідні які не
навчалися А зараз із початком війни це
Я навіть не знаю як це Як це назвати Ну
не вчаться вони Ну якщо відверто не
вчаться вони але питання в іншому
Питання в тому що ці діти особливо це
підлітки навіть не тому що вони діти
епохи гаджетів вони діти епохи
соціальних мереж коли вони не читають
вони скролять вони навіть не читають
отих коротеньких два речення які є в
заголовку бо тому що вони це проскролили
якщо там їхні нічого не зачепить з точки
зору графічних елементів чи да чи відео
то то ні але ж Давайте будемо відвертими
Ми не говоримо їхньою мовою ми не
зацікавлюємо ми не пропонуємо їм
інструментарій який дозволить їм е
натиснути і розгорнути ці два речення
або там подивитися або почитати щось ми
говоримо класичними стандартними
інструментами до яких звикли які у нас в
освіті і В стандартах у нас роками
А І це має дуже пряме відношення
до того як діти сприймають читання як
вони
сприймають задачі які їм ставлять
вчителі Я зараз навіть не про онлайн
офлайн про доступ до освіти Ні це от про
в принципі про наші підходи до роботи а
я це точно знаю тому що з усіма цими
дітьми Ми працюємо офлайн Ми шукаємо
можливості ми розуміємо що там
20тикілометрові наприклад зоні у них
немає шансу і немає нормального доступу
до освіти тому ми шукаємо можливості ми
робимо інтенсиви ми їх вивозимо в
безпечні регіони ми приїздимо до них ми
шукаємо можливість і що Ми зрозуміли для
себе от в частині читання те що я писала
Таня що Я приблизно знаю що робити тому
що навіть ще до Да ми розуміли що
читання - це не не їхні муслен сжу не їх
коньок Да і ми шукали а підходи А як
зацікавити тому що в нас в основному в
програмах на долуже освітніх втрат для
наприклад старшої школи да
це українська мова і це математика І от
ми шукали підходи Ми зрозуміли що Єдине
чим ми їх можемо зацікавити це коли ми
будемо говорити їхньою мовою і коли ми
будемо їм кидати
виклик і давати їм завдання не просто
там от да текст прочитати чи переказати
проаналізувати не суть Ми пішли через
проектну діяльність оце їм може бути
цікаво Ну тобто Такі от речі треба
розвивати і ми побачили що з підлітками
це працює
Але хотіла сказати ще не це це от
перша перша тема перша Ремарка яку ви
підняли стосовно
психоемоційного стану наших дітей так от
ми провели дослідження і глибинні
інтерв'ю зробили з підлітками оці девятй
10т 11-ті класи В них немає Вибачте
страху вмерти хоча Ці діти щоденно під
обстрілами
А у них є страх бути нереалізованими у
них є страх бути бідними і ще купа
страхів які не дають їм можливості
розвиватися і це Ну типу коли ми хочемо
да навчити дитину читати а у дитини
страх е навіть не обстрілів в тих умовах
в яких вони живуть А у дитини страх бути
нереалізованим А відповідно бути бідним
то ми маємо розуміти що Ну ми їх ніяк не
зацікавимо і не стануть вони краще
читати і не стануть вони краще показник
які академічні успішності з математики
не покращать ми спочатку маємо щось
зробити щоби стабілізувати дати їм
розвантаження психоемоційне і дати їм
якусь впевненість у собі тому що ми
зараз робимо для для таких дітей і для
особливо це стосується підлітків які
зараз є нашою цільовою аудиторією Ми
зрозуміли що їм треба допомагати
допомагати В
самореалізації от ми зараз
починаємо пілотний проект в трьох
регіонах Сумщина Чернігівщина харківщина
менторство ми йдемо в групове ментерство
Ну тому що ми розуміємо що в масштабах
країни і цих регіонів індивідуальне
ментерство це нереально але будемо
пробувати принаймні це робити тому що ті
діти які проходили через наші інтенсиви
які
працювали з нашими тренерами з
психологами з і менторами це працює це
працює Тому що в них після цього
з'являється впев ність
і буквально там через місяць через
півтора ну це Неймовірні історії коли Ти
отримуєш від них повідомлення Ми
створили молодіжний центр а ми
започаткували громадську організацію
а в наш молодіжний центр двічі вже
попавша Хед з того моменту як ми з вами
бачилися але Нічого ми не здалися ми
зараз пішли в дитячий садочок і ми
будемо там збиратися то ви нам пришлете
книжки а ви нам пришлете там ну
допоможете нам знайти Тото і Тото це про
мотива ці дітей коли вони розуміють що
вони комусь
потрібні ми до речі так всіх наперед
трошки забігаючи запрошу ми 14 грудня
будемо
робити велику виставку відеовиставку
фотовиставку це буде на в Києві на
екранах Гуліверу Ми зібрали 10 історій
життя підлітків в прифронтових і
прикордонних громадах де ми будемо
розказувати про цих тей
е не тому що вони герої або не герої Ні
ми хочемо показати що це діти які хочуть
бути почутими Що це Підлітки Які тут і
зараз розуміють і проживають з нами всі
події які і ми що це Підлітки Які
розуміють що завтра чи післязавтра їм
робити вибір чи їм виїздити з країни Чи
їм залишитися тут куди їм вступати і з
тими знаннями які у них є і з тими
показниками які ми сьогодні почули А я
думаю з того часу вони ще трошки може і
погіршилися навіть більше да тому що
після блекаутів Тобто ми будемо це
робити щоб підняти єдине що от ми
вважаємо що треба піднімати дискус
обговорення в публічній площині серед
громадських організацій Серед лідерів
думок про те що оце покоління зараз да
ее воно потребує уваги вони вони
потребують уваги для вирішення
психоемоційних проблем насамперед щоб
вони розуміли навіщо вони потрібні що їм
робити які у них можливості в цій країні
а тоді буде мотивація тоді буде читання
тоді буде математика Я не кажу що це не
потрібно робити але це головне це дуже
важлива теза на завершення ми з цього
починали в мене ще є одна добра новина
другого кола не буде бо ми свій час уже
вичерпали я хочу подякувати кожній
кожному з вас за те що ви робите за вашу
проактивність за Оцю гру на випередження
в політиці і запрагнення до співпраці Ну
бо співпраця - це є один одне з
наскрізних вмінь нової української школи
що ви ж пам'ятаєте тому от тац теза про
співпрацю прозвучала і про конкретні
справи в співпраці ці конкретні справи
можливі Я дуже дякую
вам я щиро дякую пане Романе щиро дякую
Шановні колеги коліжанки запрошую вас до
за до зали сьогодні дійсно приклади
єдності і ця єдність в різних таких
проявах і в різні способи але всі
говорять про те саме ми маємо разом
робити і навіть сьогодні знаємо що
власне е ми для вас маємо ще останню
презентацію Це Вишенька просто на цьому
величезному торті щастя і радості з
назвою Піза е ця вишинка пов'язано з тим
що ми розуміли що вам у вас стільки
багато даних за сьогодні ви отримали всі
говорять і про Такі дані і про ці Що
складається враження що Піза - Це просто
якийсь абсолютно розірваний набір де
неможливо знайти ні початку ні
завершення ні взагалі про що І власне з
цього приводу ми маємо презентацію Ганни
Бочко це заступниця директора заступниця
начальника відділу українського центру
оцінювання якості освіти але перспектива
є правда українсько українського центру
Я вас прошу пані Ганна і основна ідея її
презентації полягає полягатими в тому
щоби власне
повідомити цілісно системно про ті
результати які є пройтися щодо важливих
питань цих результатів і якщо у вас
будуть
питання на них відповісти для того щоб
не простоювали ці прекрасні білі крісла
Ми будемо тут разом
Вітаю всіх по-перше Дякую Дуже за те що
ви в принципі дочекалися цієї
завершальної презентації Ви дуже віддані
слухачі справді я це ціную розумію
наскільки це все було нелегко наскільки
насичений був цей день
а справді дуже багато спойлерів було з
моєї презентації сьогодні сказано
насправді Мабуть що половина з того що я
хочу розповісти уже було сказано а Але
звичайно моя суть моєї презентації в
тому щоб зробити правильні певно акценти
і можливо
деякі речі трішки пояснити тому що Піза
- це досить непроста непросте
дослідження з досить складною
методологією своїми
особливостями А так одну секундочку
туди
Починаємо ми з цього починаємо теж з тих
речей які вже були сказані але все ж
таки повторюся Піза - Це надзвичайно
масштабне дослідження воно охопило майже
700 000 підлітків із 81ї країни
економіки Іза проводилася у різних
форматах Це був у різних країнах Це був
паперовий або комп'ютерний формат і
звичайно надзвичайна важливість цього
дослідження саме цього циклу пісу
полягає в тому що це перше масштабне
дослідження після початку ковід-19 у
світі і звичайно це перше масштабне
освітн дослідження після початку
повномасштабної війни у
нас було охоплено пізою цього разу 18
регіонів з 27 Тобто Це ті регіони де в
принципі було можливо провести це
дослідження Тетяна Сергіївна розповідала
що там ще були заклади освіти з Дніпра
Ну але на жаль їх результати не було
включено у звіт тому тут ми зараз
говоримо саме про результати 18 регіонів
дослідження нагадаю було проведено у
жовтні 22-го року учасник ми Піза в
Україні стали учні та студенти різних
типів закладів освіти це і
загальносередні школи і
навчально-вихобні комплекси ліцеї
гімназії і професійно-технічні заклади
освіти із особливостей Пізи України
по-перше це перше дослідження яке було в
нас проведено ну саме Піза у
комп'ютерному форматі тому що нагадаю
попередній цикл у нас був проведений в
паперовому форматі провідною галузю
стала математика минулого разу було
читання і також ми мали інноваційну
галузь це креативне мис ня про яке ми
будемо детально обговорювати результати
якої уже
у цієї ве Наступної весни
точніше всі результати в нас доступні у
звітах це наш національний звіт який ви
сьогодні отримали І це два томи чудового
дуже грунтовного міжнародного звіту його
можна знайти на сайті
оср розповім трошки про структуру нашого
звіту національного щоб ви не плуталися
якщо захочете щось знайти цікаве для
себе Отже перший розділ присвячений
загальному огляду украї власне у Піза
Тут розповідається про учасників про те
чому ми беремо участь у Піза як Піза
вписується в систему наших освітніх
досліджень і тому подібне другий розділ
в нас ну це власне основні наші
результати про які вже багато говорилося
третій розділ присвячений добробуту
наших українських підлітків і їхнім
очікуванням четвертий розділ стосується
освітнього середовища і те як це
пов'язане з успішністю учнів Ну і п'ятий
завершальний розділ він присвячений
варіантам політичних рішень для нашої
освітньої системи
крім того наш національний звіт містить
чудові дуже інформативні додатки про те
теж багато про це повторилася говорилася
але повторюся перший додаток А - це в
нас різноманітні дуже цікаві матеріали
про проблеми Українського учнівства в
галузях з математики і читання природи
другий додаток містить переклад
українською мовою цікавих дуже таблиць і
діаграм із міжнародного звіту теж дуже
цікаво ознайомитися Ну і інші додатки
додаток вема має статистичні дані які
можливо теж буде цікаво для більш
ґрунтовного заглиблення у деякі
результати і додатки г гтат мають це
такі більш технічні дані які потрібно
розуміти для інтерпретації результатів
АА в нашому національному звіті ми
порівнюємо результати України із
референтними країнами Це робиться для
того щоб ми не дивилися на всю
сукупність на всю 81 країну учасницю
Піза тому що це дуже мало інформативно
Це нам нічого не ні про що не говорить
тому що надзвичайно різні освітні
системи економічна складова соціальна
культурна все дуже сильно відрізняється
Тому це мало про що нам скаже натомість
якщо ми подивимося оберемо такі країни
які є відносно близькими до нас за
різними показниками або культурними або
економічними історичну споріднаність ми
маємо Це вже буде говорити нам значно
більше ну тобто ми можемо подивитися де
де є ми де є ці країни і можемо зробити
певні висновки і ось ми обрали для
порівняння собі такі шість країн
і Крім того ми будемо порівнювати свої
результати із середнім значенням по
країнам
оср а дуже назвичайно важливим поняттям
те що буде зустрічатися в звіі постійно
це буде поняття рівня сформованості
предметни галузей Піза а Звичайно про це
говорилося Але можливо дещо повторюся а
в Пізі є шість рівнів сформованості
предметних галузей на першому рівні
знаходяться найменш успішні учні на
шостому відповідно на найбільш успішні
учні А при цьому дуже часто будемо ми
згадувати про базовий рівень Він же
рівень два Справа в тому що саме на
цьому на базовому рівні знаходяться учні
які здатні виконувати завдання які
передбачають принаймні мінімальну
підготовленість і спроможність мислити
самостійно і тому коли ми говоримо що
учень досяг рівня два це вже значить що
він подолав певний такий поріг який є
дуже важливи і коли ж ми будемо говорити
про учнів з високим рівнем досягнень то
ми будемо говорити про тих учнів які
досягли рівня п або рівня
шсть кожному рівню відповідає певний
проміжок балів і ось наприклад на цьому
слайді ми бачимо нижню межу балів для
математики тобто наприклад той учень
який здобув 40 420 балів набрав за тест
математики ми вважаємо що він уже
подолав базовий поріг із математики
тобто він уже є мінімально підготовленим
учнем і в світі ви можете знайти
детальну детальний опис того що саме
Кожен з учнів може робити робить знає на
кожному з рівнів сформованості всіх
трьох предметних галузей
Піз також розповім про деякі специфічні
терміни специфічні поняття Пізи які
також часто будуть фігурувати у звіті і
їх важливо розуміти їхню суть а по-перше
часто буде зустрічатися те те що вже
звичайно сьогодні не раз говорилося а от
еквівалент року навчання Тобто ми
говорили про те що маємо різницю між
селом містом еквівалентну там таким-то
таким-то рокам навчаннящо що ж це
значить А справа в тім що у Піз є оце
поняття яке у циклі 22-го року
відповідає 20 тестовим балам відповідно
коли ми говоримо що А пев певна група
учнів відстає від іншої групи учнів на
20 тестових балів ми вважаємо що цей
еквівалент дорівнює одному року навчання
відповідно д це 40 тестових балів і так
далі це умовне позначення і наприклад у
циклі 2018 це було 30 тестових балів
зараз це 20 балів і також надзвичайно
важливе поняття яке
Також ми постійно будемо говорити про
нього в звіті це соціально-економічний
статус показник соціально-економічного
статусу - це такий показник який дає
можливість виявляти групи учнів із
різними передумовами для навчання А тут
коли обраховується цей показник
враховується дуже багато різних факторів
зокрема це культурне тло вдома це
ресурси які має дитина це професія
батьків освіта батьків кар'єрні
очікування учня і так
далі Ну і власне далі про основні
результати нашої
країни ну почнемо з того графіка який ви
вже бачили прокоментую тут ми бачимо
результати України бачимо результати
наших референтних країн бачимо
результати країн оср ми бачимо що три із
наших референтних країн мають вищі
результати за Україну а Три країни
навпаки менші результати за Україну а
при цьому Ми бачимо що наші результати
звичайно нижч за результати оср і
найбільша різниця спостерігається із
читання на дорівнює 48 ба балів з
математики та природи звичайно різниця
також є суттєвою Але дещо нижчою а на
цьому графіку ми можемо подивитися
розподіл рівнів досягнень за предметними
галузями наших учнів і оте що я казала
важливо є оцей показник базового рівня
ми бачимо що в Україні досить значна
частка учнів не досягли навіть базового
рівня сформованості кожної з предметних
галузей в оср ця частка є помітно нижчою
і зновутаки якщо ми подивимося на наші
результати ми бачимо що з математики аж
42% не досягають базового рівня з
читання цей відсоток складає 41
зпіроднич наукових дисциплін дещо менше
- це 34%. при цьому найбільша різниця
якщо порівнювати із результатами оср ми
спостерігаємо саме з
читання Ну і звичайно одне з того що
найбільш важливого дала нам ця Піза - це
можливість порівняти наші результати із
результатами попереднього циклу а
Звичайно вже приводився цей графік тому
я певно хіба можу Повторити ще раз
можливо зі своїми акцентами а справді ми
бачимо падіння з усіх трьох галосей і ми
бачимо що з читання воно знизилося в нас
результати найсильніше Тобто це
еквівалентно двом рокам навчання з
математики ми бачимо падіння на 12 балів
а з природничо-наукових дисциплін 19 але
тут певно варто зробити певну таку теж
ремарку і повідо якби зробити акцент на
тому що з математики наприклад у на в
нас результати як були низькими так вони
низькими лишилися натомість з природи в
нас були помітно вищі результати І
те падіння яке ми зараз бачимо воно не є
настільки суттєвим Тото воно не знижує
аж дуже посутньо наші результати Ну а з
читання зрозуміло ми мали високі
Результати вони були Практично на рівні
природничо наукової грамотності зараз
вже ці
результати досить не досить а дуже
суттєво
знизилося також Піза дає можливість
порівняти результати хлопців та дівчат
АА ми бачимо ми можемо спостерігати
гендерні розриви із двох предметних
галузей це із читання і із математики з
читання ми бачимо гендерний розрив на
користь дівчат вони випереджають хлопців
на 23 бали а з математики цей розрив є
на користь хлопців і складає 10 балів
тобто дещо меншей а з природнич наукових
дисциплін розриву в принципі майже не
спостерігає це менше одного балу Тобто
це не є
суттєво Також ми можемо подивитися на те
як оці гендерні розриви змінилися
впродовж цих чотирьох років ну власне
звичайно ми бачимо падіння результатів і
дівчат і хлопців але що можна цікавого
Виділити це те що ми бачимо певне
скорочення розриву а з з читання А яке
Однак скалося не через те що у нас
хлопці стали краще читати а навпаки
через те що дівчат втрати дівчат Стали
суттєвішими маємо суттєві шетрати саме у
дівчат і через те бачимо таки такий
розрив який насправді нічого позитивного
нам ніякого меседжа позитивного нам не
несе з математики у дівчат теж дещо
сильніше знесилися бали а з природнич
наукових дисциплін відносно однаково
а далі Піза нам дозволяє виміряти оцей
цю сегрегацію пов'язано з
соціально-економічним статусом і якщо ми
подивимося на цей слайд ми бачимо що в
Україні дійсно присутні певні розриви
між учнями із різним рівнем
соціально-економічного статусу тобто тут
ми ба бачимо що Наші учні із низьким
соціально-економічним статусом Вони
мають в 2,8 разів більше шансів не
досягти базового рівня з математики
порівняно з іншими учнями А якщо ми
подивимося порівняємо наші результати з
результатами інших країн то ми бачимо що
в принципі у більшості реферетних країн
цей показник є ще вищим ніж у нас
натомість у словацької республіки
Естонії дещо нижчим
А ми в звіті Піза приділяли дуже багато
уваги тому що власне сьогодні теж уже
обговорювалася це різниця між учнями які
навчаю які проживають у різних типах
закладів освіти Ми дивилися на учнів які
проживають у великих містах маленьких
селах містечках невеликих містах і так
далі Ну І от на цьому графіку Я думаю
тут він є досить таки показовим ми
бачимо кожну нашу школу яка взяла участь
у Пізі кожен цей кругляшочок - це одна
Наша школа І зверху жовтенькі наші школи
- це школи з великих міст і ми бачимо що
в них як високі результати з математики
так у них і високий
соціально-економічний статус тому що поі
по осі ми бачимо розташовані Ці школи за
саме зростанням соціально-економічного
статусу
натомість зелененькі наші крапиночки
Тобто це учні із маленьких сіл Вони
мають зазвичай як значно гірші
результати з математики так і посутньо
нижчий соціально-економічний статус Ну і
зновутаки розриви розриви які і в балах
становлять зчитання еквівалент п'яти
рокам практичного навчання з математики
природничо-наукових дисциплін так само
він є дуже суттєвим
а Аналогічно до попереднього слайду тут
ми бачимо а теж такий розподіл наших
всіх наших шкіл всіх наших учасників за
типами навчальних закладів А ми бачимо
що в нас є ліцей гімназії це наші
жовтенькі кругляшки які учні в яких
мають і суттєво вищ бал з математики і
суттєво вищий соціально-економічний
статус здебільшого і з іншого боку ми
бачимо коледжі професійно-технічні
навчальні заклади і середні школи які
мають як здебільшого нижчі результати з
математики так і нижчий
соціально-економічний статус Тобто та
сама залежність і ми також бачимо що ті
учні які навчаються в ліцеї гімназіях
спеціалізованих школах з одного боку і
ті які навчаються В коледжах технікам
професійно-технічних навчальних закладах
їхні розриви теж є досить суттєвими на
користь звичайно перших ту валент трьом
рокам навчання
приблизно далі переходимо до добробуту
наших українських підлітків це теж дуже
важлива частина того що ми присвятили
цьому справді досить багато уваги з
огляду на всі події і тут потрібно
звичайно сперш розповісти про те як
збиралися ці дані а не в плані того в
якому контексті Це відбувалося але в
плані тому що
А добробут українських підлітків в Піза
досліджується лише за допомогою запитань
анкети
відповідно коли ми говоримо про той чи
той показник добробуту ми говоримо
власне про певні думки певні погляди
певні оцінки наших учнів які звичайно
носять суб'єктивний характер тому
наприклад коли ми говоримо там про
порівняння певних показників між
країнами це не завжди є дуже правильно і
дуже інформативно нам потрібно досить
виважено підходити до порівняння цих
результатів А те що вже сього сьогодні
теж демонструвалося це показник
задоволеності життям як на мене він
досить насправді є цікавим і досить
цікаві маємо знахідки А по-перше ми
бачимо що у нас дівчата порівняно з
хлопцями менше задоволені своїм життям і
крім того таку ж саму закономірність ми
бачимо коли подивимося на учнів із
різними передумовами для навчання Тобто
ми бачимо що ті учні які мають низькі
передумови для навчання тобто низький
соціально-економічний статус їх рівень
задоволеності життя менше посутньо
порівняно з тими хто має високи
соціально економіч ч статус Ну і теж
досить як на мене важливий інформативний
графік це порівняння задоволеності рівня
задоволеності життям наших учнів у 18-му
році і у 22-му році якщо ми на це
подивимося ми бачимо Ну по-перше ми
бачимо насправді що Наші учні досить
таки сильно задоволені своїм життям
Тобто ми не можемо сказати що це низькі
показники абсолютно тобто у нас 50%
учнів кажуть що вони дуже задоволені
своїм життям Але все ж таки якщо ми
подивимося на порівняємо наші ці з
даними минулого циклу ми бачимо досить
суттєве зниження цього показника що
абсолютно звичайно зрозуміло і в той же
час ми бачимо і кількість учнів які
незадоволені своїм життям вона
збільшилася а
також Піза приділяє значну увагу такому
явищу як булінг у закладах освіти і що
ми виявили ми виявили коли подивилися на
це почали досліджувати це питання
виявили що от зараз Україна якщо
подивитися порівняти наші результати
результати референтних країн у нас є не
дуже високим цей показник булінгу в
школі всього 14,7% підлітків у нас а
піддавалися в принципі будь-якому прояву
булінгу на фоні референтних країн Це не
є дуже високим
показником і Крім того ми можемо
побачити що порівняно із 2018 роком цей
показник в нас знизився а тут можна
зробити теж таке нашу інтерпретацію
певно додати а тому що якби не лише Піза
інші дослідження також доводять що
булінг найчастіше зароджується
розповсюджується саме у закладах освіти
а
відповідно досить тривалий час
дистанційного навчання А ми нагадаємо що
дослідження наше проводилося у жовтні
22-го року відповідно діти лише
повернулися у вересні у заклади освіти
тому що до цього не було ніякого
навчання І от ми їх питаємо про ці
випадки булінгу і ми спостерігаємо таку
картину тобто е-а
безумовно оцей зв'язок між
відвідуваністю закладу освіти між
булінгом він
прослідковується а
також теж теж вже про це говорилося
звичайно сьогодні але Піза От такий
цікаві речі досліджує як приналежність
до закладу освіти А ми бачимо що Наші
учні попри все вони показують досить
хороше хороший рівень приналежності До
закладів освіти Тобто їх запитували про
те чи вони почуваються на своє місці чи
вони почуваються комфортно в закладах
освіти чи відчувають підтримку з боку
вчителів чи не почуваються там самотніми
чи мають своїх друзів Там і так далі І
ми бачимо що насправді ці показники в
нас є дуже високими що насправді ну це
дуже хороший показник це справді
позитивно Ну і звичайно ми досліджували
ж як власне оці показники добробута про
які я говорила впливають на успі нуто як
пов'язані з успішністю певний зв'язок
Звичайно є Тобто ми бачимо Що наприклад
ті учні які мають високий рівень
досягнень вони рідше почуваються
задоволеними життям ніж їхні однолітки
із нижчими
досягненнями зрозуміло що ті учні які
стикалися з випадками булінгу їхні
результати є нижчими порівняно з тими
хто з такими проблемами не стикався і в
той же час ті учні які відчувають
приналежність сильну приналежність до
своїх закладів освіти їхні результати з
математики є посутньо
вищими також наших учнів запитували про
те який же яке яке ма вони собі бачать
Який рівень освіти Вони хотіли би
здобути ми бачимо по Україні що у нас
майже половина учнів кажуть що вони
хочуть здобути високий рівень освіти
Тобто це спеціаліст Магістр або ж
кандидат наук але також і Значна частина
учнів хочуть здобути освіту повну
загальну середню або ж рівня молодшого
бакалавра молодшого спеціаліста при
цьому спостерігається і деякі
відмінності між різними групами учнів
так наприклад у нас хлопці Рі ще
планують здобути освіту високого рівня
порівняно з дівчатами і також досить
суттєво відрізняється цей показник у для
учнів з різними передумовами для
навчання тобто учні з високим
соціально-економічним статусом вони
значно частіше говорять про те що хотіли
би здобути освіту високого
рівня далі ми переходимо до питань
пов'язаних з освітнім середовищем
освітнє середовище в пізії передбачає
перш за все ресурси Тобто це людські
ресурси часові ресурси матеріальні
ресурси і тут теж знову ця Ремарка про
те що ми збирали ці дані Піза збирає ці
дані на основі анкетувань керівників
закладів освіти і анкетувань учнів тобто
застороги всі ті самі Тобто ми питаємо
людей Вони відповідають вони говорять
нам свої думки свої погляди і ми
вважаємо це ось цим покабираємо їх всі
показники тому зновутаки порівняння з
іншими країнами є досить умовним його
потрібно робити проводити із
обережністю Отже Почнемо ми з людських
ресурсів
в Україні прослідковується брак
педагогічних кадрів Про це повідомляють
нам керівники закладів освіти тобто в
нас 30% керівників говорять про те що
брак педагогічних кадрів певним чином
впливає на освітній процес при цьому цей
показник в Україні підвищився якщо ми
порівняємо результати з попереднім
циклом підвищився він аж на 10
відсоткових пунктів тобто досить
посутньо звичайно в Україні це Україна
як ми бачимо на фоні референ країн Це не
така країна де це аж настільки суттєва
проблема Проте це також є помітним для
наших керівників а в одночас ми бачимо
що в Україні 42% підлітків в нас
навчається в закладах освіти де
керівники говорять що їхні вчителі
проходять регулярно навчання з
підвищення якісь курси з підвищення
кваліфікації і дуже важливим як на мене
на мене знахідкою є те що порівняно із
циклом 18-го року цей показник у нас
зріс і зріс посутньо зріс на 20%ткох
пунктів тобто Відповідно ми бачимо що і
педагоги зараз більше шукають варіантів
для підвищення кваліфікації і також
певно і збільшився збільшилась і
пропозиція Тобто ми педагоги мають і
більше можливостей для проходження
відповідних курсів
а також Якщо порівняти власне пошукати
цей зв'язок між якістю наявністю і
якістю людських ресурсів і успішністю
учнів він е ми можемо його знайти можемо
говорити про певні залежності Так ми
бачимо що ті підлітки які навчаються в
закладах освіти де вистачає вчителів і
де вони проходять певну підготовку Вони
мають зазвичай більшого і більші бали з
математики А але ж разом із тим
прослідковується інша залежність тобто
ті заклади освіти яких вистачає
педагогів де вони проходять постійно
підвищення кваліфікації це там
зазвичайно вчається учні з вищим
соціально-економічним статусом тобто
оцей показник соціально-економічного
статусу він є теж дуже в ливовим коли ми
говоримо про людські
ресурси далі ми переходимо до розгляду
матеріальних ресурсів і тут можливо буде
дещо лякливим цей графік де ми бачимо
Україну на першому місці серед усіх
референтних країн А коли ми запитували
керівників закладів освіти про те як
Якою мірою впливають проблеми з
навчальними матеріалами з
інфраструктурою на освітній процес ми
бачимо що дуже суттєва кількість
керівників закладів освіти збентежені
Тобто їх бентежи ця проблема вона є Вона
наявна а і звичайно на це варто звертати
увагу але знову таки повертаюся до того
що це думка наших керівників Тобто це не
є якийсь об'єктивний показник ми не
збирали там додаткових даних з цього
приводу ми їх запитали І от ми отримали
Отакі відповіді що звичайно говорить про
те що явно проблема є яку потрібно
вирішують А так само ми бачимо Україну
на першому рісті серед референтних країн
коли ми говоримо про цифрові ресурси їх
брак або ж неналежну низьку якість тут
треба сказати що зновутаки Зрозуміло що
коли ми говоримо про Україну де в
принципі неможливо
функціонування цей показник називається
брак брак цифрових ресурсів або їх
неналежна якість відповідно
це Е тут Ішлося про показник браку або
неналежної якості засобів навчального
призначення це Ось ціі перше це
синенький і зелененькию так Так а
далі це ми запитуємо керівників чи
заважає їм певною мірою така проблема І
вони нам говорять що так заважає Тобто
це є
проблема І так само ми бачимо про
цифрові ресурси теж на думку керівників
це є посутньою проблемою і ми розуміємо
що коли наша освіта дуже сильно залежить
від того чи зможуть в принципі учні
підключатися до уроків чи зможуть
вчителі проводити ці уроки А коли ми
говоримо про дистанційне навчання то
звичайно цифрові ресурси є надзвичайно
важливими і керівники явно Про це
повідомляють Але разом із тим ми у звіті
присвятили частину розділу про про
ресурси саме тому факту що насправді вже
є дуже багато ініціатив які направлені
саме на вирішення цього проблеми
забезпечення навчальних закладів
якісними цифровими ресурсами Тобто це
вже робиться і ну Є надія на те що
проблема буде вирішуватись вирішується
вже насправді а також Піза приділяє
значну увагу часовим ресурсам і зокрема
Піза доводить послідовно те що дошкільна
підготовка учнів Вона має значний вплив
на учнівську успішність в подальшому і
якщо ми подивимося на це питання
А на Україну серед референтних країн ми
бачимо що в Україні не дуже значна
частка учнів тривалий час відвідували е
дошкільні заклади освіти на противагу
більшості референтних країн тобто
наприклад в Естонії це показник
наприклад показник принаймні тих учнів
які відвідували заклади дошкільні
заклади освіти три або більше років він
є посутньо вищим
а також ми дізнавалися власне скільки
часу Наші учні витрачають на виконання
своїх домашніх завдань з математики і ми
бачимо що Україна тут на першому місці
саме за тривалістю тобто Наші учні
викона витрачають на виконання
домашнього завдання досить багато часу і
порівняно з референтними країнами ми
справді в лідерах а крім того ми
порівняли ж Які середні бали мають учні
в залежності від того як довго як
скільки часу вони витрачають на
виконання домашнього завдання і ми
бачимо що найгірші результати є у тих
учнів які витрачають або дуже мало часу
на це або навпаки дуже багато Тобто аж
більше трьох
годин і також ми подивилися на зв'язок
між часовими ресурсами І власне
успішністю з математики справді цей
зв'язок прослідковується і найбільше
суттєво на успішність учнів з математики
впливає те чи пропускали учні заняття
протягом тривалого часу в закладі освіти
тобто тут ми бачимо що навіть після
врахування соціально-економічного
статусу справді ті учні які тривалий час
не відвідували свій заклад Вони мають
суттєво нижчі бали порівняно з іншими
учнями ну власне це основне із
основного але я впевно все ще повторюся
пройдуся ще раз по тому що ми що би ми
дуже хотіли донести до вас усіх
а спочатку знову ж таки ми не проводили
не змогли провести дослідження у всій
Україні і коли ми говоримо про
результати Піза 2022 в Україні ми маємо
на увазі 18 її регіонів відносно
безпечних для того щоб можна було в
принципі реалізувати це
дослідження ці дані є суперважливими для
нас і для світу звичайно але для нас в
першу чергу через те що це перш
масштабне і дуже якісне дослідження яке
показало нам що ми втратили за ці наші
буремні
роки що ми бачимо ми бачимо те що
найбільше
жахливо ці всі події останніх років Вони
мали вплив саме на читацьку грамотність
учнів тобто тут у нас на 15%ідсоткових
пунктів збільшилася кількість тих учнів
які не досягають навіть базового рівня
порівняно з 2018 роком знизилась також
рівень математичної грамотності зараз
він складає відсоток тих учнів які не
досягають базового рівня складає 42%
порівняно із 36 у попередньому циклі з
природничи наукової грамотності наш наші
досягнення звичайно також знизилися але
знизилися не настільки суттєві і саме з
цієї галузі на даний момент Україна має
результати
найвищі
а знову ж таки ми прослідкували гендерні
розриви Ми побачили їх і двох галузей із
читання - це 23 бали на користь дівчат і
з математики - це 10 балів на користь
хлопців при цьому Ми також побачили що
поглибилися розриви між учнів із різними
передумовами до навчання зокрема тими що
проживають у великих містах з одного
боку і у Великих се і у маленьких селах
Перепрошую різниця тут є дійсно дуже
посутньою вона дорівнює 98 балів з
читацької грамотності дещо нище з інших
галузй Але все рівно вона є дуже
суттєвою Тото від чотирьох до п'яти
років
навчань Також ми побачили те що в
Україні залишається дуже актуально
проблема нестачі і недостатньої
кваліфікації педагогічних кадрів але
водночас бачимо і певні позитивні
моменти ми бачимо наприклад що
збільшується досить суттєво а кількість
тих педагогів які зацікавлені в
професійному розвитку які проходять
регулярно курси підвищення кваліфікації
Ну і також доволі високим ми бачимо є
рівень відчуття наших українських
підлітків приналежності до своїх
закладів освіти що безумовно є чудовим
показником це дуже позитивно впливає і
на їх успішність і в принципі на само
почуття Ну і на сам кінець хіба можу
сказати що Піза справді бездонна і її
досліджувати потрібно ще дуже довго і
дуже глибоко і ми безумовно будемо цим
займатися те що ми маємо зараз - це
старт Я дуже сподіваюся що старт
непоганий і він справді може стати таким
гарним підґрунтям для того щоб починати
приймати правильні рішення Дякую я дякую
Гані дорогі друзі дорогі друзі я дякую
вам ви стійкі і
витривалі дякую Гані це був надзвичайно
складний шлях і я дякую команді за те що
ми цей шлях пройшли разом і багато
шляхів попереду нас чекає багато доріг я
бажаю вам всім безпечного дня безпе
чного вечора і ми зустрінемося на нових
майданчиках говоритимемо про те в який
спосіб ми працюємо над тим щоби
результати були кращими успіхів і до
зустрічі український центр з
[оплески]
вами